stay true
I appreciate that
well
I mean
ah
foreign
good morning
it being after nine o'clock we're going
to start the public hearing this morning
if you would all please join me in
saying the Pledge of Allegiance
at this time I'll record uh recognize
the private sponsor
representative Manny
which one
for HB 32 are you here for that
okay speaker shortlist
thank you Mr chairman with my scribbling
I don't
wonder why you had a problem uh knowing
who was going to speak first for the
record my name is Steve Charlotte and I
represent uh Merrimack District 15 which
is Ward one of conquered the village of
Penacook and I'm here this morning Mr
chairman Drew's to introduce to the
committee uh House Bill
32. let me just say is the former chair
of this committee it's nice to come home
again
and I can honestly say am I too happier
she is in the house for on this
committee and I see the committee
welcomes you back thank you oh thanks
um Mr chairman in 1990 uh the federal
government passed the gun free school
zone bill
and um
it was the Assumption of law enforcement
and local school districts that that
bill would cover them in New Hampshire
and a few years ago before then attorney
general Gordon McDonald was elevated to
Chief Justice
he issued an opinion to local law
enforcement that said no you cannot
really enforce the Federal Gun free
school zone bill that has to be done by
federal agents
and so for the past three years we've
been somewhat in a uh gray area as to
what to do
the bill I'm proposing today would be
the New Hampshire's version of gun free
school zone
and let me just say Mr chairman I speak
today is someone who is not empty gun
um
believe it or not I've been a licensed
hunter in New Hampshire for 60 years now
yeah I'm really that old and uh
all during my working career I carried a
firearm three years in the military here
in Vietnam as a conquered police officer
than 26 years with US Marshals
um
I was a past member of the Alderbrook
Sportsman's Club
so
this isn't any anti-gun legislation the
purpose of this is to keep guns out of
school that shouldn't be there
um I tried it in developing this bill
take into mind the fact that when I was
in high school I used to go deer hunting
after school and you bring your gun to
school and go hunt this bill allows for
people to bring a vehicle on the school
grounds with a weapon in it it's just
got to be secured the same with someone
visiting the office they can have their
gun secured in their vehicle and they're
fine
I try to put the penalties as minimum as
I could uh first offense is a B
misdemeanor uh second offense is an aid
misdemeanor
and then if your third time you
obviously don't understand then it go
elevates to a felony
um
I introduced this bill
because I've got
two kids and grandchildren in school my
17 year old daughter is in high school
I'm a 12 year old grandson is in Middle
School
I can't understand
why any responsible gun lawyer and
concern and to any student this season
thinking
is this going to be the day that I die
because the national violence we've all
seen
so Mr Jim and I know you've got a lot of
work today I'm going to end there I hope
the committee will support this bill and
I'd be very glad to answer any questions
I can
representative Manion
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
I don't see any time
restraints on this so if it's two in the
morning and you're driving within a
thousand feet of a school zone this
applies to you as well
if you're driving through a school zone
yeah it doesn't Supply to you as well
within a thousand feet of a school at
say two in the morning I don't see
anything in here that allows it that
restricts it only during school hours
exactly I think a lot of times school
activities can go for great periods of
time uh from High School proms and
dances to basketball games things of
that nature if you're driving through
driving past the school you're fine it's
when you're stopping at the school and
you're going to go you know you're on
actual school property that uh
the law would take effect that you've
got to secure your weapon
it
follow-up thought one follow-up
am I understanding it wrong it says one
at a thousand feet of a school so that
would mean beyond the school's actual
physical property
if you are
in a field or well the bill makes it
exemption for example a local homeowner
or somebody traveling through going from
point A to point B driving by the school
it's when you stop and pop down the
street we've seen that sadly we saw that
in Texas recently with a perpetrator
Pact
probably a quarter of a mile away and
then walk to the school with this long
gun that's when the law would take
effect but if you're going from point A
to point B or if you're a homeowner or a
business then you'd be exempt from this
law
thank you thank you for the question
thank you for your introducing bill this
morning thank you Mr Jim
at this point the chair recognizes Tom
Manion
Mr Tom Mania
thank you representative thank you
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Tom minion I
represent Hillsboro One Pelham I'm here
to testify in opposition to HP 32.
this common expression I use when
discussing why I carry when seconds
count the police are only only minutes
away this bill prohibits the type of
personal rapid response in a crisis
situation anywhere near a school it
creates a publicly advertised soft
target in other states with similar
Provisions this is the exact type of
area where mass shooting events occur
places where there is the least amount
of resistance from law-abiding citizens
that obey these ordinances
the Bill's shifts responsibility of
Defense of life entirely onto law
enforcement and while it's more
comfortable to think that the Vivaldi
Police Department is the only Department
that would wait outside the school for
hours and tase you if you try to enter
to do their job for them I'm not
confident that would be the case
you see Courts at all levels have
repeatedly affirmed that law enforcement
are under no obligation to risk their
lives to save yours or the lives of your
loved ones
I know the reaction to mass shooting
events is to do something and I agree
but this is not the right something to
do the solution to this problem is not
to prevent teachers janitors counselors
or parents from on site from being the
first respond in a crisis situation
frankly I'm of the opinion that the more
teachers that more teachers should take
firearm training and carry
to me it is akin to any other emergency
situation learning the Heimlich maneuver
CPR automatic defibrillator usage
what to do in case of a fire Etc
I don't believe in mandating carry but
administrations being more encouraging
but
for it and including training courses
for those that are interested would be
nothing but beneficial with that I ask
you to itl HP 32 and I'm willing to take
any of your questions
thank you for your testimony this
morning
at this point the chair recognizes
Mr Andrew Schuler and just for anyone
wishing to testify if you have a pink
card please turn it in now and not hold
it to the end
um at this point I'm not going to limit
testimony but if it gets too much I'm
going to have to put a Time cap on them
so that we can all get out of here
before the sun goes down hopefully so if
you have a card please bring it forward
and you may commence thank you
I just want to quickly testify that
Firearms are a source of protection for
kids that may be that are in schools
it's not something kids be afraid of and
position of firearms should be fully
legal in this Camp you know campus uh
with another thought I don't know if you
heard about some of the news of teachers
doing adult content on school campuses
this is a deterrent for that kind of
behavior and also a source of help in
case there is some sort of dirty
Behavior going on in schools that's all
I wanted to say thank you sir
thank you for Testimony
the chair calls William last name starts
with the r the rest I can't decipher
again
sorry push the button
and if you could say your name for the
record William Rogers thank you
Winchester New Hampshire
um I'll tell the sponsor why I would
carry a gun in a safe school zone if I
was going for my grandson or my
granddaughter I'd want to protect them
because it's well documented that quote
unquote safe zones gun-free zones are
targets for criminals because there's no
guns there and they can do what they
want
that is why I would carry a pistol to
pick up my granddaughter or my son or my
grandson or any of them that's why to me
a firearm is just a tool for protection
it's also a tool of enjoyment from
Marksmanship and hunting but in that
case it's for protection that is why I
oppose this Bill thank you for your time
also thank you for everything you do
it's the second day I've been to these
meetings you guys like Saints I don't
know how you do it listen to the the
stuff all day long but thank you I think
my third grade nun would disagree but um
thank you anyway
this printed chair recognizes
uh Mr Brian blackton
I asked itls Bill does this bill
indemnify a person who has a legal right
to be in proximity to a school who may
be a witness to an active shooter
and take appropriate action with his or
her legal firearm to neutralize said
sure
in order to save lives or are they
merely supposed to call 9-1-1 and watch
as Carnage unfolds and do nothing
thank you
thank you for your testimony
at this point the chair calls
skip Mr skip Bernie Marion
[Music]
for the record I'm uh Frederick barrier
skip Frederick Berrien from Exeter New
Hampshire former member of the of the
house and vice chair of the
children's and family law committee
allow me to correct it then the
honorable Mr Frederick
thank you
um and um
I'm a retired pediatrician
eight years ago I testified before the
Commerce and consumer affairs Committee
in the shadow of the massacre of 20
children in Newtown Connecticut
Nicole Hockley mother of Dylan Hockley
was one of the who was one of the six
children who was who was murdered in
2012.
she appeared here before this committee
on that day asking this state to take
action
to prevent a similar episode from
occurring in New Hampshire
the killer in the new Newtown massacre
was born in Exeter
and spent part of his childhood here in
New Hampshire
Cindy hook could have been Main Street
School in Exeter
or any Elementary School here in New
Hampshire
now eight years later what have we done
to reduce the risk of this kind of
school massacre
I say nothing
instead the legislature has voted to
prohibit enforcement of federal
Protections in the case of far arms
threats in New Hampshire schools
our children are educated in fortnite
fortress-like structures
where children practice hiding from
armed Intruders
with a continuation of school shootings
no wonder our children are experienced
experiencing more angst and mental
health deterioration
HB 32 is one of many necessary steps to
acknowledge that there are millions of
guns in this state
some of which can get into the hands
wrong hands and create Mayhem in our
schools
HB 32 provides a modicum of protection
for our children
and may provide our children with
reassurance
that we are looking out for them
HB 32 does not restrict anyone's guns
rights
or accept unschool premises where they
cannot possess a gun
I urgently urge you to vote
OTP on HB 32. thank you
thank you representative
this time the chair calls
The Honorable John Burt
thank you
Mr chairman and fine committee members I
am former representative John Burt I
served 12 years in this house and I'm
taking a small break
Mr chairman
I would guess you would know I'm opposed
to this bill
this bill is not needed
I've had dozens in dozens and dozens of
teachers call me when this bill was
before us when I was serving as a state
representative
and they also oppose this bill because
bottom line we have teachers carrying in
this state
New Hampshire has never had a school
shooting and there's a reason
because the nuts out there understand
that our teachers are carrying guns
also that the citizens are carrying guns
in our schools
so I hope that this bill will be itl
Mr chairman let me tell you about
Parkland Florida
there was a school shooting down there
pretty bad one
it was a gun-free zone
Mr chairman guess what it is today
it's not a gun free zone
they've earned the teachers because they
said they don't ever want to see what
happened that dark day
the teachers in Parkland Florida are
currently carrying guns
it is the only way to protect our
children
because as Parkland Florida in that
school in Texas showed us
the police do not have to go in and
protect the children
they can hide outside
in beat up on the parents that are
trying to get in to protect their
children
so I don't understand how anybody could
vote for this knowing those two schools
had police officers in Parkland Florida
they hid outside
the Texas Vivaldi Texas
they were pushing the parents back not
to go in there to protect their children
as children would be in shop
New Hampshire has never had a school
shooting
and I believe again is because our
teachers and our citizens carry guns in
our schools
we've never had a problem so I don't
know why this bill is needed
but as I said before Mr chairman on the
house floor as a state representative
that I served proudly for 12 years to
fight these bills
what I said
is if this bill passed
there will be a school shooting in New
Hampshire
and there'll be dead children and dead
teachers in the blood of those dead
children and dead teachers will be on
the hands of whoever votes for this
so I hope that every one of you
understands that we don't have a problem
in New Hampshire we're one of the safest
states in the country
so I ask you to itl this and IPL it fast
thank you
thank you for your testimony
this time the chair calls the honorable
Maria Perez
good morning members of the committee
and everyone in the public thank you for
taking the time in common and testify
on this Bill I'm here in support of this
bill let me tell you why
I'm going to give you a little bit
background
I grow I grew up in El Salvador
before I move here
I used to hide and then in my bed
we used to go to school
with white towels anything why just to
try to protect our life
guns violence that was everywhere
when I was six years old and my sister
was seven years old
we went to our school
we find our principal our school
killed in the girl's bathroom
that was the worst traumatized thing
that I ever seen in my life
we find our body in blood everywhere on
the floor
I don't wish any kid
to look through
what we went through
we don't need guns in the schools
or around schools
I can tell you that guns in the school
is not going to make us eat safer
guns around school is going to make us
scared
and for a lot of us who have been
traumatized for things like this is
going to open scars
I'm not here to take away anyone's right
to have a gun
that's not what I wanted to do
but I just want a safer
in a bare environment for the children
and for everyone who have been through
the things that my sister and I went
through
I wish my sister was alive so she can be
here testified like myself but she's not
she passed away 13 years ago
all these cars and traumatized that she
went through
because the guy in violence
she passed away not the way that I wish
I can tell you that she did
but she started using drugs
and then she died from the HIV
but guy in violins it was a scar that
she she had all her life
until she passed away
so I asked the committee to support this
bill
for people like myself and that she's no
longer here she doesn't have a voice
anymore
and for many of us that we still walking
around with the scars thank you so much
the chair recognizes representative J.R
Hall
good morning members of the committee um
someone on the way up said it's
difficult to hear about who's running
the sound system so for those speaking
Yelling to the microphone I guess
um I'm here in opposition to this bill
um for multiple reasons one of which is
it will not address a criminal whose
intent on doing harm the end of the day
adding additional prohibitions on law
abiding citizens will only increase the
risk
of an incident in New Hampshire schools
I think everybody in this room has a
common goal of making sure our children
are safe but this is the wrong way to go
about it
first and foremost whether the
instructor in the classroom wants this
role or not they are the only adult in
the room and if there's a problem they
will be because of proximity the only
the sorry the first responder to any
incident
I had a conversation several years ago
outside of that outside of this Hall
was someone who was vehemently anti-gun
and we had a discussion about whether
teachers should be carrying mace
should be carrying pepper spray and the
reason we had that discussion and the
person agreed that was an appropriate
solution because they both we both
realized
that the first responder in all
situations is the adult in the room when
you have children
this bill as filed will make our schools
more dangerous
or less safe depends how you want to say
it
I would ask that you would IPL this bill
there's no reason for it our schools are
safe there are there are faculty and
staff members who who do carry okay
there are people ready and willing to
respond who live adjacent to schools
and this bill is unnecessary thank you
thank you for your testimony the chair
recognizes Leonard Coro Dr Leonard Coro
thank you very much and thank you for
your work and
trying to uh enhance Public Safety in
our state
uh this bill is a bill to try to make
schools safe
our teachers and our students and
administrators and other people in
schools are really frightened and
anxious kids are anxious I'm a
psychiatrist we see this so often these
days and this is a bill to keep guns out
of schools so we don't have accidents
and we can begin to make our schools as
safe as they can be thank you very much
thank you for your testimony
chair recognizes Mr Timothy Wolfe
thank you Mr Speaker
um I would just like to um voice my
opposition to this uh proposal
um
I certainly understand the intent and I
think we all agree we want to make
schools safer
um I think our minds automatically go to
Columbine areas you know mass shootings
like that
um I I think the
thing that I disagree with with this is
the fact that
we are asking our abiding citizens to do
something not carry a gun in school
which we won't uh if this is passed but
if I was a criminal and I woke up in the
morning and decided that I was going to
inflict harm in a school
um I don't I would have no regard
um which for this so I really do not see
I understand the intent but I think the
I I do not feel as though this is if we
really ask ourselves if we pass this law
today
tomorrow is it going to have a real
impact is this something
that
our children are going to be safer you
know when my son is in school is he less
likely uh to be In Harm's Way if this is
passed and I have to honestly say I
don't believe he will be safer I
actually genuinely feel he will be less
safe because I think in the instance of
people who are doing this type of
heinous crime they have no regard for
the law
and
I know that
their mindset is they want to do
something go down in their last blaze of
glory and I think the immeasurable thing
with a firearm
ownership and and people having firearms
is you don't know who has a firearm and
if there's the thought it doesn't have
to be a firearm there but just the very
thought of there being a firearm is
enough to discourage somebody from going
in there because you're gonna you're
gonna mess up their master plan and and
they traditionally people have gone past
country zones uh like in Aurora Colorado
they went past two movie theaters to go
to the movie theater that had the no gun
sign over it
um in Amherst New Hampshire we had a gun
free zone probably 20 30 years ago with
his big Community got together and they
said we're a gun-free neighborhood they
started getting broken into left right
front center and when they took that
sign down the break-in stopped
um so
um I won't belabor the point but
um I just don't I feel basically we
would be losing I would rather have
somebody uh trying to protect my child I
know there's always you know anytime
Farms involved in defense there's always
you know somebody could get hurt you
know that you don't intend to but I
would rather that than allow evil to
Prevail thank you
thank you for your testimony
and the chair recognizes Dr Johan
good morning members of the committee my
name is Joe Hannon I'm the vice
president for gun owners of New
Hampshire and I'm speaking in opposition
to this bill
um this bill does one thing it makes
criminals out of people who are not
criminals law-abiding citizens uh
someone intent on harming someone or
committing a heinous crime is not going
to be deterred by a sign or a lesser
charge of a misdemeanor or even a class
B felony if someone is going to do that
they're going to do it
um
there's not a lot else to say other than
this is going to hurt people who could
possibly defend themselves in a
situation where their life may depend on
having a firearm with them uh years ago
when there was the shooting in
Connecticut I was actually in my son's
school teaching a few kids volunteering
and I went home saw the new I heard the
news there I went home uh the next week
I went back and they gave me a school
safety briefing on what to do if there's
a shooting
and since I didn't I wasn't an employee
I was a volunteer I didn't have a key to
the room to lock the door so they said I
couldn't lock the door but they covered
the windows and paper and told us to
just line all the kids up against the
wall so they can't see who's in the room
that was our self-defense plan
it was ridiculous for one there were
windows we could have easily gotten out
going to the woods but the bottom line
is we're making uh basically fishing a
barrel with this kind of policy and uh
as a member who was on the uh the school
safety task force back in 2018 one of
the people that was uh there to help
with some of the policies and
recommendations there were a lot of
recommendations and this was not I
believe one of them
um so please I tell this bill and
that's all that needs to be said thank
you
thank you for your testimony
the chair calls Mr John bunkin bunkave
bunker bunker
Mr chairman I have testimony
Mr chairman and committee members
I'm John Bunker I reside in Stratham New
Hampshire and I'm here today to support
Bill 78 32 and 106. I have submitted
written testimony and I'm here to tell
you why I'm here today
last year on April 26th I was driving
back from Maine on a fishing trip
without access to Wi-Fi or radio or cell
service and I heard about the Uvaldi
shootings
that news report left me
angry scared and motivated
angry that we as a nation have failed to
successfully address the public health
epidemics of gun violence
here that my three-year-old
granddaughter would soon be in the
classroom
and motivated to become engaged
in my community in my state
that's why I'm here
I grew up in Concord
I hunted and fish with my dad and my
grandfather
I taught rivalry and gun safety I am
also a parent
a grandparent and a gun owner
in a public health profession
I come to gun violence
issue with respect to the vast majority
of gun owners in this country who are
responsible safe and law-abiding members
of their communities
I've enjoyed a 30-year career in public
health
in healthcare
I hold Masters in doctoral degrees from
the Johns Hopkins University of Public
Health
I have done International and National
Healthcare Consulting for private sector
public sector and non-profit sector
clients
I served for over a decade as the
founding president of new futures
an advocacy organization established by
the New Hampshire charitable Foundation
to reduce substance use disorders in New
Hampshire
after new futures
I served as an associate Dean in the
director of external relations in the
College of health and services at unh
I also serve on several non-profit
boards including Goodwill of Northern
New England
and I was a former board member of
Menominee New Hampshire the National
Alliance of no loans
after extensive study and research on
the epidemic of gun violence in our
country
today I have strong support for this
bill
this bill clarifies that possession of a
discharge of environment and safe school
zone is illegal in Acts age criminal
penalty adds criminal penalties if this
law is violated
I have several other remarks but for the
sake of time I will pass on those
finally I want to share a quote from a
recent editorial that resonated with me
the latest shootings were tragically
inferiorly predictable
so let's ask politicians not just for
lower Flags in moving speeches
but also for a better way to honor the
Dead
an evidence-based slog that saves life
in the handout that I have for you the
testimony I've left you with three
references that I hope might be helpful
for you as you deliberate your vote the
first is from the Rand Corporation it's
on the science of gun violence it's 486
pages but there's a fair amount of
information that might be relevant for
this conversation
I've also given you the link to the
Johns Hopkins gun violence and
prevention policy Institute as well
and there's a terrific article that's
sponsored by the Journal of American
Medicine that also has information that
you might find helpful
thank you for the opportunity to present
my testimony today
thank you for your testimony
and the chair calls J.E simkin and I
would ask anyone who is coming to
testify please make sure you speak into
the mic
the Acoustics in this room are designed
to go that way not this way so if you
could speak right into it it would be
very helpful
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee thank you for giving me an
opportunity to testify I do have
prepared testimony uh which I'll hand in
it covers several bills I figured it was
were tree efficient and less burdensome
to you to have short comments on each
bill but there are obviously Bill
specific comments your testimony that
you're handing in is good for all the
bills but if you could limit your
testimony now to just a bill in front of
us
I thought it was a little again more
efficient I want to
I'd like to hand this in if I may so
that the members can look at a table so
that the members can look at a table of
data
I don't think anyone else will present
these data to you
on the third page of my testimony is a
table of data drawn from the FBI's
uniform crime reports
these data which cover 20 years from
2001 through 2020 show the incidence of
violent crime per 100
000 residents for the New England states
a Time series this long and as I'll
point out so consistent likely is fairly
representative of reality
sometimes data series bounce around a
lot for example gains or losses in jobs
varies widely from month to month these
data annual are very consistent they
show that over this 20-year period the
incidence of violent crime in New
Hampshire with a one-year exception has
been a
among the three lowest incidences
Nationwide
we live
in a very very safe state
second
if you look at the line of data for
Massachusetts it shows that the
incidence of violent crime in
Massachusetts throughout this 20-year
period has been at least twice that of
New Hampshire
I point out for the benefit of those who
may not be familiar with Massachusetts
laws as to Firearms they are voluminous
I deem them nasty and repressive so over
20 years if gun control laws were
beneficial one would have thought
that would be obvious in Massachusetts
because periodically they add to the
volume of their laws
it's brought down the level of violence
there but it's still twice that of New
Hampshire
now to the specifics of
32 House Bill 32 FM
it is so vaguely drawn
that a purpose of it stated or not must
be twin snare those who are unaware
in a small town
a country school zone could cover the
entire town
so I have visions of towns being fenced
off
as East Berlin was from West Berlin in
the bad old days you know you're leaving
New Hampshire you are entering a
prohibited area
okay if we're gonna do that that gives a
person notice I I'm carrying I have to
do a U-turn and go around this town
the Practical impact of this is that
law-abiding folks who have no ill intent
are going to be ensnared
I don't know and I'm not asking now
because it wouldn't be proper how many
members of the committee have actually
litigated against a state
I've done so twice
I hold in my hand
of Massachusetts
temporary non-resident license to carry
firearms it was wrongfully revoked it
was restored to me by order of the
Supreme Judicial Court of Massachusetts
that process took three and a half years
and even with me doing most of the law
research
and drafting pleadings for my attorney's
review and signature cost about 125
thousand dollars
the data in the fiscal note attached to
this bill
come from some other Galaxy
it's the only way I can describe them
the
there's some imaginary rate that
attorneys are deemed to charge it
doesn't correspond to the facts so that
most folks charged under this bill
should you decide to enact it
are either going to be bankrupted or
they'll take a plea because they can't
afford to fight it
that kind of law should not be enacted
not only not here members of the
committee and Mr chairman shouldn't be
enacted anywhere it's a trap
it's going to cause folks to acquire
criminal records
who
didn't have any criminal record
and the cause and the consequences of
that even if they fight it and even if
they succeed
could well be job loss
family problems because of the financial
spring and reputational damage
those who propound this kind of measure
may have Noble intent
the road to hell is paved with Noble
intentions
in conclusion and I'll be happy to take
any questions you may have for me
please do not enact this bill or any
similar
thank you for your testimony this
morning thank you
the chair calls Kimberly Morin
I'm short so this is easy for me my name
is Kimberly Moore and I'm here
representing the women's Defense League
of New Hampshire we are Grassroots all
volunteer woman-run organization who
teaches women in New Hampshire and the
states surrounding how to safely and
accurately shoot firearms this bill does
nothing to stop criminals from going on
to school grounds with Firearms nothing
it's already illegal to go on school
grounds with a firearm unless you have a
pistol revolver license that's federal
law
what this bill does do is stop
law-abiding citizens from protecting
themselves and children from criminals
intent undoing harm
it also makes women who have either left
abusive relationships or have stalkers
unable to protect themselves for the
mere Act of dropping their kids off at
school
the mom who fled to a new city and has
to walk her kids to school but is always
looking over her shoulder for her abuser
or her stalker
will be further victimized by this
legislation if it were to pass
this legislation is written by an
out-of-state organization most of not
all these gun control bills are
and it seeks to solve a problem that
doesn't exist in New Hampshire
and again this bill will not stop
criminals from bringing Firearms onto
school grounds in fact criminals seek
out gun-free zones because they know
their victims will be unable to protect
themselves
please vote in expedient to legislate on
this bill all it does is make Granite
Staters especially women and children
less safe thank you
thank you for your testimony please
refrain from clapping
the chair recognized Mr James gath Noah
yeah free
Daffy
thank you
thanks Jeff
um
this isn't the first time we've seen
this bill it's come up in various forms
in in years past most of you have heard
the same testimony over and over and
over
this bill won't accomplish anything the
only person that can defend you and keep
you safe and your families is you the
Supreme Court's already
come to a decision years ago that the
police have no obligation to defend you
this is settled law
so the only person that can defend you
is you and so you're going to restrict
people's ability to defend themselves
that doesn't make sense I mean how many
states do we have to look at that
already restrict firearms in school
zones and other places which are
keep having school shootings time out
after Time After Time police can't
protect you the laws that you guys pass
can do nothing but punish people after
the fact
this bill will accomplish nothing but
make schools less safe
period end of discussion it's proven in
Liberal state after liberal state if the
if gun control work and keeping guns out
of people's hands then
Chicago New York you know name a city
would be like the safest places in the
world but instead they're the most
dangerous because nobody can defend
themselves from bad people
so what are we going to accomplish by
doing this nothing the structure of the
bill is terrible we've beat this to
death and what disturbs me most is that
the sponsors of the bill keep hearing
the same stuff over and over and we keep
looking at the same bad results in
states that have enacted stuff like this
and yet year after year after a year we
get the same dumb idea presented to us
and I'm sorry to be offensive but that's
a fact I want results I don't want fluff
and this won't accomplish anything
any questions oh one other point
this bill in its structure doesn't
accommodate what if you have a situation
where a parent is walking a child to
school there's no accommodation for that
person to to carry a firearm and take
care of it it's one thing if you have a
car but not everybody drives there are
lots of people that walk their kids to
school so the structure of this bill is
terrible the ideas behind it don't
accomplish anything and it's only going
to make us less safe
any questions
thank you for your testimony have a good
day thank you
the chair calls Nancy Brennan
good morning
my name is Nancy Brennan I'm from where
and I thank you for being here and for
this long day ahead of you
I find it
ironic
and more than a little sad
that in these weeks that we are
discussing this bill there are other
bills being discussed
that would supposedly
keep our kids safe by not letting them
read certain books or
use the bathroom
and yet this
bill that deals with deadly consequences
should have full support
will this bill by itself save all our
children and will it make sure that we
never have a school shooting no it will
not but this bill along with some other
very good legislation such as a piece I
heard I think yesterday on Health Care
Mental Health Care for Kids along with
some of the other bills you're going to
hear today would go a long way in making
a huge difference
I grew up at a time when the hunters
brought their guns you could see them in
the back of the trucks because it was
hunting season and I'm not even sure
they locked their trucks the world is
very different if you doubt it go back
and look at the speech last night and
the angry partisan way we treated each
other it is not the same world and we
need to do something this is one little
piece I am a teacher no longer but once
a teacher always a teacher and with all
due respect to my former representative
who said he had talked to dozens and
dozens of teachers who want to carry
guns I too have talked to dozens and
dozens of teachers here in New Hampshire
and across this country when I was lucky
enough to be a new Hampshire's teacher
of the year and travel and meet with
other teachers and everyone I talked to
agreed we are busy trying to teach the
kids to read and write
we do not want to carry guns in our
classrooms I believe in the Second
Amendment I actually own a gun and I'm a
pretty good shot but I would never have
a gun in my classroom and if you think
it would make a difference
I'm sorry you are terribly terribly
wrong there was a there was a story or a
person who was interviewed when uh Gabby
givers was shot and he was a person a
civilian that was allowed to carry a gun
and he was there and he heard the
gunshots and he said by the time I got
my gun out and tried to figure out who
was shooting who and who I should
protect it was over
if you've ever taught middle school
that's kind of what it feels like
sometimes in a middle school classroom I
would urge you pass this bill pass these
mental health bills and let's begin to
change the narrative there is a poem
called America is a gun a lot of you may
have heard it but it talks about every
country what are they known for wine
cheese this that and every verse ends
with America is a gun let's change the
narrative Let's Make a Difference thank
you
thank you for Testimony the chair
recognizes
Brian Berry
good morning citizens good morning
Representatives
thank you for taking time out of your
day to be here
it's good to see our Republican action
I'm happy
I just want to read briefly from the New
Hampshire Constitution
pot first Bill of Rights Article 2A
bearing of arms all persons have the
right to keep and be our arms in the
fence of themselves their families their
property in the state
their families our families
New Hampshire families
guns are not the answer to the world's
problems and I don't think anyone here
no matter what side Iran believes that
however there are well-documented
instances
whereas firearm stops
another bad person ill intent who has a
firearm or a knife
these had happened in churches
Walmarts and even schools
oftentimes as a school resource officer
that would stop the assailant
now to the best of my recollection we
have not had a school shooting in New
Hampshire thank God Almighty
but criminals don't like challenges
and I'll draw my law enforcement and
Military experience to guarantee you
that
that's why they give up when uniforms
show up
as it was pointed out earlier
officers do not have
a duty to protect you or your family
Society in general
I love our law enforcement and 98 of
them
will step in front of you on me and take
a bullet in defense of us
some woman
as evidenced
and selling the school shootings that
we've seen documented videos
they sit there and wait
and that's unfortunate
does that mean because I'm carrying a
firearm in school legally
that I'm going to be a hero no
does it mean it gives the kids and
teachers and people in that school
fighting chance if I choose to engage
that bad person
yeah
maybe I draw enough fire maybe I get
killed
maybe it gives the kids a chance to get
out
maybe I go down
maybe I stopped them
this bill
I believe isn't as well intentioned we
want safe schools I do believe that I
don't think anyone here is doing
anything
out of spite
although not what they feel pure in
their High
but there is a reality here that evil
exists
it does
some people just want to see the world
burn I've seen it firsthand
there's many good people here today
who have a belief different than mine
that the firearming school would save
the lives of students and teachers and I
respect that
but
I'll bet yeah khalafi from Aroma Joe's
if I was at their child's school and I
took action
whether I fall
or whether I make it
that they'd be happy someone did
something
they gave those kids and those teachers
a chance to escape
we can look back
to the 50s and 60s when they were
shooting teams in schools
if we didn't have the problems we have
now
Society has changed
we need to fix that
mental health is a big deal
but
this bill ladies and gentlemen
respectfully
is not going to cure evil
it will not stop someone who has intent
I want you to think about that please
when you cast your votes for this
thank you for your time
thank you for your testimony
the chair calls Joanna
Brown
thank you all my name is Joanna Brown
from Manchester New Hampshire
I have to drop off my daughter at
Manchester Central High School which is
one of the most highest crime ridden
communities
what's worse is that I have to park in
the back lot in the dark waiting for her
to get from home from the bus from
sporting events
my heels lie I am five feet tall
I cannot defend myself against any
aggressor not one
so if I decide to carry a firearm to
protect myself and my daughters in the
worst city in the state
you're taking away my right to defend
myself and my daughters
you're attacking the wrong people
criminals don't follow laws
they don't follow gun laws they don't
check what the rules are they just do
what they want to do and attack the
people they want to attack when this
urge strikes them I don't know when that
urge is going to be
but I can't protect myself and my
daughters on the dark streets of
Manchester
so I vehemently oppose this Bill thank
you very much
thank you for your testimony again
please refrain some clapping
um the chair calls
Marcel do
I don't know do we
Marcella
if everyone wonders why I'm struggling
it's I promise you I can read it it's
okay it's Marcela duvee thank you a nice
French name
um so my name is Marcella Dube I am a
resident of Amherst New Hampshire I am a
volunteer member of Mom's demand action
we are probably very well known in this
room to many of you we believe in
responsible gun ownership and support
gun owners rights but there are several
instances where we need to have laws and
guidelines to protect our children and
to protect our society there are many
many bills for lots of things this is
only one of many bills it can't just be
this one that protects the kids or
protects our citizens I am reading
testimony on behalf of my dear friend
Gene lute she is a school board member
in the town of Amherst
restoring gun-free school zones to our
state is something that I feel
passionate about my experience as a
school board member of the Souhegan High
School in Amherst for 13 years was
especially embolding because as you know
school board members are entrusted with
maintaining a safe learning environment
for the children and their dis in their
districts in addition to being a board
member I was also on multiple security
study committees over the years
after a year-long study recommendations
were made for how to improve Security in
our schools and I'm going to take a
moment and just mention that after many
many years so Eagan finally got a buzz
in uh door at the front
for many years you could just walk
straight into the front
so that's a and also an important factor
is Security in our schools
unfortunately the state legislature
legislators decision several years ago
to allow people to carry guns into
schools make safety in almost
insurmountable challenge we would have
to create a prison-like environment for
our children in order to ensure that bad
people with guns never entered our
schools this bill to restrict the
possession of dis or discharge of a
firearm in a safe school zone would go a
long way toward protecting our children
and School staff parents need to feel
confident that they are sending their
children to a safe place every day
a federal law on gun-free school zones
is adhered to in a majority of the
states in this country
I believe that we are one of three
exceptions I do hope that this committee
will back HB 32 and its Common Sense
approach to protecting our public school
students and staff from gun violence
thank you
Gene loot
any questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
for having me
okay um this one I'm going to ask you to
come down and fill out the card
um it's somebody wrote bear arms well
that's great I actually need your name
unless that is your name could you come
forward please and fill out the card
with your accurate name
my name is Sir could you oh you want me
to write that yes please it's for the
record
thank you
hello uh ladies and gentlemen dear
legislators
um my name is Kang Liu speaking to Mike
my name is Kang Liu I'm a New Hampshire
right residing in Cheshire County
and I'm here to say that just ask a few
questions isn't it true that the
proposed legislation would not apply to
Law Enforcement Officers carrying
firearms in schools loans during the
performance of their duties of course
it's true doesn't apply to police
officers and isn't it true that these
police officers derive their power from
our constitution to protect us and to
serve us
specifically article 8 of our
constitution says all power residing
originally in and being derived from the
people all the magistrates and officers
of government are our substitutes and
agents
because those statements are true
then the intent and effect of this bill
is unconstitutional on its face since it
would deprive the people of our original
right and power to defend ourselves and
our children
we're still
and even more intolerable is that the
proponents of this bill are working to
deprive us of these rights knowing full
well
that the Supreme Court has concluded
that as a matter of General law the
state does not have an affirmative
obligation to protect an individual
against private violence see the Cheney
versus Winnebago 1989.
this is a government of delegated powers
Supreme within its prescribed sphere
but powerless outside of it in this
country sovereignty resides in the
people and Congress and legislatures can
exercise no power which they have not by
their constitution entrusted to it all
else is withheld if the power is not in
terms granted it does not exist see
Juilliard versus Greenman
1884 a Supreme Court decision thus I
conclude that for facial violations of
Article 2 and article 8 of our New
Hampshire Constitution the Second
Amendment and article 4 section 4 of the
Federal Constitution this bill must fail
thank you very much for your time
if your testimony
the chair calls Xander rice Hawkins
good morning my name is Andrew rice
Hawkins I'm the director of gun sense
New Hampshire a project of Granite State
progress and the convener of the New
Hampshire gun violence prevention
coalition
we support this bill the Federal Gun
free schools act prohibits students from
bringing Firearms into schools and the
gun free school zone act prohibits all
other persons from bringing Firearms
within one thousand feet of school
property unless they are licensed by the
state to carry a firearm while federal
law establishes gun free school zones
with qualifications gaps in state law
and statements from the Attorney
General's office has left school
districts and police departments in
murky water on enforcement and
jeopardizes safe spaces for our children
to learn and grow
this is further Complicated by House
Bill 1178 which Governor sununu signed
into law last summer this seeks to
prevent local and state law enforcement
and school officials from Akron swiftly
in response to the presence of firearms
in our K-12 schools
a bill this afternoon seeks to further
penalize state and local law enforcement
and others for taking quick action to
prevent gun violence
federal state laws ensuring that schools
are gun free and zones have helped make
K-12 schools even safer significantly
reducing gun violence in these places
the claim that gun-free zones invite
mass shootings has been thoroughly
debunked by research showing that the
overwhelming majority nearly 90 percent
of all high fatality gun massacres since
1966 have occurred wholly or partly in
locations where civilian guns were
allowed or there was armed security or
law enforcement present
in fact unarmed School staff have
stopped more active Shooters than
civilians armed with a gun according to
the FBI an FBI study of 160 active
shooter cases from 2000 to 2013 found
that 21 incidents ended after unarmed
citizens restrained the shooter 11 of
those involved unarmed principals
teachers other school staff and students
students
who confronted and restrained the
shooters
and only five of the 160 instances did
the shooting end after armed civilians
exchanged gunfire with the shooters
contrast those five cases with at least
20 reported incidents for the presence
of firearms subjected students to more
Danger
this bill seeks to clarify that our
elementary middle and high schools are
gun free it is critical that this
measure passes the student or adult
brings a firearm into a school in New
Hampshire right now local school
districts and police departments face
real challenges in how to appropriately
deal with it in light of the major gaps
in state law
the vast majority of States 47 of them
and the District of Columbia prohibit
carrying or possessing a firearm on K-12
school property or events only Hawaii
New Hampshire and Wyoming do not
this problem will only go worse as time
passes and especially now that more
people realize how loose the gun laws
are in New Hampshire in fact in the past
some gun groups have even hosted
seminars encouraging people to carry
firearms in our schools
this includes our classrooms Elementary
School recitals High School football
games you name it
right now someone could bring a gun into
a school and unless they issue threats
or start shooting students
school and local law enforcement are
essentially being told to stand down
in fact some have been told to contact a
regional ETF agent instead of taking
immediate action
this means that schools are forced to
monitor the situation directing School
personnel and resources away from the
primary job of teaching our children
if the person carrying the gun does
indeed do harm and start shooting there
will be a lot of second guessing as to
what should have been done from the
start
this is the major liability in public
relations crisis for our schools at best
and we all know what a worst case
scenario means
let's get the second guessing and
Empower our local school districts and
police departments to take action from
the start without this bill they won't
have all the options they can rely on to
help deter a dangerous situation before
it becomes a deadly one guns do not
belong in our schools
we urge the committee to vote House Bill
32 ought to pass to protect our students
our Educators and our learning
environments thank you and I'm happy to
take questions
representative Reed
thank you Mr chairman can you just give
me the source of the data for the safety
of the school free zones yep um Daniel
Webster firearms and college campuses
research evidence and policy
implications a study of active shooter
incidents in the United States between
2000 2013 from the FBI and the Giffords
Law Center to prevent gun violence has a
comprehensive overview of firearms laws
in the state and federal level I will
send this by email with the hyperlink
thank you but I'd said it out loud for
anybody else interested thank you very
much for the question thank you very
much thank you for your testimony thank
you
happen
the chair calls Penny Dean and it
appears on microphone situation has
improved so now you can stand at a
reasonable distance from the microphone
I'm not sure what reasonable distance is
but I guess this is it my name is Penny
Dean I'm from Concord I'm a private
attorney in private practice
and my mother always told me you only
have one time to make a good first
impression
and I would ask that you itl this bill
we can start from the beginning where
it's a train wreck whoever wrote it
didn't bother to proofread or even look
at what they were saying because if you
look at page one line five they
reference RSA 189 13A Roman 5.
and it says specifically specifically
and if the offenses enumerated in that
statute well that statute is actually a
provision about checking the criminal
records for volunteers
so my basic premise is when you start
going through this and you look at it
it's gobbledygook that doesn't make
sense
because I look at things like a mechanic
how do you actually do these things this
doesn't work
you had one speaker say this bill would
go a long way and I agree it would go a
really long way and make a difference a
bad difference
and we're looking at Death By A Thousand
Cuts when it comes to people who hate
guns they don't think guns belong
anywhere
and they don't like people that carry
guns and they always want a reason that
you shouldn't have guns
when you look at this bill
and again we'd look back at practicality
even if you wanted to enforce this bill
if you look at page one line 19.
they talk about the grounds of a school
zone
idify any of you including the
facilities manager for Concord schools
to show me the property lines of all the
conquered property in the school's use
I bet they can't I know they can't I can
tell you that my property my back
property backs up with the crystal
McCullough School
and they had some trees years ago that
grew over my property and so I was
willing to pay for tree cutters because
I wanted the branches fun
it took me hours and hours and days and
days to get to the facilities manager
who gave me permission he said hey if
you're paying bring in your people and
cut away but the gist of it is how are
we going to find out who's in charge to
get permission to do these things this
was talking about a tree cutting a
couple branches from a tree and you're
asking for permission to carry guns
through there for shooting
for hunting for whatever hunting season
will be over five years from now before
you get to the right person and then you
ask for those who are politically
what I call incorrect they're going to
say well why can't they walk around this
way why do they got to walk over the
school property with our gun and what
gun are they going to carry and when are
they going to be there no no no no no no
no
as a practical matter if this passes
there won't be any people walking across
the back of school property
but more importantly you're going to
have people getting arrested this is one
of these bills I call it make Work bill
for lawyers
and I already got plenty of work I don't
need more work I'm very grateful for
that but what you're talking about here
is innocent people getting ensnared not
knowing where the boundaries are
and I guess we talk about people
carrying firearms in school zones
what's the problem we haven't had a
problem in New Hampshire in decades with
this Pro with those issues so just
because someone doesn't like Firearms
just because someone's carrying a
firearm doesn't mean they're going to do
anything illegal and they talk about
monitoring the situation why are you
monitoring any situation they're not
bothering anybody you need to leave them
alone
the other thing when you go to page two
of the bill
and again we go back to look but paid um
lines 19 20 21 22.
we go back to about authorized by school
authorities
does that mean
this facilities manager does that mean
the principal of the school where it's
located does that mean the school
superintendent
who does that mean so even again if I
thought I were ever so lucky to get the
permission of any one of these any more
anti-gun people do you honestly think
you know and then we get this what I
call Turf War the principle gives me
permission and the school's
superintendent says he wasn't authorized
to give you that permission
so you're looking to set people up to
fail you're looking to set up innocent
gun owners to fail but the bottom
substantive thing that you should ask
yourself beyond the horrible mechanics
of this someone who drafted this was not
a litigator or lawyer I can tell you
that
is that do we need this the answer is we
absolutely don't need it and it's
abysmal and it's really offensive to the
Constitution
it's really offensive you look at people
like this and you say what are you
trying to do here we've had enough
instances in this country going back
that when people have had firearms in
school zones lawful people they've been
able to stop things they've been able to
stop Carnage so I respectfully say that
this bill is a horrible piece of
grafting a horrible piece of legislation
it's not mechanically sound or legally
sound
and it will result in a lot of
litigation but more importantly is we
have constitutional rights and they
Trump all of this Balderdash of what
people don't like maybe people feel
uncomfortable if I wear pink do I not
have to wear blue
you know so I really am happy to answer
mechanical questions but again this is a
drafting nightmare
your testimony thank you
does anyone else who has not turned in a
pink card
they're being run I hereby close the
public hearing
on HP 32 the committee will take a
10-minute bio break
thank you
what's that
be careful
okay
foreign
we're going to resume hearings if
everyone could please take their seats
and halter conversations
at this point I am opening to public
hearing on HB
5'9 and I recognize the prime sponsor
representative
thank you Mr chair
[Music]
ing to everyone
um
guns don't kill people
people do
now that's an expression that's been
used for many many years I'm not sure I
ever got my mind around it
um
and yet I've come to recognize the truth
of that
that guns don't
automatically kill people it's the
people who aim those guns
and that's why I believe that this bill
is so incredibly important that is
supported by more than 90 percent of our
constituents
and by 90
of gun owners that is responsible gun
owners and by Republicans
slightly higher percentage of Democrats
support it but when you're up at 90
that's in the stratosphere
so I think it's pretty clear that this
is a bill that is supported by people
who want to protect the right of
responsible people to own guns
this bill addresses to knock the gun but
the person who wants to use the gun
I'm not an expert on guns but I do know
a fair amount about people
most of them including gun owners
care about gun safety
this bill is to protect us from those
very few
who purchase and misuse guns for reasons
that no responsible gun owner or caring
citizen would support to harm others and
perhaps in some cases to harm themselves
never having purchased a gun I was
interested to learn how easy it would be
to purchase a gun legally do you know
that there are 59
000 unique gun dealers licensed gun
dealers across the country that's four
times as many as there are McDonald's
and nearly twice as many as U.S post
Offices nobody lives more than 10 miles
from a licensed gun dealer you don't
have to travel far
to be able to legally buy a gun and
legally participate in a background
check
this bill requires commercial Firearms
sales in New Hampshire
to be processed through a licensed
Firearms dealer the bull does close what
is referred to as the Charleston
loophole
that is the
referring to what happened in Charleston
before one of the most egregious
massacres and that is someone who would
not have passed the background check
was permitted to have a gun because it
took more than three days
for the report to come back
this bill provides
a way to wait until that report comes
back
um and I think that's that's important
also you will see that I've submitted an
amendment
when the bill was present was printed
the analysis said
this bill excludes private
non-commercial sales or transfers
between individuals provided neither
individual is prohibited from owning or
possessing a firearm under state or
federal law
somehow when the bill was printed
the analysis was there but that specific
language was omitted from the bill and
so I have submitted the amendment that
adds those uh important words and I
believe it's been distributed to the
entire Committee in a recent
conversation I had with one of our
colleagues he talked about the fact that
he wanted to be able to give a gun to
his child
he has trained the child
in gun safety and he felt that the child
was of an age where he would be
responsible he would be able to do that
in this
in the language in this bill
um our distinguished former colleague
Catherine Rogers brought expertise
in her repeated efforts to have a
background check bill become law
there will be highly knowledgeable
Witnesses who will follow me and be
better able to answer almost all
questions but I am here not as a gun
owner not as an opponent of gun
ownership but representing the
overwhelming percentage of New Hampshire
citizens including almost all gun owners
who believe in responsible gun ownership
background checks makes sense they use
existing systems that are familiar to
Legal gun purchases and they save lives
I hope this will be the year that this
committee will support
a carefully drawn background check bill
and I thank you very much via courtesy
thank you for your testimony this
morning
the chair calls Dr johannan and I'm
going to start telling you who's on Deck
just so we can move it along after that
we'll be representative John Burke
that idea courtesy of the
sergeant-at-arms thank you wherever you
are
good morning again my name is Joe Hannon
Gunners of New Hampshire vice president
I'm in opposition to this bill as usual
um
for start I mean for starters I'd like
to just say that this bill the main
issue is the definition of commercial
sale
um now I haven't read the amendment
that's proposed so I'll just speak to
the bill at hand but commercial sales
transfer of ownership of a firearm
including but not limited to a sale gift
or exchange
uh that's not the definition of a
commercial sale anywhere else uh you
know Commerce involves selling for
profit livelihood uh even the federal
definition of of Commerce and related to
Firearms has nothing to do with
individual trade or gifting to a spouse
or family members things like that or
even individual Private Sales which are
legal at the federal level someone has
to engage in the
business of selling Firearms so if
someone is just liquidating their
collection or selling a few Firearms or
not making a profit and let me tell you
that if you're selling a used firearm
it's generally not profitable
um so it doesn't meet the definition of
Commerce it's almost I don't want to go
to the length level of saying it's news
new speak but it's definitely changing
the definition of a word to make people
think differently about not just this
bill but
everything that we're going to be
governed by do we want to change the
definition of Commerce not just for this
but for everything anything can be
commercial commercial trade if this is
allowed
um
let's see um
there's another problem I'm not really
sure if it's
um
it's impossible to be addressed but it
says
when someone has to sell they have to go
to a
licensed dealer and
the seller is allowed to give them the
firearm the background check will be
performed on the buyer
and the show process the sale as if they
were the seller so now the dealer is a
temporary seller they're acting as if
they're the seller at that point
uh the person who originally dropped the
gun off is allowed to remove the firearm
from business premises from the license
dealer while the background check for
the purchaser is being conducted so if
they're waiting for it to to be
conducted they can remove it and take it
home do whatever they want with it
but when the background check for the
seller the purchaser is completed they
must return to complete the transaction
if it's illegally allowed to present go
forward but if not it must be returned
to the original seller however there's
nothing that says that they can give it
back to the seller without having to do
another background check now it makes
sense I think most people would think
that's what would happen but it says
if the dealer cannot legally deliver the
firearm to the buyer the dealer shall
return the firearm to the seller after
ensuring compliance while state and
federal laws applicable to the transfer
and the transfer to the buyers shall not
take place well according to the first
definition of commercial firearm the
commercial sales that's any transfer of
ownership the ownership went to the
dealer and they have to act as if
they're the seller and now you've got to
do another background check to get your
own firearm back from the dealer
so that is one one issue
um another thing is this is an indirect
tax on gun owners in a sense you know
people with without a significant means
you know 25 or 50 for a background check
processing fee can be quite significant
uh so this disproportionately affects
people that don't have the means uh to
easily throw away 25 or 50 for every
transaction on a firearm
uh it's we know we've heard it's
federally illegal to sell a firearm to a
felon and other categories of
individuals who are not allowed to
possess a firearm this bill does nothing
to do
um anything to prevent legal law-abiding
gun owners from getting a firearm what
it does is it increases the value of the
black market you've now made the black
market more lucrative and I ask you not
to do that and please I tell this bill
thank you for your testimony
the chair calls representative John Burr
and next up will be Timothy wolf
thank you Mr chairman and fine committee
members again I am former representative
John Burt
I represented uh Goffstown wear and dear
and for 12 years
Mr chairman House Bill 59 seeks to
categorize all sales as commercial
but a gift or a loan between friends
family neighbors is not a commercial
sale it is a private transaction that
should stay private the government has
no business telling people how to or
when to dispose of personal property Mr
chairman I am against this bill we have
seen this bill many many times we kill
it every time
it's not needed the federal government
already does background checks
it works
and I like how they delete the records
of my records within 24 hours
now from what I understand that they
will make a database here in New
Hampshire but there is an RSA that they
have to follow also to delete it but why
have two databases I don't think we need
two databases on what guns I buy
thank you and please oppose this thank
you
thank you for your testimony the chair
calls Mr Timothy wolf and up next will
be James Caffrey
thank you
um
I'm just a little bit uh just to stay
simply a little confused by the language
on the bill and not really sure of its
uh necessity given the laws that we
already have
um that you know first of all when you
purchase a firearm they mentioned
commercial firearm transactions so I
assume that means anything through a
dealer
um I don't know of any dealer in the
state that you can go to and not do a
background check if they're doing things
as they should which everyone that I
know does
um my understanding I might be enough
dealers here probably could correct me
if I'm wrong but if you're buying a
pistol it generally goes to the federal
government and they do it FBI does a
national incident you know the
background checked on you and uh if it's
um you know the uh or I'm not sure if
it's the other way around and the other
one goes to the state police but you're
going to go through the background check
um so I don't really see if we're
already doing this already I'm not
really understanding the need for this
at all because I feel like it's already
being done
um why would we use more of our state's
resources for something that's our we're
already doing
um it just doesn't make any sense
um the other thing is just in the
beginning of this
um under the analysis it says the bill
excludes private non-commercial sales
or transfers between individuals
provided neither individual is
prohibited from owning or possessing a
firearm under state or federal law
so it's saying that it excludes
individuals
um
and then further down
under the purpose
uh it talks about the the commercial
firearm sales
um and then a little further down it the
background under the definitions
actually where I got confused it talks
about
um the commercial sale uh is not limited
to uh sale exchange or gift
um so if you're if you're gifting it to
somebody
how is that
um
I I just I don't understand the language
for commercial here
um you know because they actually have
an individual listed under definitions
means a natural person so is there a
conflict between the exclusion under
analysis and
um the definitions uh they they seem
seem I I might be missing something here
but it seems like there's a conflict in
in the in the in in the definitions and
the exclusion under the analysis
um
and um
other than that um
that's all I have thank you thank you
for your testimony chair calls
um James gaffery
and up next will be je simpkin sorry for
my handwriting the last name's Gaffney
um
the bill as it's written
is poorly written we've dealt with the
same language or intent multiple times
has been voted down each time
this bill seems to be a little more
special than previous versions and that
it attempts to tell me that the sky is
green and the grass is blue
in stating that a private transaction
between two individuals is somehow a
commercial
activity are we then going to to apply
that same standard to every transaction
whether it's it pertains to a firearm or
any other inanimate object no of course
we're not so why would we do it in this
special occasion
murders illegal
saw it's illegal
we have innumerable laws to to that say
various things are illegal and so now
we're going to criminalize
a the transaction of some inanimate
object it's not going to accomplish
anything
all it does is make more work for people
it makes more it more difficult for two
individuals to to perform a transaction
uh there should be a cost analysis of
this right first and foremost what is it
going to add to the the burden of two
individuals to to engage in a
transaction a private transaction
what about all the trips back and forth
between the FFL between these two people
should there also be an environmental
impact study
I'm not trying to be ridiculous I'm
trying to to point out the obvious
problems with this bill and the fact
that it's not going to accomplish
anything
thank you very much
thank you for your testimony the chair
calls je simpkin and up next will be
John uh Tom Manion
good morning Mr chairman of members of
the committee thank you for giving me an
opportunity to testify I make it my
mission to put before you things that
probably you would not otherwise hear
so some disclosures I'm federally
licensed Firearms dealer I've been so
for a few months short of 40 years 30 of
them in New Hampshire
I personally do background checks
that is to say I'm the fellow who picks
up the phone
and calls the New Hampshire State Police
gun line or the FBI Nick Center so I
know with some Precision how the process
works
background checks are a Consumer Fraud I
heard prior testimony that 90 of
Americans support them
may be true no Source was cited for the
data
okay so here are some foundational facts
as at the end of 2020 there were in the
United States approximately
454 million firearms
that data point is from U.S Department
of Justice
Firearms Commerce in the United States
issues of
2000 and
2020 sorry 2022 5 May
so there is a far more
than one firearm for every U.S resident
including infants who usually don't own
much and we hope they don't own firearms
my point is real simple
anything so numerous
mainly concealable can not be controlled
the effort is for doomed
to pursue it is akin to doing what was
done in the ex-soviet union where it was
thought if all factory farm mine Forest
etc etc output
is governed by quotas set by planners
sitting in offices in Moscow
we will eliminate waste we will be super
efficient and we will overtake the
capitalists
I have little background in this realm I
used to lecture Russian and Soviet
studies at University level
well they pursued this they committed a
genocide in order to break opposition to
this approach to managing the economy
and as the evidence mounted that this
approach made Soviet citizens poorer not
richer they doubled down
eventually the Soviet Union went
bankrupt
so my point is there are some ideas that
get a really strong grip but they're
flawed
and the approach the idea that
background checks stop bad folks from
getting weapons is such a flawed idea
now here's some data
I'll preface it by a statement that the
federal authorities do almost nothing to
stop bad folks from getting weapons
the attempt by someone
to get a weapon from a dealer
and to lie in the process is a federal
felony
specifically it is a violation of 18 U.S
code section 922 small a 6.
this felony is punishable by a fine up
to ten thousand dollars and or
a prison sentence sorry a sentence up to
10 years in federal prison and or a fine
up to 250
000 dollars
you could say that's a pretty good
punishment
here's the problem
the feds rarely prosecute those who lie
here's some data points from 2010
of
000 denials there were 62 prosecutions
fast forward 2018
government accountability office study
of 12
000 denials referred for investigation
there were count them you'll have to
take off one shoot 12 prosecutions
in short the feds do not enforce
criminal penalties on those who lie to
dealers
and these penalties have been on the
books
if memory serves since 1968.
quick things have changed since 2018
possible but here's why I doubt it if
you looked at the number of cases
bioed by U.S attorneys Nationwide
for them to have prosecuted
those mentioned in the GAO study 12 000
plus denials
the U.S attorneys would have little time
to prosecute other cases
Espionage Securities fraud
etc etc
in short
the feds don't only not prosecute those
who lie to dealers if they did
that's pretty much the only crime that
would actually
be prosecuted by federal prosecutors we
simply don't have the infrastructure the
human infrastructure
to
prosecute bad guys who try to get
weapons
in short
I understand that a lot of folks put
Faith in background checks they are as
much in error as were the Soviets who
insisted that making all output
decisions in Moscow would make Soviet
citizens wealthier
they were simply wrong history has
judged the fact that the folks now in
charge of the Soviet Union look back
with longing to the Soviet era
is proof positive that some ideas
plainly failed
have an unbreakable grip
background checks is one of those ideas
unless
we meaning the taxpayers are willing to
hire enough Federal prosecutors and
build enough prison space
to put behind bars those who lie
in closing in the 20 plus years that
we've had background checks they began
in November 1998
I'm a small-scale dealer I've had two
persons deny
both of whom were not murderers bank
robbers or racists
because I was told by the reviewing
Authority
have your customer call us meaning to
the gun line and we will tell them
what
matter in their record makes them
disqualified one of the two men then in
his 40s
said
I will pursue this
six months later he comes back told me
it took me nineteen hundred dollars in
attorney's fees the matters been cleared
up
I had held the firearmed for him no
cause to him
I redid the background check he passed
he left with his weapon the other fellow
never heard from him maybe he didn't
have that kind of money don't know
said what
if the other fellow wanted a weapon
there are hundreds of millions of them
quantitatively this Pro
it's for there's an idea that I've just
shown you quantitatively is nonsense
and I respectfully suggest
you do not enact it because to enact it
would suggest
that you the members of the committee
and the members of this honorable house
cannot do basic math
I have not only no reason to think you
can do basic math I suspect you can do
it without using a calculator
thank you I'll be happy to take any
questions
um I add only that in my submitted
testimony the data sources are provided
you can look at them with your own eyes
thank you for that and thank you for
your testimony
thank you the chair calls Tom mannion
and up next will be state representative
The Honorable Maria Perez
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Tom minion I
represent Hillsboro One Pelham I'm here
to testify an opposition of HP 59. to
start this bill opens with the
definition of commercial sales including
gifts so let me run a hypothetical about
you my father is raising his son way up
in Coos County they go hunting target
shooting on weekends the sun is raised
in a gun friendly environment is very
well trained and capable thanks to the
great mentorship of his father when the
father deemed his son to be mature
enough the father gives his son the
rifle they've been using for years as a
birthday gift same as his father did
before him it's now the sons to own his
eyes light up with Wonder Smiles spreads
across his face and dad is now guilty of
a Class B misdemeanor thanks to HB 59
tough break pops since FFL firearm
purchases are already subject to
background checks I want to highlight
what I believe to be unconstitutional an
ATF Form 4473 if we're going to be lap
dogs to arbitrary Federal rules I think
I should elaborate exactly what that
entails and how it's a violation granted
standards rights I want to credit
Liberty block for bringing this in my
attention and all the times I've
completed this form I hit the specific
legal language the ATF uses never popped
out of me question 11b states are you
under indictment or information in court
for a felony or any other crime which a
judge could imprison you for more than
one year
indictment not guilty of so no trial no
jury no conviction no sentence yet
answering yes would prohibit purchase of
a firearm so you're being denied Liberty
without due process of law and being
forced to Bear witness against yourself
this violates the Fifth Amendment
question 11c covers conviction so 11b
sticks out unnecessary and
unconstitutional uh and subject to
felony convictions of firearms uh for
and Firearm ownership is in a bill that
this committee's already heard and I've
already submitted testimony for uh
question 11 e states are you an unlawful
user of or addicted to marijuana or
antidepressant stimulant narcotic drug
or other controlled substance and then
in bold it says warning the use or
possession of marijuana remains unlawful
under federal law regardless of whether
it's been legalized or decriminalized
for medical recreational purposes in the
state where you reside
the question is dubiously worded and it
says unlawful user and immediately
reminds you that any use of marijuana is
unlawful this question as with all these
violates fifth amendment protection
against bearing witness against oneself
as well as the 10th Amendment which
gives off all authority not explicitly
outlined in the U.S Constitution of the
states which includes drugs
uh this goes on uh but I would argue
that we shouldn't be completing these
forms in the first place let alone
making a dad-run one for gifting a son
to his rifle criminals do not acquire
arms through these means they steal them
or federal agencies like those during
the Obama Administration Ferry them to
Mexico and they come back and sit into
circulation that way I also uh it also
won't be long before the newly
taliban-owned arms make their way around
the planet I'm certain the dod didn't
run background checks on those guys
before leaving them guns I asked there's
a committee to itl HB 59 I'm willing to
take any questions
thank you for your testimony
the chair calls representative Perez and
up next will be
Andrew Schiller
thank you honorable members of the
committee again my name is Mr
representative Maria Perez I represent
District 43 in Milford
I'm here in support of this field
I'm tired here
so many comments about wasting time
wasting money
let me tell you something
Tire money
means a lot
for big things of domestic violence
none of the people who's been coming and
testified previously have said anything
or care about people like myself
I'm a Survivor of domestic violence
ma'am uh represent please don't
characterize the testimony of other
people speak to your own yeah that's
fine thank you I'm a Survivor of
domestic violence
and let me tell you
me buying a gun it doesn't make me feel
safer
it means
I'm gonna cause more harm to the world
than say myself
I don't feel safer
how many times I've been told every time
that my name is been targeted online my
information my personal personal
information has been put online my name
has been targeted so many times
that doesn't mean that I'm gonna go and
buy a gun just to feel safer and for the
people who say this is wasting time and
money and they don't have the money to
pay
if they have the money to buy a gun
even if that was the gift the person who
give you the gift have enough money to
buy the gun they should have the money
to provide you money to go through the
background chip
I asked this committee to support this
bill
in office in us we see an upcoming
violence did not passing this bill is
creating more unsafe world
but big things like myself thank you so
much
thank you for your testimony the chair
recognizes Andrew Schiller and up next
will be representative Janine otter
hey thank you
um I just want to make a comment
um the rights delayed is a right
infringed and given forcing the
background checks on all commercial
sales can potentially add unforeseen
delays that the customer may have no
control over and therefore cannot
exercise their rights for nothing of
their own doing
um I also remember uh somebody mentioned
uh marijuana use there was a recent
Supreme Court ruling saying marijuana
users cannot be denied uh Firearms so
just more further proof that uh the
background the forcing the background
check is is not a good thing and
therefore this bill should be ideal
thank you
thank you for your testimony chair
recognizes representative Genie nodder
up next will be Theresa Grinnell
hello Mr chairman good morning committee
members for the record I'm Janine notter
I represent the town of Merrimack
Hillsboro 12.
I promised my constituents that I would
defend and protect the Second Amendment
and I'm here today for the people who
voted for me
you're hearing bills all day long that
pertain to the Second Amendment and I'm
here to ask you to itl every single one
of them that infringes on our rights to
bear arms thank you
thank you for your
brief but succinct testimony
um chair calls Teresa Grinnell and up
next will be William Rosen I think
hi there thank you for the time to speak
my name is Therese Grinnell I'm a
registered nurse foster mom from Loudon
New Hampshire many of you know that my
first amendment was violated severely on
October 13th of 2021 at the executive
council meeting where I was arrested for
uttering the word amen I am still
awaiting my trial date after six
hearings with zero evidence that I made
any such word
our second amendment by our forefathers
was to protect our first
I can't help but see people jump from
high-rise buildings in China where my
exchange students came from and told me
what it was like in their country to
know that our forefathers put our Second
Amendment there to protect us from a
government that comes in to violate our
rights
I'm now aware that if my husband and I
go and purchase a couple of guns it gets
reported to our chief of police in our
town
it's registered why is it registered
we've already seen the ATF knock on
doors to say hey I just want to make
sure those two guns you just bought they
actually went to you can we take a look
at them why is the government taking a
list of who's burying arms
our forefathers gave us that right to
protect us from becoming China or North
Korea we need to understand our history
we care about our children our future we
need to make sure that we're able to
protect ourselves and I'm here to tell
you after living through the Rodney King
riots in East L.A while I was in college
at Azusa Pacific when things go bad they
go bad very very quickly
and the people who are going to do
criminal activity with a firearm are not
the ones that are going to go somewhere
where they have to have a background
check
there is a way with our open borders for
people to very easily get their hands on
the firearm show up at a school show up
at a polling place do whatever the heck
they want to do
and you're only penalizing those of us
that are trying to protect this country
you took a note to preserve our
constitution
each and every one of you
I don't want a child to be in a shooting
I feel as though my children my two
little boys would be safer if I knew
that there was someone at their public
school that was a responsible gun owner
that if something happened they could
protect those children quicker than
police and the EMS could get there
we've already seen our state troopers
come tap me on the shoulder four of them
tell me to come to the back of the room
put me into the back of a Paddy Wagon
make me urinate in front of the glass
wall in front of grown men
for doing nothing
if they can do that by our governor
sununu who I voted for
please do not let us become China do not
let us become North Korea
our children deserve America that our
forefathers fought for
I would ask you to oppose anything
table anything that comes up to you
today that violates our rights as
law-abiding citizens to safely have a
firearm
without any sort of government overreach
or infringement or to be on a list where
I'm going to get tapped on the shoulder
and told to get into a Paddy Wagon
because I'm there trying to protect my
family from a government that's gone
sideways that's what our forefathers
wanted for each and every one of us God
bless each of you for your time serving
our our legislative body and our
citizens
thank you for your testimony any
questions
okay thank you
the chair calls William Rosen
and up next will be Leonard Dr Leonard
Cohen
don't see anybody else so
I I think my penmanship got me again
yeah I think I butchered your Lane
Knoxville William Rogers
sorry about that
um this bill seems like a solution
looking for a problem
frankly I was confused by it because I
thought it covered just commercial sales
but then you look it calls a private
sale a commercial sale all commercial
sales are already under federal
background checks private sale that says
it's going to exempt it I don't
understand I'm not as smart as
Representatives 10 of them but I don't
understand it's confusing to me so I'll
I'll trust your judgment because you
guys are obviously a lot smarter than me
and can figure it out so thank you
thank you for that
chair calls Dr Cohen and up next will be
Brian Blackman
so I have some written testimony which I
would like to give to
me
this bill like
six of the other guild build gun bills
today
are a response to a problem that exists
in the United States
this is not
we do not have the safety in the United
States
that Norway
and Great Britain and France and Germany
and every other
civilized Western Society has we have
more than 25 times the gun violence of
those other
Democratic countries
why does this exist
partly or mostly it exists because we
don't have common sense
gun was
doesn't it make sense
that this particular bill
if a person wants to buy a gun that they
pass a background check
why is that so unreasonable I don't
understand
the background check Bill exists to
prevent people
who have committed felonies and have
other reasons to not purchase a gun
we've heard it before
seventy percent ninety percent of the
citizens in this country want reasonable
gun laws
but the reason that we don't is that
politics rather than the will of the
people
interferes with reasonable Common Sense
gun laws
so
about gum
it takes a person and a gun
that's the equation
in order to reduce the very
significant gun violence in this country
we have to attack both
the person
and the easy availability of guns
now I represent the New Hampshire
Medical Society and the New Hampshire
Psychiatric Society
the reason I'm standing here is that
this is a lane
where we as Physicians
occupy
we take care of the people who are
injured
or killed and come to our emergency
rooms
if they're still alive
we operate on them and try to save them
there are so many
horrible injuries
as well as deaths every year every day
more than 120
people die of gun violence every day in
the United States it's unconscionable
and every reasonable gun law that comes
before you
ought to be passed so that we can do
something about this
so
the background check law is really the
Bedrock of
of reasonable gun laws it's a simple law
it requires people who want to have a
gun
to pass certain requirements that
they're safe
to have a gun that's all
thank you from
listening to my testimony does anybody
have any questions
thank you for your testimony
chair recognizes
um Mr Brian Blackman and up at next will
be Brian Berry
I ask you to itl this bill as I started
reading the analysis
I was very happy I was doing my job as
an FFL really really well
and it looked like at first glance
somebody just cut and pasted part of the
ATF rules to tell me what to do
until I got to this bill excludes
private non-commercial sales or
transfers between individuals provided
neither individual is prohibited from
owning or possessing a firearm under
state of federal law
and this is where it gets a little
fuzzy for me
as far as the definition of commercial
sale
it says
ownership of a firearm including but not
limited to a sale exchange or gift
that's not commercial
and on the front here it says this
excludes private non-commercial sales
that's a conflict to me
except when you get to number two it
says if neither party to perspective
Firearms transactions is it is a
licensed Firearms dealer
the parties to the transaction shall
commit shall complete the commercial
sale through a license Firearms dealer
what you're doing in this basically
is making all private sales commercial
that's all that's happening here I
already do background checks I actually
do a lot of private party background
checks
but this is forcing people
to do
Private Sales as commercial sales
and to me that's nothing more at
blocking and tracking Private Sales
and noted in number six in the bill mail
order sales are now required to go
through an FFL
they do now there's no need for that to
be written in there we already do that
and under Section
6 2A that is a violation of federal law
because once an FFL takes possession of
a firearm it puts it in their Bone book
that gun doesn't leave their possession
doesn't leave that door until the next
check is done
So for anybody
to think that they're going to give an
acapella gun then walk out the door with
it they're crazy it's not going to
happen
it's a federal it's it's a against
federal law
and all you're doing at that point is
making FFL deals criminals that's all
that does
as far as criminal penalties under RSA
159 f
or 1A of this
proposed Bill criminal deterrence of a
Class B misdemeanor is a joke if you're
trying to appear tough on crime
considering consensual Act of public sex
carries a stiffer penalty than that
in my opinion this bill would be found
to be unconstitutional
unconstitutional and maybe the office
should know the requirements of being an
FFL
and this bill also makes a private sale
commercial in one direct contradiction
to the private sale description in House
Bill 351 FN if you compare the two bills
they they contradict each other
please itl this Bill thank you
thank you for your testimony
Brian Mary and up next will be Kimberly
Moore
good morning everyone again whoa
you did fix that problem huh
how's it going
I'd like to draw your attention to New
Hampshire state constitution
going to go down to Article 2 B right to
privacy
and individuals right to live free
through governmental intrusion in
private our personal information is
natural essential or inherent
our constitution
as is pointed out prior by some other
testimony there are problems with the
federal background check
that's for another day
let's talk about New Hampshire
the analysis of 59
shows that this bill requires commercial
firearm sales or transfers in this state
to be subject to a criminal background
check and providing criminal penalty for
a violation
the bill excludes private non-commercial
sales or transfers between individuals
provided neither individual is
prohibited from owning or possessing a
firearm under the state of federal law
sounds reasonable right
as was pointed out already
commercial CL definition I don't get
rehashed out you guys right get that
down
but on page two line three
Roman numeral two
if neither party is through a
prospective Firearms transaction is a
licensed Firearms dealer
the parties to the transaction shall
complete the commercial sale
through a licensed Firearms deal as
follows
shop
what should shall words matter
this does eliminate Private Sales
and it contradicts the analysis on the
front page of it
I would like if you could please
respectfully read that when you have a
chance and and see if if I'm
a little bit off there
we already know that in a private sale
we are responsible to make sure we know
who the person is we're selling to
to make sure that person isn't a
prohibited person that falls on us
already it's already in law
and and that's common sense
I wouldn't come up to someone like oh
yeah flea market by a gun sure see you
later
most responsible citizens who own guns
and sell guns and buy guns look for
something a little more definitive
do you have a PNR license with you
do you have your state ID can I see
those please
okay let's do a transaction together
take a picture of it fully document it
where good if something happens
the federal government provides for
transactions
to be put through the system
on Private Sales as well they encourage
it hey you met off
website X if you are hey you know what
let's go to a gun store and do this the
right way
all right I don't know who you are we
just met online
these steps are already in place
but this isn't going to prevent
a criminal
from obtaining a gun illegally the way
criminal still
it won't
I think we have a little bit of
government intrusion to our lives now
a little more than I like
I don't think that
we the citizenry as a whole should be
penalized
for the crimes I feel
let's focus on the people who are doing
the wrong things let's bring them the
task let's get them in the system
let's have them
realize the consequences of their
actions
instead of being leaning on them all the
time and understanding and yeah okay
you're a criminal you're doing it you
know what you're doing
ladies and gentlemen I oppose this
background checks exist already in two
forms federally next at the state level
through the gun line
the gun Line's a good idea because
it will
show prohibited person status on the
state level quicker than it would get
into the federal system
that's not a bad thing
and the federal background check system
works I've had the Niles I'm an active
FFL by the way next level Firearms so
I'm speaking from current experience
it works
it's not perfect
some of the language in the federal
portions on a 4473 I don't like
but as far as this Private Sales
I think that's
just being a dead hustle honestly guys
and I will take questions if people want
to come by and get me I'm right here
hard to miss and thank you for your time
thank you we appreciate your testimony
and your availability uh the chair
recognizes Kimberly Morin and up next
will be
um Xander rice Hawkins
this legislation written by a California
gun control organization many years ago
we've had fun with this bill every year
for at least 10 years maybe more hasn't
changed much over the years it was
resurrected from the depths of hell with
a few changes in language but with the
same results it will harm those who seek
gun safety training other than at Big
corporations who have gun shops in their
training facilities
at the women's Defense League we provide
gun safety training to women every year
and have trained hundreds of women and
girls since 2014. because we aren't a
licensed FFL dealer according to this
legislation we have to get background
checks on each of these women before
every class
as an all volunteer organization this
isn't physically feasible or possible
any students who take training sign a
waiver that states they are not a
prohibited person this California gun
control legislation doesn't find that
acceptable
this legislation will do nothing to stop
criminals from seeking illegal Firearms
but will do everything to stop
law-abiding citizens from seeking gun
safety training to protect themselves
from criminals especially women
we ask that you vote in expedient to
legislate on House Bill 59 so that women
will continue to get gun safety training
and will not be further victimized and
for the record all commercial firearm
dealers have to perform background
checks according to federal law
thank you
thank you for your testimony the chair
recognizes gender ice Hawkins and up Max
will be Penny Dean
hello again my name is Andrew rice
Hawkins I'm the director of gun sense
New Hampshire a project of Granite State
progress and a member of the New
Hampshire gun violence prevention
coalition
we are here today in support of this
bill
it is important for states to explore
options to prevent or reduce gun
violence in our communities this bill
would require background checks for all
firearm sales helping keep guns out of
the hands of felons and domestic abusers
and other prohibited persons
let's talk for a minute about how
background checks work under the federal
birdie act criminal background checks
must be conducted on individuals before
a firearm may be purchased from a
federally licensed dealer manufacturer
importer sometimes referred to as ffls
as you've heard today in New Hampshire
background checks on handgun purchases
are conducted by the New Hampshire
Department of Safety and background
checks on Long guns are conducted by the
FBI's National instant background check
a criminal background check system or
Nix
since the Brady act through January 31st
2023 just under 446 million applications
for firearm transfers or permits were
subject to background checks
a study of the Brady act from its
Inception in 1999 through 2010 found
that
118 million applications for firearm
transfers or permits were subject to
background checks and about 2.1 million
2.1 million applications or 1.8 percent
were denied a Department of Justice
study of those applications found that a
felony conviction or indictment was the
most common reason to deny an
application during FBI 63 or state 50.7
percent of background checks domestic
abusers attempting to purchase guns
accounted for the second most common
reason of denials during those federal
background checks at 15.5 percent or in
state at 13.2 percent of the background
checks conducted
where are we in New Hampshire
last month New Hampshire conducted
over 10 000 mixed background checks to
keep guns out of the hands of felons
domestic abusers and other prohibited
persons
last year they did around 133 000
throughout the year these are real
numbers in an important public safety
check but gun sold in Hampshire through
Private Sales at gun shows online or the
classifieds do not currently require a
background check
requiring a background check every
single time a gun is sold is effective
in keeping guns out of the hands of
those who should not have them
this bill does that and it just makes
sense responsible gun owners should not
put guns in the hands of people that
they do not know or do not know well
enough to know whether they are
prohibited from possessing or owning a
firearm
under this bill of gun sales including
online sales would require criminal
background check through a federally
licensed dealer using the same
background check system already used in
all dealer sales
it defines these as a transfer of
ownership of a firearm including but not
limited to a sale exchange or gift
transfers and exchanges are included
because it is not uncommon for a firearm
to be traded rather than sold for
financial value
this bill would help keep guns out of
the hands of dangerous criminals and
save lives
an overwhelming 9 out of 10 Granite
State or support closing background
check loopholes including a majority of
gun owners and NRA members
what's more this bill closes what is
known as the Charleston loophole
under federal law a licensed dealer May
proceed with the sale with firearm after
three business daily days the mandated
background check has not yet been
completed and there's no confirmation
that the purchaser is legally permitted
to have firearms we have seen how this
tragedy plays out
according to a fiscal note at the end of
a similar bill in 2014 an estimated 33
000 gun sales in New Hampshire did not
go through the background checks process
the previous year
we don't have a lot of data on this this
is why I'm citing a 2014 piece in the
fiscal note and we would love to see an
updated piece in the in the other build
this morning our office looked on
Armslist which advertises itself as an
online Firearms Marketplace there are
over 80 firearms for sale or trade in
New Hampshire alone
the website has a disclaimer at advising
users to follow all federal and state
Firearms laws
that is it
you have to click a button saying yes
I'm allowed to purchase a gun no
questions asked no background check
there is no guaranteed individual seller
will require one there is however a
disclaimer alleviating the company and
its owners from any liability
it's high time we had a conversation
about who can easily buy firearms in New
Hampshire
this bill does not affect law abiding
New Hampshire gun owners selling and
trading guns between friends and family
as long as no one is prohibited to own
or possess a firearm it express
expressly prohibits a gun registry we
ask for your support and I'm happy to
take any questions
chair calls Miss Penny Dean and up next
will be
something you'll have to tell me how to
pronounce it
kriya sakakini thank you that's okay
my name is Penny Dean still and I'm
still a Concord attorney and I'd like
you to itl this bill for several reasons
and I always believe in starting in the
basement when you're doing an analysis
and the first thing is like a fish story
this bill has come back again and again
and again
we heard years ago that 50 to 55 percent
of gun owners support it and then we
heard it 60 and we heard 70 I heard 90
percent
and here's where I come from if I bring
you studies or data I give you clear
sources
of where I get those facts or data from
and everyone knows that where the study
is conducted matter was it conducted
outside of Sarah Brady supporters for
handgun violence or was it you know
conducted outside an NRA convention
those things matter
and I think you hear a variety of
numbers but I think what matters is we
elected a majority of Republican
legislature and if everybody wanted gun
control in the state I think there'd be
400 plus Dems in here don't have that so
I think that speaks but when you talk
about this bill itself specifically
I want to talk about what I call
wrongful denials when we talk about how
many are denied
I make a good amount of my living and
quite frankly a lot of the free time I
do for people doing wrongful denials you
don't know how often a person said I had
one most recently said oh your client
has felony convictions
I said Gee that's funny I've got
certificates of annulment from the
Superior Court
oh well we didn't get those entered
and so what you have last time I heard
and I've heard different numbers so I
don't pertain to represent to you the
exact number between a hundred and
seventy thousand and two hundred and
twenty thousand superior court records
and court records that are not whether
they be entered or entered correctly or
reconciled whoops with the New Hampshire
criminal records database and I don't
claim to know what one of those numbers
are right I've heard different
variations of them over the past four or
five years but I will bet you a nickel
you're talking about well over a hundred
thousand records and what you have are
human beings entering data and with
human beings human beings make errors
and so many many many gun denials that
either delays or quite frankly outright
denials that come from the New Hampshire
State Police gun line are based on bad
data and I'm not cracking on the gum
line here I'm saying that it's based on
bad data and those people are lawfully
entitled to buy firearms
but what you have happening is think
about the average working man it
sometimes takes me I most recently took
pity on a man and did one of the many
freebie cases I do it took me 10 hours
of my time to straighten out the fact
that he was able to buy a gun he was
denied they said he had felonies once we
looked into it two things had happened
the gun line had not entered annulments
that he had
and there's a fee that a lot of people
don't understand I put together a two to
three page letter explaining to clients
how the annulment process works because
it's not clear
it took me a long time to put that
letter together and at the end of a
process when the average person gets a
certificate of annulment from the court
signed by a judge they think they can go
out and buy a gun they got a certificate
of a Noma from a judge well if you don't
pay the state police a hundred dollars
to enter in their system after that you
can't buy a gun because your annulment
isn't entered even though you have that
piece of paper from a judge now if you
have a lawyer like me who is known to be
anal you're going to know that and I'm
going to hold your hand to the very end
but there's
some people who do annulments on their
own they're poor or they think they can
handle it themselves or there's other of
my colleagues who I hate to admit don't
do a job that I would be proud to do
but however you look at it there's many
many wrongful denials that's number one
and that's huge
because if you come to me and I say it's
going to cost probably a thousand to
three thousand dollars best case
scenario to try and figure out why you
were denied
how many people can just write a check
like that think about their working
constituents I mean doctors and lawyers
yeah we can write a check like that but
working people that's a lot of money to
them
the next thing you have to look at here
is you look at what I call almost a fish
story
and this is probably the one that
offends me the most and I feel for women
I have a bad ankle got it from running
and so I don't run anymore I barely walk
I can tell you that I can't defend
myself like I used to and I represent
Sometimes women who they now need a gun
they are physically afraid for their
well-being
and they're going to have to wait
and not even if there's a problem with
the record not be subjected to a
three-day period right now under federal
law the gun dealer can choose to let
that firearm go after three days and
they will have within three days of fire
and let me tell you what happens all the
time police arrests go to a scene where
there's domestic violence I had a client
they arrested her husband and somehow
there's somebody clicked the box that
they arrested her
she wasn't able to buy a gun
we're at the terrible most terrible time
in her life and she's going to wait how
long
this is anti-woman it's a horrible
horrible bill but here's what's even
worse you go down this and you say okay
let's look just at the Drafting and I go
back to whoever drafted this doesn't
have subject matter confidence or
they're deliberately as one client said
don't ever ascribe to malice what can be
explained by incompetence so maybe we
have incompetence here but if you look
at page number one
and we look specifically at 9 30.
possessing a firearm pursuant to 18 USD
922d or pursuant to state law
well let me tell you what the drafter is
evil either ignorantly left out or
deliberately left out
1822 or I'm sorry 922 D specifically
says if you have a state long
misdemeanor for which you received more
than a Year's imprisonment you are
barred from guns but that's not the end
of the story you have to keep looking
and do a whole job here
18 USC 921 a20 amb says no a person can
have a state court misdemeanor for up to
two years
and or have Anti-Trust violations and
they can still have firearms
but if you enact this without that other
exemption which is found in federal law
you are foreclosing tons of people of
their rights because what people in New
Hampshire might not understand there are
a lot of Massachusetts residents come up
here Massachusetts has tons of two-year
misdemeanors
under this provision the way it's
written all those men and women wouldn't
be able to buy firearms even though they
can under federal law
we go to the back when people talk about
loopholes loopholes is any law they
don't want and they want changed
the definition of loophole is very clear
it's an oversight
the three day of letting people have a
firearm if there's no response it's not
a loophole it's deliberate it's to keep
the government honest
and to keep honest citizens to be able
to get Firearms instead of having what
we had for some years at the gun line
people dragging their feet or playing
mini detective or doing whatever and
taking days and days and days and weeks
and weeks and weeks and months and
months and months to find out something
that could have been found out in two or
three days
and so you look at that the other thing
you have to look at
is on page two line six through 11.
what you're doing is basically asking
every federal firearms licensee in the
country to violate federal law and
pretty soon the ATF is going to
investigate all of you don't worry won't
have a gun dealer in the country
you can't ask or require these dealers
to do something that violates the
provisions of federal law or the
conditions of their license that's not
reasonable
people have to look at this and we could
go on and on and on and on
but the bottom line is the other thing
is dealers can't work for free these men
pay money they have overhead they're
going to charge usually 25 to 50 bucks a
check you're going to add that onto
every gun
think about that again for the average
working guy who's going to buy a two
three four hundred dollar gun
that's a lot of money people you know
make x amount of dollars an hour
but in short there's a lot of mechanical
defects in this bill in addition to the
fact that quite frankly I'm
ideologically opposed to it there's no
reason to have it to begin with this is
not worth fixing you're going to make a
father go get permission to give the
family rifle to the Sun
you know when they talk about these
internet gun sales that's the biggest
crack of horse feathers I've ever heard
it is illegal to have Interstate sale
between private individuals non-licensed
people it's illegal now it just doesn't
happen and when it does the ATF cracks
down on it so I'm happy to answer any
questions you have
but as a practical matter this is
horrible and you put the gum line in
quite frankly a bad position asking them
to do things I'm not sure they can do
and when I say legally I'm not saying
they couldn't mechanically potentially
do them but you're putting them in a
position
and asking them probably to violate
several agreements they have with the
databases are in
for your testimony
a chair
who recognizes
it's okay it's Korea sakikini um sure I
I wasn't planning on speaking today
um but I am speaking on behalf of my two
children Owen who is six years old and
Zaya who is two years old and I'm
acutely aware that there are mothers and
fathers in this country whose children
are not alive and do not have the
privilege to stand here and to advocate
for this bill because their children
have been slaughtered by people who were
able to get guns who we know never
should have had those guns in their
hands
the children in this country and in this
state do not have the privilege to be
here before you
to plead with you to do what is right to
protect them
there are mothers in the state who
cannot be here right now because they
are caring for their children who they
trust you to protect they trust you
every time they send their children into
school to know that you will do the
right thing that they will not be
victims to senseless gun violence when
they kiss their child in the morning and
say goodbye to them
this is a law that we know the majority
of people support this is a law that has
statistics behind it that shows it
produces homicide it reduces suicide it
reduces senseless killing and when we
talk about rights
where are the people protecting the
rights of our children
the children who deserve a chance at
Living of growing to their potential of
advocating for themselves
they have been slaughtered we are
watching them die in numbers that are
beyond what other developed nations are
witnessing and is because we do not have
the courage
to put these laws into place
took this opportunity to the women who
are at home with their children to speak
to you to look into your eyes I
guarantee they would speak to you but
they don't have access to the
opportunity to come into this room like
many others who you've heard from
I'm asking you to open this conversation
up to the mothers and the parents in
this state and listen to them and
possibly even listen to the children
thank you for your time and please
please consider passing this bill
keep your testimony is there anyone who
has not turned in the pink card yet to
test it on this bill
saying none I hear my clothes in public
hearing on the hb59
in openly public hearing on h376
oh
I reopened the public hearing and please
take the microphone
um we don't we seem to have misplace the
card so I brought it in late it was
passed down so I'm sure it's somewhere
I'm Joanna Brown from Manchester
um I oppose this bill and I too have
children and I would like you to all
think about what you don't hear on the
news are the people the private citizens
who are stopping gun violence by taking
out the aggressors you don't hear about
in that in the news in a utopian society
a three-day wait might be fine but a
woman
a restaurant waitress in Manchester
received death threats from a homeless
man
she doesn't have three days to wait
three days is the difference between
life and death for her women who've been
in abused relationships who are dealing
with stalkers on the street they can't
wait three days man
this bill is about background checks the
three-day waiting period bill is later
although this does touch on it a little
bit but not really about what you're
talking about so if you could just speak
to this bill regarding the background
checks so this bill is the one about all
the technical language and doing a
background check that takes three days
IT addresses the part where if you have
to wait three days you don't get an
answer back
the law currently is that you can get
your firearm so it's it briefly touches
that's all I had to say anyway okay
thank you
anyone else
seeing none hp59 is not closed HP 76 is
open and the chair recognizes the prime
sponsor
I representative David Muse
foreign
Roy just to clarify I am not the prime
sponsor representative cam Kenny is the
prime sponsor but I think I can play one
on TV
so I'm going to try to do that I'm going
to read representative Kenny's uh
statement and then I'll have some
comments of my own
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I apologize for not being able
to be in person to introduce HB 76 today
unfortunately I'm in my second year of
law school and have class right now but
please email me if you have any
questions
to start with
this bill establishes a reasonable
waiting period of three days before the
delivery of a firearm
this should not be a partisan issue as
both blue and red states such as Florida
Massachusetts Rhode Island and Illinois
and others have passed some form of
waiting period
additionally waiting periods or cooling
off periods have been shown to reduce
suicide and other forms of Violence by
offering time to gain perspective when
things in the moment might seem
intolerable or hopeless
this bill gives a very reasonable window
to increase the possibility of second
thoughts and of getting help
there are reasonable exceptions offered
in part three of the bill which the
chairman just just mentioned such as a
16-hour hunting education course lawn
exemptions for law enforcement officers
or active duty service members there are
also Provisions
for exceptions for folks who have who
basically are impacted by restraining
orders or who have a reasonable fear
of violence
the bill is only intended to reduce
impulsive acts by establishing a waiting
period that has worked in other
jurisdictions and hopefully part three
offers a fair balance that will narrowly
uh narrowly confine the impact
um what I wanted to add uh and I'm a
co-sponsor of this bill is that HP 76
with the exception of the enactment date
is identical to HB 1101 that's a bill
that passed in the Full House in 2020
and was tabled in the Senate during
cobit
under current federal law there is no
waiting period to purchase guns a
waiting period uh can actually give law
enforcement additional time to perform a
background check and a cooling off
period uh in cases where people may be
prone to violence or maybe maybe
considering a suicide attempt
I also wanted to mention the fact that
waiting periods are not an uncommon
thing to encounter as a consumer in this
state
anyone who's bought Dental or health
insurance is familiar with waiting
periods after you buy coverage we have
waiting periods for pet insurance we
have waiting periods for divorces and
many employers also have a waiting
period between the time you start work
and when your employee benefits take
effect we also have cooling off periods
for many types of contracts where a
person can can opt out of a contract
three days after signing it
um one of the things I wanted to mention
too is how frustrating it was for me
during uh during covet when my oven went
out to have to wait uh for three months
to it for a new oven to show up at my
house uh that was a bummer we have lots
of microwaved meals very inconvenient
um and and I think the key point of that
is that
all of us are adults and we're used to
waiting some sometimes sometimes we just
have to deal with the fact that some of
the things we would really like to have
now we just simply have to wait for uh
so I wanted to make that point
um the other point that I wanted to to
make also is that uh this bill probably
more than some of the others that we're
going to hear today
um has the potential to significantly
impact suicides
so in in New Hampshire I would be the
first to say we have much less of a of a
gun homicide problem than we do a gun
suicide problem in 2020 which is the
last year that I could find 118 out of
129 firearm debts were suicide that's
about 91 of the deaths by firearm during
that year and that's from the chief
medical examiner
uh from 2015 to 2019 suicide was also
the second leading cause uh in the
granite state between people between the
age of 10 and 34. uh and meanwhile I
think one of the things you have to
consider is that uh
death from Firearms Remains the most
lethal type of suicide uh about 90
percent of the people who try it
unfortunately are successful
one of the things we hear a lot is that
well gee I could take a screwdriver and
I could commit suicide with that I could
I could drink too much water and commit
suicide that way the point is is all you
have to do with a gun is pointed at your
head pull the trigger and ninety percent
of the time it's Lights Out it's over
um in addition to establishing the
three-day waiting period
the bill does offer some common sense
exemptions and those exemptions and we
mentioned the one for people who've
completed uh 100 safety courses there
are also exemptions that address issues
uh by victims of domestic violence or
people who have had their personal
safety threatened in cases where your
you feel your personal safety is
threatened
um and uh you uh and you've expressed
fear for your personal safety to a law
enforcement officer the three-day
waiting period could be waived not to
say that it's not a terrible idea giving
a firearm to an untrained person there's
also some significant risk there but the
bottom line is this was one of the main
objections that came up the last time
that this bill was filed
um and uh and it was amended to address
the subject objection and essentially
that's the bill that's before us today
so what I would ask you is uh please
give it your strong consideration uh
waiting periods are not unusual they're
not a tragedy in in the case of a
firearm or suicide or exit violence is a
real risk it's one more thing that we
can do not necessarily to completely
prevent gun violence but it's part of
the picture of reducing the risk of gun
violence and I think that's that's
something that um whether you're a gun
owner whether you're gun violence
prevention Advocate I think that's
something we also be able to to support
hopefully so please give it your strong
consideration thank you
thank you for your testimony the chair
recognizes The Honorable John Burt
and up next will be Dr Hannon
thank you Mr chairman and find committee
members I am former representative John
Burt
for 12 years I represented Goffstown
where in Darren
Mr chairman
we don't need this
and I'm going to tell you why
New Hampshire is one of the safest
states in the nation
you know this is just going to mess it
up
I look at the men and I do say men and
women that are abused in this state
and occasionally some of those men and
women want to protect themselves from
their abuser
and they purchase a firearm they don't
want to wait the three days
because as
we've seen it takes a half hour 10
minutes
even two minutes for a police officer to
show up
that's too long
or it can be too long
and again that we are this at one of the
safest states in the nation occasionally
we're number one occasionally we're
number two or three it's always within
those ranges we're even safer than
Canada
and look what Trudeau is doing up there
he has taken guns
in their crime rates are increasing
isn't that something
and Mr chairman
I do want to point out one last thing
the fine representative that spoke last
said that there is a three-day waiting
period in Massachusetts
there is no waiting period in
Massachusetts
you walk in
if you're not a prohibited person you
walk out with that firearm that minute
so I you know you just look at this bill
it's bad so please oppose this Bill
thank you for your time
thank you for your testimony chair
recognized Dr Hannon
up next will be Joanne Brown
uh good morning for the next two minutes
I guess still morning uh johannan Gunner
Rose of New Hampshire uh we're obviously
in opposition to this bill again
um you know there are exceptions in this
bill which I'll I'll give credit where
credit is due we usually don't see this
many exceptions but uh they're not
they're not anything that um would would
make us feel more comfortable with
supporting this bill at all
um you know allowing exceptions for uh
law enforce you know expressing to a law
enforcement officer for a reasonable
fear of his or her own safety sounds
reasonable unless you're married to a
law enforcement officer who is abusing
you and that's why you need the firearm
now their buddies know and that's the
only way you can get it otherwise
um that's just one example
um you're allowed to get it if you trade
in a firearm sounds great because you've
already got a gun but you know
what if you already have a gun do you
have to trade it in what if I already
have one and show them I already own a
firearm so there's no exceptions for
someone who already has a gun that has
the means to do whatever with that
firearm that's not an exception
um
I'm not trying to improve the bill I'm
just trying to tell you that there are a
lot of things wrong with the way it is
written
um you know if someone can purchase a
rifle or a shotgun and for one thing if
the purpose is to reduce suicides there
are two things that are not
predominantly used in suicides but they
can I'm not I'll say they can be but if
a person completes a 16 hour Hunter
education course offered by the
department of fishing game uh you can
take that as young as age 12 obviously
you have to be older to purchase a
firearm but all they have to do is take
a course so we're assuming by this that
if suicide prevention is the goal that
people that are trained in the hunter
safety course are not going to be
suicidal so there's a lot of exceptions
to make people happy but I don't know if
it's doing what people expect it to do
and also the data shows that most
suicides that occur with the use of a
firearm although more successful with
the firearm obviously it is effective
unfortunately most of them occur after a
year after purchase and even with 10-day
waiting periods there's still a very
significant increase in suicides in the
shorter period even after a 10-day
waiting periods so having a shorter
waiting period if someone's intent on
doing it you know it's not something
that's going to be statistically
significant to stop what the intended
goal may or may not be
um
there's more that can be said but we've
heard this so many times uh you know a
right delayed is a right denied is
something that was uh said I forget I
don't remember Supreme Court Justice
sorry but uh it's it's very true in this
case we don't expect people to wait to
post something online or social media
although it's probably a good idea for
some people uh you know we don't expect
people to in New Hampshire to wait to
vote you can do same-day voting
um they're making an exception for this
which is is not right uh if you're
allowing exception for what for to
exercise a right not a privilege
um that's that's a very bad precedent to
set in New Hampshire thank you
thank you very testimony chair
recognized Joanne Brown
and up next will be Andrew Schuler
chair calls Joanne Brown
Andrew Schiller
hey thank you for uh let me publicly
speak so I noticed there are some
semantic issues here uh it mentions uh
in order to skip the uh time to pretend
that delaying is an imprinting rights
for a second I'm expressing to the law
enforcement officer reasonable fear for
his our own personal safety
um well expression can mean multiple
things like maybe buying favors or
giving them something and it's not
particularly up uh a pursuing citizen
thing to do but it is possible according
to here
um I know there's a concealed carry
permit which could be in essence the
same thing but it doesn't include open
carry so that this doesn't really
include that
um and then just more in general
speaking
um not just fire and still if you had to
wait to buy a car or even worse you know
like you have a kid but you have to wait
three days to take the kid home like
that's silly right so applying to farm
is the same way why would you add an
arbitrary delay to an item that you will
awfully you know that's all I want to
say thank you
thank you
chair calls Leonard Cohen Dr Leonard
Cohen
thank you
as
as a psychiatrist we know that suicide
is a very impulsive Act
and often the impulse to kill
subsides over hours
uh let alone a couple of days
this bill is an attempt to interfere
with the impulsive Act
that somebody
who is thinking about suicide might go
get a gun and act on it right away
so this is an attempt to interfere with
that impulsive act and we think it would
be one
important
step in uh trying to reduce gun violence
thank you
thank you for your testimony the chair
recognizes Brian blackton
I apologize if you're going to get sick
of hearing me today
I ask you to ATL this bill in response
to house bill 76.
this bill is in conflict with ATF Form
5300.9 revised December of 22.
specifically the proposed Bill states
there is no waiting period for a person
who has obtained a restraining order
from a court under circumstances where
the person feared for his or her safety
or expresses to a law enforcement
officer a reasonable fear for his or her
own personal safety reasonable is very
subjective
the 4473 Nix Check May delay anyone who
was aged 21 up to 10 days
I will not be made a felon by this bill
if I am told by a police officer to sell
someone a firearm prior to this bill's
three-day wait period if the ATF can
make them wait 10 days
I will not be told by a police officer
to break the ATF rules based on the
proposed bill in there
thought of what is reasonable
I also find The Spill hypocritical that
someone may buy a shotgun or rifle
instantly merely due to holding a
hunting license
which
I'm not an expert on New Hampshire
hunting licenses so I don't know how
easily they can be forged
I answer to the ATM
not to a local police officer if the ATF
has up until 10 days to wait
I refuse to be a felon because a police
officer says
he wants somebody to have a gun
instantly for their own safety
what if a police officer's friend
doesn't want to wait three days and has
them tell me not to wait three days
based on their reasonable
thought of fear
this is Rife for abuse with the ffls
being on the hook
further I don't need to be told by the
authors to make my records available to
the ATF when that is already an ATF
regulation for licensure
if I refuse to comply with an illegal
law I become a felon
the authors may want to have an attorney
look over the proposed bill as it is
clear they do not know what they are
doing
thank you
thank you for your testimony chair calls
time representative Tom mannion
and up next will be brain Berry
thank you Mr chair members of committee
my name is Tom minion I represent
Hillsboro One Pelham I'm here to speak
against hb76
during the summer of 2020 I watched live
streams of fiery but mostly peaceful
protests across the country the citizens
were angry and I agreed with their anger
but not the methodology private
businesses even those with black owners
were torched and some of the largest
cities with more violent protests
terrified business owners were told by
911 dispatchers the police were
unavailable and help unavailable to help
and they were on their own hearing this
I was thankful we live in a country
where we can arm ourselves against such
violence but in states with firearm
waiting periods like California you
cannot just go get a firearm to protect
your business your family your property
these people learn the hard way that
they're feel good sensible gun control
measures would have costly consequences
a compacting criminally halfway across
the country country away
uh would result in near overnight
reaction from a rightfully angry
Community but would end up destroying
the livelihood or homes of people wholly
and uninvolved
and they were told by both the police
and the gun store owners you're going to
have to wait
it's easy to be a money money
quarterback and say they should have
already had the gun
but the same people pushing for winning
periods don't actually believe this
either
they'd rather you be disarmed and hope
the waiting period is enough to do
enough of a deterrent to keep you from
bothering at all they believe a waiting
period would stop some Heat of the
Moment gun purchase for a vigilante
looking for vengeance or whatever
thriller movie scenario they have cooked
up that same person will just get it
illegally should a waiting period be
introduced
the only person the only people being
affected by this are those that wish to
remain within the law and will
ultimately be harmed by it
if another Country-Wide protest is on
the horizon and your state has a
mandatory waiting period you may as well
pack your things and leave town just
don't expect your home to be there when
you get back I asked the committee to
itl HP 76 and I'm willing to take any
questions
thank you for your testimony
chair calls Brian Berry
up next will be Je simpkin
J.E simpkin
good afternoon
again thank you for your time citizens
and representatives we appreciate it
uh suicide yep serious
does help 988 is a good number to keep
in mind if someone that you know
or yourself maybe looking to hurt
yourself or listen to stress
okay we get that out of the way
I'm gonna oppose the three-day waiting
period that we're talking about right
now
there's a few reasons
I'm gonna touch on the Federal
Constitution for a minute if I may
amendment 14 in particular
all persons born on naturalized in the
United States and subject to the
jurisdiction thereof are citizens of the
United States another state wherein they
reside no State shall make or enforce
any law would show abridge the
Privileges or immunities of citizens of
the United States nor show any state of
Pride any person of life liberty or
property well due process of law nor
deny any person within its jurisdiction
to the equal protection of the laws
yet we have a number of exceptions
in our three-day waiting period that you
propose them
why their exceptions for certain people
in Norfolk
just let it go if I pass it background
check if she passes the background check
that part of the equation has been done
it's resolved they pass let them have
they've gotten
I've seen domestic violence
up close and personal as a law
enforcement officer and past life
it's ugly
it's very ugly
I wish it upon nobody
I don't think anyone should ever see it
but
when that cycle is broken
and enough's enough
and the police come and take away the
husband
and his last words I'm gonna
explicatively kill you
he means it
he's not going down
that woman needs something to defend
herself with right now
she doesn't
have to buy a gun she can go and run to
her her mother's Place Father's Place
cousin's place sure
but she could buy a gun if she wanted to
if she's in that much fear of her life
and leave with it that day
If This Were to be implemented there is
some conflict with federal law which was
touched on
between 18 years of age and 21 is a
10-day waiting period now it was in
response to a lot of young shooters that
were shooting up in schools and Walmarts
and stuff so that's already in Conflict
there
if I get a delay from the gum line
saying there's a delay as a pending it
was the actual language used
pending p50s and then five numbers
I'm not going to violate awe and be held
accountable because somebody's going to
tell me yeah you can do it
if that gun's used incorrectly who's on
the hook for that do you also told me to
do it on me I'm unhooky either way I'm a
gun store on the bad guy
I understand that I try to do good
though
but let's say for the sake of argument
that this takes effect it's really
waiting period and that person who's
been abused or broke the cycle
can't get a restraining order right now
for whatever reason they come to me
first
oh I closed my doors early coming sick
it would be nice if my cousin who has a
gun could give it to me
well 59
prevent that wouldn't it
so now we've just
helped along a victim become more a
victim with both sets of these proposed
laws
I hope
some of the testimony that is being
given here makes sense
and gives you a different perspective on
how to look at things
again I don't believe anybody here
is doing this
other than from the heart and what they
believe because they want people to be
safe they don't want people to get hurt
I think we all agree in that
there's different ways of
preventing from becoming a victim
different ways of responding to a
violent situation
but
I respectfully ask you that's not
penalized
the citizens who wish to exercise our
rights the way they want to the way
we've been doing
hundreds of years as a republic
let's not start making exceptions
that's not rule of law
then we stop putting certain people in
certain classes oh
the trooper can have a gun you gotta
wait
he already has a gun man State gave it
to him we paid for it he's all set
and as in the other example what about
what if his wife was the abused victim
here
she needs something to defend herself
he's trained
and as it was pointed out by some other
female colleagues here stature
look at me five foot nine to eight
where's Kim
I think she's gonna stop me
it's it's morbid I understand that
but it's real
thank you for your time
thank you for your testimony
share calls and Je Simpkins
and up next will be Timothy Wolfe
good afternoon Mr chairman of members of
the committee thank you for this
opportunity to testify
I'll try to be a little briefer than
I've been
anyone who uses the term gun violence
end quote seeks to mislead homicide is a
crime
suicide is not
both are very sad but these are
fundamentally different events that
should not be lumped together the doing
so is to my mind this speaks a certain
element of intellectual dishonesty now
to the bill
in New Hampshire and for the members of
the committee I may labor the obvious
murders are so infrequent that all are
prosecuted by
an assistant to the Attorney General of
the state
I presume I do not know this for sure
that County Prosecutors don't see enough
murders to become Adept at this type of
prosecution
the murder rate in New Hampshire
typically is about one per hundred
thousand which is about the same as in
quote civilized countries in Europe
occasionally it will pop above
occasionally a little below one
whereas the murder rate in the nation at
large is usually five per hundred
thousand or more
so again we appear to be a very
law-abiding state that would not
therefore appear to be
any matter any reason having to do with
prevention of crime for a waiting period
at all
for I mean I can explain if anyone wants
to ask a question why the incidence of
violent crime in New Hampshire
is so much lower than it is in
Massachusetts our neighbor to the South
but only take your time if you wish
as do other civilized countries and I
put that term civilized countries and
quotes
those who use or cite those statistics
disregard
the number of residents of those
countries
who for example were murdered by the
Nazis victims of genocide aren't counted
the biggest murderer in the century just
closed the 20th century were not
criminals either
common or organized the biggest
murderers
in the century just closed were
officials of governments gone bad
Nazi Germany Soviet Union Mao Zedong
China Rwanda Cambodia
Uganda Guatemala
all of these countries had
gun control regimes in place in some
cases 90 years
before the genocide occurred
you should think of gun control laws as
akin to expended but unexploded bonds
and artillery shells
Ukraine for the next century
will have to send out teams
to dig up
and disarm or explode in place
quote Doug rhymes
how do I know this and I do know it with
certainty
I know this because in Western Europe
where a war has not been fought for 80
years
governments there
if not deadly certainly weekly France at
Belgium Germany sometimes even Britain
send teams of military experts to disarm
unexploded ordinance and this stuff
remains lethal Mr simkin okay the
committee appreciates the history but
well the history day waiting period
because we Mr chairman is relevant
because everyone here at some level buys
the case that gun control saves lives
and therefore the discussion is well how
do we
adjust it to make it less onerous my
point attacks the basic concept gun
control clears the way not for a
thousand murders for Millions
the fact that it hasn't happened here
recently neither here nor there
and this is a point that I really think
the members of the committee need to
think about
because the same bills are brought back
year after year after year because the
assumption is gun control is a social
good
even in countries where Firearms are not
abundant
it's a bad concept
a lethally bad concept
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for your time I appreciate it
thank you happy to answer any questions
relevant to my testimony
and thank you for that availability uh
you're welcome did you recognizes
Timothy wolf
up next will be James Gaffney thank you
um some good testimony uh here
um just standing there
um or sitting there I should say
um really brought up a lot of issues I
hadn't really even thought of but um in
terms in terms of this bill
um I see a lot of this type of
legislation being proposed for um
Suicide Prevention specifically
um
and it's a pretty close uh issue to me
um I can think of four people just
sitting there that I know or have a son
actually in one case who uh took their
life at the hand of a firearm
um one of them actually is still alive
unfortunately for her as a ward of the
state of Massachusetts
um so I understand the in intention
um but I have to say that talking to all
these people's families afterwards
um
you know these were not stupid people
they were just they were hurting and um
they would have found a way to take
their lives with or without a firearm
that there's no doubt about that
um is a firearm something that you use
it's quick you can't take it back yes
um but
do we need to
the cases that a lot of other people
have made here is if somebody needs a
gun I I specifically think of my
children my
um my two sons you know they're getting
older one of them died in my house one
of them's about to be out of my house
and um I brought them up I've taught him
how to shoot
but they have no interest in Firearms at
all
um and but they know how to use them and
God forbid they'd be in a situation
where they would ever need that firearm
and they'd be in another state per se
say that state is a student or something
in the year in New Hampshire and
somebody uh relics you know basically
says I want to kill you and it's a it's
a you know a domestic situation
um whether it be a man or a woman and
somebody else wants to do you harm well
three days is a long time when somebody
wants to kill you and I think for every
action
there's a reaction so yes you know I
understand this is seen as a cooling off
period uh somebody to kind of get their
wits back about them but uh if you're
the person who needs a gun because
somebody wants to kill you it doesn't
give you the opportunity to defend
yourself uh in it discounts their life
it does not give them the chance to
defend their life
um so but that would be my major issue
with it
um and in a lot of cases uh in
specifically all the ones that I am
unfortunately a little too familiar with
those guns were already owned they were
already in possession you know and other
people I know you know I mean but they
could have used a charcoal grill
um just as easily as they could have
um
a firearm
um so anyhow thank you
thank you for that testimony the chair
calls James Gaffney and Penny Dean will
be next
this bill is very similar to the last
one it's not accomplish anything
I'll let Penny go into the structural
details of it but this is a bill that is
written in such a manner that it is
it tries to lump together two different
issues
suicide is very very different than
someone committing violence against
another person right that's the first
thing the second thing is is that
if somebody wants to do something
whether it's kill themselves or commit a
violent act right in the second case we
already have laws against that it's
illegal to murder somebody it's illegal
to commit assault it's illegal 16
different ways so if they already have a
gun or a knife or baseball bat or an
automobile or any other tool this makes
me a tool user
uh they're gonna find a way to do it and
nothing you can you say or do can stop
them from doing it
period full stop you are not going to
stop people from this law is not going
to cause somebody to say oh wow now that
it's 17 times illegal I'm not going to
do it it's like the joke about the
British police stop or I'll say stop
again
so
as far as suicide goes
well I haven't heard anybody offer much
information I just want to interrupt you
real quick I wanted to recognize in the
gallery we have a class of school
children here today and I wanted to
thank them for coming in to take part in
uh this government exercise so thank you
very much and welcome to the New
Hampshire house
thank you sir
as far as suicide goes we haven't heard
anybody talk to the reasons that people
commit suicide it's very it's everything
from mental illness to people who are
terminally ill and want to end their
lives and
I think that's an important point
because nobody's talked about it before
this is my life if I'm facing a terminal
illness it's not up to any of you or
anyone else to tell me whether or not I
can choose to end my life or not
this bill it's a complicated issue with
this bill in the end will not accomplish
anything but trample the rights of
people
over and over and over
please give this an itl rating any
questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
the chair recognizes attorney Penny Dean
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee good afternoon and I would ask
that uitl this bill despite its laudable
goals
as judges tell me all the time connect
the dads tell me how it's relevant they
can't this isn't anything that we should
quote have to deal with this is a
constitutional right
and that's really what's important I
happen to do divorces there's no waiting
period
you know they have 30 days like
everything else before if kicks and be
for an appeal period that's not a
waiting period it happens with all sorts
of cases there's a period of time in
which either party can appeal
but you're talking again about a
constitutional right here that's a big
deal but when we look at
I call them dog whistles at the anti-gun
Community whenever you hear the words
reasonable restriction
common sense
those should be keywords to you
anti-second Amendment litigation
legislation and that's what it is and to
say that people support this I don't buy
it I haven't seen any surveys that they
support things like this and I
understand that suicide may be an
impulsive issue don't disagree with that
but here so you're telling me that
people who have taken Hunter education
are not impulsive
it just so happens that I've taught
Hunter I've taught Hunter education
that's an interesting story for 17 years
so it says here that if you have certain
Criterion that you would be exempt from
that
and again back to connecting the dots so
you're going to tell me that if I just
go out and buy a hunting license I'm
exempt
that doesn't make any sense to me it
doesn't make any sense whatsoever the
other thing that we hear about more and
more and more
is police and firemen about how they're
really stressed out about their jobs
lately they're having higher and higher
and higher suicide rates and they are
taking mental health breaks
and so what about the police officer who
has a domestic violence restraining
order against him
they pulled he's off work
paid or unpaid
he can walk in
because he's exempt from that waiting
period according to this
but I think the thing that probably
concerns me or one of the most important
things concerns me of this
is that if you look at page one line 25
and 26. there's an exemption for a
person who has obtained a valid
restraining order
anybody on planet Earth can get a
temporary restraining order ex parte
before the person has a right to a
hearing
and there's an old saying that you could
indict a ham sandwich and it's about
darn true when it comes to some of these
temporary orders
and so you look at a person the question
is is this going to incentivize people
to make false accusations against other
people
and I think that's a problem
you're gonna have I'm not saying
everyone or all of them but I'm saying I
can see a person going into a police
department
and having someone because I've seen all
sorts of officials do it NAD nod wink
wink nudge nudge if this was your
problem I could help you are you scared
and so you have to ask yourself how many
false accusations will get out of this
and how many temporary orders that once
there's a hearing are dismissed be it
that person got away with no waiting
period
and I'm not saying there should be a
waiting period I'm totally against it's
constitutional right it's not like
buying a car it's not like in a divorce
it's not like anything else but there
are huge mechanical and inequitable
problems in this and for someone to
suggest that certain categories of
people essentially are less impulsive
so you don't have to worry about them
they can buy guns but all the other
people they're impulsive so we're going
to stop them and save their life I think
that's patently ridiculous
and happy to answer any questions and
thank you for listening to me
thank you for your testimony uh the
chair is recalling Joanne Brown I
believe I saw her enter
you don't want to testify this one
okay thank you uh anyone else hasn't
turned in their pin card
who
oh go ahead if you if
while the intentions of this legislation
attempt to stop some of the suicides
that occur in the state of New Hampshire
it does not address the actual issue of
suicide nor help the people who are
potentially thinking about suicide in
2021 the latest official statistics from
the Centers for Disease Control
223 Granite Staters committed suicide
around half of those people used a
firearm why are legislators focusing on
only on Firearms rather than focusing on
the mental health help necessary to help
all people who may be thinking of
committing suicide
Japan has a higher rate of suicide per
capita than the United States and they
don't have guns
at the same time this legislation also
creates a deadly problem for others
especially women who are in abusive
situations or need to protect themselves
from stalkers it serves the women who
are already victims of this abuse or
stalking into victims of the legislature
because they are unable to purchase a
firearm to protect themselves thanks to
an arbitrary weeding period that could
mean the difference between life or
death now we brought that up last time
this again out of state legislation was
pushed in the legislature so they
changed it to include people who get
restraining orders or if someone tells
an officer that they are in reasonable
fear of their life so really a woman is
going to have to wait to prove she can
immediately practice her fundamental
human right to self-defense only if she
gets a piece of paper or brings a police
officer to the gun shop with her
while we are um while we've been in here
there is a woman online her name is
Maura Chappelle she was going to be here
but she stayed home due to illness but
she's listening and she told me that it
took her two days to get a restraining
order from her abuser
and she would have much preferred to go
to a gun shop to try to protect herself
but she couldn't
please vote in expedient to legislate on
this bill the legislation will make it
so women cannot save their own lives
because law-abiding women will follow
the law no matter how ridiculous their
attackers will not do the same
thank you for your testimony and that
being the last person I'm going to go
ahead and close the
what was yeah
yeah regardless please come up and take
the microphone
thank you William Rogers I think we look
at guns differently
here in this room I look at it as a
self-defense tool strictly
to defend myself and to defend my family
defend my country defend my state being
a self-defense tool like other people
have done there might be times I want it
immediately and I might be a person who
never had one before
why should I be infringed if you see it
as a suicide tool strictly as a weapon
of violence to to do harm I could see
that makes sense but if you see it as a
defense weapon it makes no sense and I'm
not just talking about it's certainly
valid a woman who's been stalked or has
someone else feels threatened and I see
that woman
I don't see a suicidal person with a gun
to their head that's a horrible tragic
then I see a woman behind her door and
she's relieved she's real she's signed
she's breathing a sigh of relief that
she can protect herself
and as the lawyer said go on to the this
is an infringement on the Second
Amendment plain and simple it's we have
the right to defend ourselves why would
we wait to do it and this could also be
not just a stalker it could be a natural
disaster coming we know there's the
hurricane of the century coming and
we're worried about looting we're
worried about things like that if I had
no weapon I would go out and get one and
I would expect to be able to to protect
myself because it is a dissell defense
tool strictly thank you
thank you for your testimony
down I'm closing public hearing HP 786
and this time I opened public Hearing in
HP 78
and recognize speaker shortlist to
introduce the bill
thank you Anna thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Steve shortliff and I
represent Merrimack District 15 which is
Ward one of conquered the village of
Penacook
and having said we all of you are
sitting today let me stop by saying a
conclusion
um
I'm here on behalf of Representative
Bale to introduce this bill and I want
to thank the committee for everything
you've done already this morning your
attention and your politeness to the
Witnesses on both sides of the issue
that's commendable and looks very well
on the New Hampshire house
Mr chairman in 1997 as I mentioned I
retired as a supervisory Deputy U.S
Marshal
and in 1997 I was still on the job
in August of that year
and we learned of the horrific shoot
again
up in another part of the state and the
name and I was Escape my mind and I know
Colebrook where four people had been
murdered uh
newspaper editor a district called court
judge in two state troopers Scott
Phillips and Leslie Lloyd and my partner
at the time Bob Weisberg looked at me
and said you know Steve New Hampshire is
not Mayberry anymore
in regardless of some of the testimony
we've heard New Hampshire really isn't
maybe he was right 25 years ago
I'm here to ask the committee to support
House Bill 78 which would repeal
uh 1178 which restricts law enforcement
uh involvement in the enforcement of any
federal gun law that could impair the
New Hampshire's right to bear on
last September
within the Attorney General our current
attorney general for Miller issued a
six-page memorandum to New Hampshire
armed forcement going through the
various points that have already been
brought up that officers could be
concerned about if what they were doing
were legal over the violating
um
the RSA that forbid them involving
themselves in federal gun laws
and one of the things the Attorney
General pointed out on page three of his
memorandum was be very careful although
your law enforcement officer you could
be charged under federal law with aiding
and abetting if you should not do
something you should legally do for
example if you're searching a prisoner
are you located a handgun that's illegal
you've got to make sure that you seize
that as you would any evidence is turned
over a federal agent so they can
prosecute that case
the he also said don't confuse
assistance with cooperation they aren't
the same you have certain rights
in the six page memorandum was followed
by several uh uh frequently frequently
asked questions
and uh and I wouldn't be surprised if
the ehe had to do a supplemental because
you did a wonderful job of pointing out
where you could belong and what you're
doing
and This concerns me and it goes back to
what I talked about that horrific depth
and those that died the offices acted
superbly but my fear today as a local
officer or a state officer could get
involved in a situation and be hesitant
for just a few seconds because they're
not sure if they're violating the state
law
and
and I'd hate to see that kind of a
tragedy happen again in New Hampshire
and I thank you again Mr chairman if
there are any questions I'd be glad to
answer them
thank you for your testimony introducing
the bill Mr speaker thank you Mr
chairman
the chair recognizes The Honorable John
Burt
just for everyone's information I'm
going to do two more witnesses and we
are going to take a short lunch break
and then we will continue
thank you Mr chairman and fine committee
members again I am a former
representative John Burt I served 12
years here
um
Mr chairman
I'm a little concerned on this bill
because it repeals 1178
which is my bill
uh 1178
that house bill 78 repeals
um I worked extremely hard to get it
right
and let me explain what I mean by right
if you break New Hampshire law
has the case in Colebrook
in the feds for whatever reason I don't
know if they were involved with the
Colebrook case but if they were
New Hampshire law enforcement
can help
because you broke New Hampshire law
it's that easy
that's why the governor signed this this
is a good bill that this that house bill
78 is trying to repeal so I hope uitl
this bill
I'd like to point out that I was very
honored
there's a magazine called the American
Revolution
that is put out and it was put out on
the core of the fourth quarter of last
year
unmentioned in that bill or the the
magazine
again the American Revolution
it says
New Hampshire emerges as a beacon of
Liberty
and it was by Heather uh fazo
what the article read real quick is this
one section it says with the leadership
of John Burr the law has been corrected
and that the citizens of New Hampshire
now can move forward uh move about the
mountains
fully armed with on the snowmobiles and
that was another bill but then it goes
into this
more uh significantly
Rhett Bert House Bill 1178 effectively
rejects federal gun control a certain
that state and local law enforcement
will not cooperate with the Bureau of
ATF
and then it also says what the real
world impacts of this bill earlier this
year the White House announced a new
rule that would ban ghost guns
that's the build kit which allow you to
create a firearm without a serial number
House Bill 1178 that this bill is trying
to repeal
states that local and fish local and
state officials are forbidden to help
federal agents in an unconstitutional
rule
so that's what this is trying to repeal
is my house bill 1178
which is protecting New Hampshire
citizens from unconstitutional laws that
the feds or rules that the feds pass
so I asked you to itl this because again
New Hampshire is a very safe state
we want to protect ourselves from the
federal government's overreach up here
everybody on this board everybody out
here both sides always says local
control well I don't want the feds to
come up here and to borrow my Goffstown
policemen to come to my house if they
feel I did something wrong
which I didn't
and that is the way it should be the
feds do not need our tax paid local
police help
to enforce their unconstitutional rules
or laws so please itl House Bill 78
thank you
thank you for your testimony the chair
calls Brian blackton this will be the
last witness before lunch
this is real short
I asked itl this bill
I believe it is merely an attempt at
strategically trying to form the
groundwork to remove arms from citizens
making them subjects we already had that
discussion and it didn't go well for
Britain
that's why we have article 2A and 10 in
our state constitution thank you
thank you for that testimony at this
point the committee stands in recess for
one hour until
what is it an hour and a quarter of two
Quarter Two
yeah 145 in other words
foreign
thank you
enter
foreign
but
different
ly
foreign
today
the public hearing for House Bill 78
in the house
the chair recognizes who's up next
representative Tom menu
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Tom minion I
represent Hillsboro One Pelham I'm here
to speak against HB 78.
the federal government creates so many
rules and laws that even their bloated
agencies are incapable of enforcing them
all as such they rely on our law
enforcement to waste time and resources
aiding in any number of potentially
unconstitutional Acts then reward such
obedience for things like barricade
Bearcats that the police then use to
smash in the front uh private residents
just because they can
our law enforcement should be focused on
the laws of New Hampshire we are not
obligated to assist the feds in with
whatever new rules they create
especially as it pertains to firearms
the atf's own rules are extremely fluid
in nature and they don't wait for a law
to come from Congress to just decide to
ban new things the latest pistol braces
but before that an executive order from
president Trump and bump stocks only to
be overturned by the courts so in the
interim while these unconstitutional
rules in the executive orders came into
existence with no oversight any one of
us could become a felon in our sleep
last year last year's House Bill 1178
and John Burt great guy uh put it put an
end to wasting our law enforcement's
time with these wild swings in policy
from D.C
if the feds want to enforce these laws
there's sadly not much we can do about
it yet
but they're going to have a much harder
time doing it alone despite what the ATF
and others believe we have a natural
right to self-defense and we respect
that here in New Hampshire
I personally believe the ATF is an
illegal Opera organization responsible
for many deaths caused by their actions
over the decades I do not want our state
law enforcement agencies cooperating
with them and ideally we'll create an
alert system warning communities that
they are in danger whenever they are on
the Move akin to a Midwestern tornado
sirens I asked the committee to itl hb78
and I'm willing to take any questions
thank you for your testimony this
afternoon
chair recognizes Andrew Schuler
look uh just a quick Point um the the
public employees of the State of New
Hampshire they're supposed to serve the
constituents of New Hampshire not the
federal agents and so uh I support the
itl of pill 78 and I like to keep our
public servants focused on just New
Hampshire and protecting New Hampshire
residents rather than throwing them in
prison thank you that's all
thank you for your testimony I also
recognizes Dr Leonard Cohen
thank you again and uh as as I've said
before I'm representing both the New
Hampshire Medical Society and the New
Hampshire Psychiatric Society and you
know
listening to so much testimony this
morning and beginning this afternoon
uh
it almost seems like
so many people in New Hampshire don't
salute the American flag
um they only seem to want to follow laws
that are
New Hampshire was well
HB 78.
is an attempt to repeal what many of us
think is an unconstitutional law as it
is 1178.
now as a psychiatrist in New Hampshire
I've been aware ever since I came to the
state almost almost 50 years ago
that New Hampshire does not send the
names of committed patients
who are
committed
after meeting with the judge
because they're a danger to themselves
or others
so people who individuals who are
committed can leave the hospital
and their their names are not sent to
the National Data Bank
um and so they can go out and buy a gun
that has never seemed to be a
particularly good idea
um for one who wants to have safety in
our state
we don't keep track of those records so
we don't really know what happens to
those patients after they leave the
hospital in terms of whether a certain
percentage of them
commit violence towards themselves or
someone else
so that's one thing about this uh 1178
that doesn't really make sense to me and
it doesn't make sense to me either
because we're one of 50 states in this
country
and why shouldn't we do whatever we can
to prevent gun violence
now there was somebody who who made a
statement that uh
suicide is not a crime that is true but
it's not terribly a good idea and if we
can prevent it
a psychiatrist is mental health
individuals as families we would like to
do something to prevent it
now there's also uh a recent executive
order uh
preventing uh
or trying to regulate ghost guns
why does it not make sense
that we would have a mechanism
to
prevent people who
are
not allowed to purchase a gun
to get a gun by another means
and these ghost guns are being involved
in crimes more and more
three four years ago maybe ten percent
of crimes were committed with ghost guns
around the country now 33 percent are
and the percentages are going up
so it makes sense
if we want to prevent gun violence to
follow some
National laws as well as the laws in New
Hampshire
so that's why
not only the New Hampshire Medical
Society and the New Hampshire
Psychiatric Society but more than 70
medical societies around the country
are trying to encourage reasonable
Common Sense gun laws and that includes
the American psyche American Medical
Association so thank you very much
anybody have any questions
thank you thank you for Testament
chair recognizes James Grenier
and up next will be representative
Heather Raymond
well thank you for your time and I want
to thank each and every one of you
actually for your time for being here
every week
you probably don't hear it enough but
you it is appreciated by the worst of us
who are just kind of private citizens
hanging around
um I get up here about once a year at
most and this is the only Bill I'm going
to speak about so
um as you know already everyone knows
that hb78 seeks to repeal hb1178
and that bill tells
the agencies of New Hampshire that they
do not have to comply with any
unconstitutional law rule or mandate
imposed by the federal government
unconstitutional means that it is not
under the purview right of the federal
government but under the state
government
when you think of it it's a little silly
we shouldn't have to have a bill that
tells the federal government that they
can't do something that's not in their
rules you know
but um there it is that's where we are
in 2023
uh we can by the way regulate our own
rules here this is uh I know we're not
doing history but I just verified that
this is the chamber where we've been
continuously doing business since 1819
so you're a part of that
so I'll just ask you to I would ask you
as a citizen like yourselves the mark HP
78 is Ito
let the legislature go on with all the
many bills you have instead of repealing
one you just did last year
and continue to do the work of the
people in New Hampshire thank you
thank you for your testimony and your
kind words the chair recognizes
representative Heather Raymond and up
next will be Eric Leighton
okay
foreign
[Music]
Lancaster New Hampshire
um and I'm very honored to be addressing
you today and I would like to strongly
oppose HB 78 I say this to you as a
former federal employee a member of the
military with a long illustrious career
where I circled the globe at least three
times east to west north and south I've
served in two Wars and I've been in
areas of the world where there have been
more penguins than people
so I have a very in unique Insight on
the U.S federal government and life here
in New Hampshire and I'm very grateful
to be here as a citizen of New Hampshire
which is after all of my travels the
place that I truly believe is the safest
freest place in North America
this didn't happen by accident
it's in the DNA of New Hampshire
it's in the mortar of this very building
New Hampshire existed before the federal
government
it had a constitution before the federal
government and long after the federal
bloated Federal Behemoth passes away
into the Dustbin of History due to its
over uh printing of money and Corruption
New Hampshire will still be here
the state of New Hampshire has done a
wonderful job of protecting the rights
of its citizens
we have a exceptionally well-armed
populace and it's protected
by a limited government
that we're fortunate to have even people
here today who have actually put
legislation forth to protect the rights
of
citizens from an overstepping federal
government
that's an honor
the
less anyone have any doubt about where
I'm sorry let me just check one thing
here you want to pull something up for
you
I'm gonna add it there in one moment I
apologize
the article 7 of the New Hampshire
Constitution expressly recognizes I I
actually invite all of you to reference
that
expressly recognizes the sovereignty
of the State of New Hampshire as a
unique free independent Sovereign
Republic
when New Hampshire decided to join what
is now called the United States it
delegated certain things to it
the United States government today has
overstepped the bounds on so many levels
we see it we see it we see a politicized
FBI IRS Homeland Security ATF the Litany
of alphabet agencies goes on and on
and wise legislators with a sitting
Governor decided no
we are
residents of a place called New
Hampshire we recognize the rights of our
citizens and we will not allow federal
agents to come in and trample
the people that live here
and we're going to hold law enforcement
and agencies accountable and I want to
know and I'm grateful to know that my
County Sheriff My Town Police
the new New Hampshire uh um State Police
are there and they have my back
they're not going to be part of that
just perfidious
circus that we see in Washington DC
and whether you like Trump or Biden
Pelosi Schumer of the litany the circus
continues and even though they have lost
sight of what their mandate is I hope
and I pray that our legislators are wise
enough to recognize
the tragedy that is Washington D.C
and the cabal that is there and all the
many reasons why that's happening here
we do it differently we've codified it
we recognize it the government doesn't
give us rights it protects our rights
and I ask you each of you to remember
that
we do it differently here in New
Hampshire and I remind you we live free
or we die that's those words were said
in a specific contest and they and they
they they haven't lost their power today
I say this as a former member of the
military the instrument of
the agent of those policies
please remember that don't lose sight of
that we're not a county in the United
States of America we are a independent
Sovereign entity
the Tenth Amendment of the Constitution
recognizes us as such and specifically
gives police powers to the states
foreign
thank you for your testimony
the chair recognized Brian Berry
button got me that time
I'm gonna draw in a few documents that
helped found this state and this nation
United States Constitution
amendment number 10.
power is not delegated to the United
States by the Constitution nor
prohibited to it not prohibited by it to
the states and reserved to the states
respectively
or to the people
part first Bill of Rights constitution
of New Hampshire a great state article 7
which was touched upon
the people of this state have the sole
and exclusive right of governing
themselves as a free servant and
independent state and do and forever
Hereafter shall
exercise and enjoy every Power
jurisdiction and right pretending there
too which is not
I mean or may not Hereafter be by them
expressly delegated to the United States
of America and Congress assembled
it's not just about Firearms although we
are here talking about firearms
it is about government overreach
federal government Outreach in this case
it's creeping up everywhere
and guns Firearms we see what's going on
executive orders for this
reinterpretations for that I'm changing
this rule
the braces I'm sure those have been in
the news lately we're all familiar with
the braces that are becoming the the new
Terror of the gun world
a few years ago the ATF approved in a
letter saying yeah it's fine no problem
now for some reason they changed their
mind
they measure something a little bit
different and go oh no now it's now it's
going to be a short barrel rifle now you
need a stamp for it
we can go down the list of Education
CRT maybe so on and so forth we all know
what's in the news we all know what it's
about I don't have to Hash it out here
there'll probably be another committee
for that we can do that later on
but there is federal overreach
I believe I found this one each state
to pave their own costs
not to be separate from the United
States but to be their own state
each state is to be its own little
experiment
with doing it right in a lot of ways
no income taxes no sales tax
a thriving and growing economy here
low crime rate
lots of Natural Resources camping skiing
we have the coast we have lakes you name
it we're doing it right
we still have some work to do
we should be Paving and steering our own
course
in this case
we're saying let's not help the feds
with what could be unconstitutional laws
and regulation
law enforcement
Representatives like you across this
nation at every level
swear an oath to the Constitution of the
United States of America into the
constitution of the state in which you
serve
that's a serious oath I'm former
military I'm former law enforcement
and I can speak for myself I won't speak
for my brother over there
my oath has no exploration
I love our country with all its flaws
with all of our good history and all
that bad history with all of our
mistakes
we make it work
nowhere else can you have
such a diverse population
of religion race Creed origin come
together and make things work
no other country can you go to I can't
go to China become Chinese
I can't go to Brazil and become
Brazilian
but anybody in this world can come here
and become American
that's what's unique about it it's so
unique about our country and I love it
you may think of straight off course by
Adam
we had a masters of our own destiny here
this is just one example of overreach by
the federal government
let's take care of ourselves
not saying
the blow off the United States not the
same separate from them that's not what
I'm saying but there are some things
which we could stand up for in the state
and say that's enough
no
you don't need to come in here and pull
our resources you've got an
investigation to do you get a lot on
Force you'll go ahead and do it
our Troopers are out here saving lives
our officers are out here neighborhood
policing in many cases from Nashua to
Manchester to try and do the right thing
bridged that divide
protect and serve
feds have enough money they want some
people on to do an investigation for
federal crimes
let them handle it
thank you for your time
thank you for your testimony
represent oh excuse me Timothy Wolfe
and he'll be followed by John Hank
thank you
um
I am here to
oppose this bill
um it does seem
um almost like we should never have
needed this bill but that said it's it's
here and um I don't see what harm there
is in letting it stand
um you know when I look at something
you know it's very short here and it
said it once it says the bill repeals a
Prohibition of a state of the state from
enforcing any federal statute regulation
or presidential executive order that
restricts or regulates the rights of the
people to keep and bear arms
you know that's that's basic that's
that's our that's our rights why would
we want to
why would we want to restrict or
regulate that
um I mean I was a student of History
which most people don't know I graduated
UNH with a four-year degree a
non-western and had my fair share of um
American history known for you with
history lesson but the one thing that I
always found interesting was that that
most people didn't know is that the
United States Constitution
the people of this country did not want
to ratify it it's a beloved document to
us they didn't want to ratify it the
only way they were able to get the
document ratified was to add what we
call the Bill of Rights the first ten
amendments and if they and those were
known to be individual rights they they
didn't they realized that the document
gave too much power to a central
government
and they had just what a revolution
um or a war of insurrection depending on
your Viewpoint
um
uh against the Insurrection but it
basically
they realized it was overreaching and by
securing those individual rights
ensuring their individual rights they
allowed
the Constitution they said okay we will
ratify this because it secures
individual rights and article one two
and three that form the executive branch
that forms the legislature and the in
the the courts
the only reason that those are allowed
to exist is because we said okay we'll
allow this government to exist if we
have these individual rights if you
start taking away those rights you're
starting to take away public trust and
when you take away public trust I don't
know if we want to go down that road
because you know I put chills on my skin
thinking of uh you know if we were to
take this bill
and instead of the way it's written
if I can find it here again which I
probably can't
um
if we basically were to say
that we wanted to
have if it was something that restricted
say
I don't know freedom of religion
freedom of speech press
maybe
um in quartering soldiers in our homes
or right to a fair trial it just sets a
bad precedence and I uh basically my
concern with it more than anything uh
like I said I I don't see any reason to
repeal it and I do find real danger
um
in the fact that you know people you
know basically the Constitution is null
and void if people lose their individual
rights they do not have to accept an
executive branch they do not have to
accept a Judicial judicial branch they
do not have to accept the legislature if
they feel as though uh those
institutions are treading on their
individual rights
um that's it thank you
thank you for your testimony the chair
recognizes John hink
good afternoon I'm Dr John hink also
representing the New Hampshire
Psychiatric Society I'd like to agree
with everything my colleague Len corn
just said we'd like to support hb78 to
allow for federal gun safety laws such
as the application of the Brady Law in
New Hampshire
the Brady Act is a federal law enacted
in 1993 by the U.S Congress following
the assassination attempt against
President Ronald Reagan
um it prohibits firearm purchases from
certain individuals
who have been committed to a mental
institution
currently there are no State
prohibitions on individuals committed to
a mental institution from purchasing
firearms
thank you for your attention
thank you for your testimony
chair recognizes James Gaffney
thanks for the opportunity I'll try to
keep this brief I'd like to address a
comment that the previous speaker
offered in testimony there are in fact
federal laws that prohibit the ownership
of firearms
of people who are involuntarily
committed to mental institutions that's
well established
back to my own testimony if I may
the existing statute seems to be
well for lack of a better way of putting
it's like a dog you guys are supposed to
found and protect our rights you took
Oaths to uphold the the state and the
Federal Constitution
those constitutions have explicit
language in in there that says that
government shall not infringe upon our
rights and that we it confirms our
natural right to keep and bear arms and
defend ourselves our families our
property
etc etc etc so the existing statute
really is is a no-brainer and
the only reason I can think of that the
sponsors of this bill would want to
support unlawful actions to support
unconstitutional actions is because
they're getting ready to do something
that you might kill them over
I'm sorry to go there but it
if people are supporting and trying to
advocate for tyranny I'm not sure that
how anybody can can condone that
let alone a legislative body
your job is to protect and defend our
rights the constitution of this state
and our Federal Constitution were put in
place to limit what government can do
our our freedoms are are a function or a
product of the limitation of government
it's government that infringes upon
individual rights natural and otherwise
and it if we read through
depending on your familiarity of History
well why do we have a state constitution
why we have a Federal Constitution it
was because they were afraid of the
creation of an all-power overreaching
central government again I.E the English
got cramped right so the Constitution
has a limitation on on government I ask
you guys to uphold your constitutional
obligations and your oath to those
constitutions and itl this bill
thank you
thank you good testimony chair recognize
uh recognizes Dr Johan
uh thank you members of the committee I
hope you had a great lunch uh I'm glad
you took a recess even though you ruined
a joke my analysis said this bill delays
lunch and I couldn't use it as
effectively before but I thought I'd
give it to you now
um
this is a pretty simple thing and I'll
make it brief because I had the
pre-lunch speech ready for you so I'll
give you that
um
you know article 7 of the State
Constitution uh State sovereignty the
people of the state have the sole and
exclusive right of governing themselves
as a free Sovereign and independent
state and do and forever the Hereafter
shall exercise and enjoy every Power
jurisdiction and right pertaining here
to which is not or may not Hereafter be
by them expressly delegated to the
United States of America and Congress
assembled June 2nd 1784 prior to the
adoption of the U.S Constitution
I'm not going to read article 2a2 out
here on this committee you probably know
that but that's also very relevant to
this and for those reasons I think it's
very important that we as New Hampshire
retain our identity our laws and our
safety and keep this in place
um since it's been passed I have yet to
hear a complaint other than uh I believe
one of the complaints I heard was
officers should be concerned about doing
what is legal well I think that should
be across the board no matter what they
should always be concerned about doing
what is legal so please
um you know what to do with this
thank you
thank you for your testimony the chair
recognizes Nick Hubbard
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee for the opportunity to testify
in opposition to House Bill 78 today
the intent of House Bill 78 is to repeal
a provision in state law enacted last
year to protect the rights of granted
Staters from federal overreach free
market Economist and political theorist
Murray rothbard in his 1982 treaties the
ethics of Liberty offered this analogy
for an argument which I believe best
encapsulates the spirit of this bill
each of us is allowed to remain free in
all aspects and particularly if each of
us is allowed to retain weapons in the
right of self-defense then surely we
would all be at war against each other
and society would be wrecked therefore
let us turn over all of our guns and all
of our ultimate decision-making power
and the power to enforce our rights to
the Jones family over there the Jones
family will guard us from our predatory
instincts keep social peace and enforce
Justice
but the Cry of who would guard us from
the Jones family especially when we are
deprived of our weapons suffice to shut
down such a scheme
to regulate weapon ownership does
nothing to make the populace safer
instead it tips the balance of power
away from peaceful law-abiding
individuals who adhere to the
restrictions and in favor of other
unrestricted entities
this includes not only criminals
possessing such weapons in violation of
the law but the governments which insist
on disarming their subjects
during the Warsaw Ghetto uprising of
1943 detainees of the ghetto stage and
armed resistance against just such a
government
in a daring bit to save their lives in
the lives of those they loved in the
face of impending relocation to
concentration camps
roughly 700 of the 70 000 remaining
detainees fought to defend the ghetto
against Nazi troops for four weeks
those 700 people and their weapons which
they were prohibited from owning by the
government attacking them are the reason
there were any survivors from the Warsaw
Ghetto at all
years later Gerard Metro quoted one of
those survivors in the preface to his
book about how to build such a weapon as
saying there was only one thing I regret
very much that I didn't have a
submachine gun
that's Metro and many others following
in the same footsteps have ensured
individuals will continue to have access
to dangerous weapons whether or not the
ownership of such weapons is forbidden
or restricted therefore the wisest is
safest and most civilized course of
action is to ensure that the balance of
power is kept equal
By ignoring the Second Amendment to its
Constitution and enacting such laws as
the National Firearms Act the federal
government has violated the restrictions
it placed for itself on its power our
legislature should continue to assert
the rights of granite Staters against
this Federal overreach because it is
only the assertion of our rights that
preserves them
for this reason I urge the committee to
consider House Bill 78 and expedient to
legislate
thank you for your testimony
the chair recognizes Kimberly Morin
foreign
before I begin my testimony will be
quick but
um since the original bill that this is
trying to reverse was passed I don't
know of any firearm scaler who wasn't
still using ATF Form 4473 to conduct a
background check and um before they sell
a firearm right on form 4473
it says under question 21 Section 8 H
have you ever been adjudicated as a
mental defective or have you ever been
committed to a mental institution for
those who don't understand what
adjudicated as a mental defective mean
that means a court of law mandated a
person gets inpatient or outpatient
mental health treatment that person is a
prohibited person if you lie on any of
the questions on this form you commit a
felony
the adjudication in the court of law
shows up on the background check
I just wanted to clear that up
um this is the second piece of
legislation we've seen this year where
legislators who are supposed to
represent granted Staters are either
begging the federal government to
infringe upon our Second Amendment
rights or demanding that the state
legislature not protect our Second
Amendment rights from an overreaching
federal government this one's pretty
easy please vote in expedient to
legislate on this bill this legislature
is supposed to represent Granite Staters
not the federal government no matter
who's in office thank you
foreign
and the chair recognizes penny D
ude
thank you chair and members of the
committee I'm asking you itl HB 78 and
first you have to look at what problem
are we looking to solve those who
suggested it's unconstitutional there's
nobody borrowing them from the courtroom
doors if they believe it's
unconstitutional let them walk into
court and find out
but the bottom line is that you have to
look at is what are we trying to fix
we're asking them specifically to follow
the law and we're telling them more
importantly
that federal law enforcement officers
can't come in and order New Hampshire
Law Enforcement Officers around like
dogs
and that's really what we've had before
and this allows
regular Rank and file Law Enforcement
Officers to essentially refuse unlawful
orders and it allows them a shield from
doing so
because you have some at least in this
state the police Chiefs Association is
one of the most anti-gun associations
we've ever seen every time we are at the
state house if there's a pro firearm
Bill Chiefs are usually against it if
there's an anti-firm Bill Chiefs are
usually for it and you have to
understand those are the people that
order the rank and file around
and this law gives Rank and file an
opportunity to follow the law
but here's the bottom line we have a
governor that can order state workers
state employees state troopers to do
within the laws he chooses if he wants
state troopers to help the feds he can
ask them to but what you have here
anyone who's been out in any type of
scene there's a hierarchy on scenes
usually in an accident scene technically
the highest ranking Fire officer is The
Incident Commander but as a practical
matter they tend to be a little bit
different people and sometimes they
allow Weber's ranking officer of police
there to basically run the scene
and that's what how it works is a
practical matter but the bottom line is
just because the feds come into certain
areas and run their operations doesn't
mean that we should be kowtowing to them
and more importantly it's really an
unfunded mandate and the question is do
you want your tax dollars used the way
you think your officials are using them
or do you want them used the way the
feds come in and tell you and so we look
at this and you haven't heard one person
talk about one instance where this law
has been a problem
so you ask yourself why would I want to
itl it when there's not one problem not
one Incident That's come up
and we heard one person say well you
know I have this fear about this or I
worry about this
so we're gonna change a law that hasn't
caused any problem because one person
has a fear or concern
and they can't articulate what
specifically that fear of concern is
about
I'm back to connecting the dots you've
got to say this is my fear this is what
I think will happen
and it just hasn't happened in a decade
or so so the question you have to ask
yourself is why do we want to repeal
something that's working
and I go back to the fact that the
governor and all sorts of authorities
the Chiefs everyone can offer joint
ventures there's all sorts of other
things that can happen but the bottom
line is we're not their lackeys and we
shouldn't be
we're equal
that's the bottom line is even though
federal law has Supremacy when you talk
about the 10th Amendment and stuff where
equal group of states
and I'm happy to answer any mechanical
questions or anything else
your testimony
at this point I'll be closing the public
hearing on HB
78 oh we have one more you turn in a
pink card
sir did you turn in a pink card I
apologize Mr chairman I do not believe I
did but based on what I've heard I beg
your Indulgence
um sure when you're finished testifying
I need you to fill in a pin card please
keep it short and succinct
I'll do my very best I owe you that
the reason to itl this bill is summed up
in three words Gregory Peter DuPont
Mr Dupont native of Massachusetts
convicted of oui in Massachusetts in
that conviction could have brought a
sentence of up to two and a half years
in prison as no one was hurt and there
was no property damage there was no
prison sentence but the potential
sentence made him federally prohibited
in 2004 the Massachusetts General Court
specifically created a Firearms
licensing review board to consider
persons who had run afoul of the DUI Law
and it authorizes board to restore the
Civil Right to be armed of such persons
if after an evidentiary hearing the
person proved to the board that they had
changed their ways and had
we're not going to reoffend Mr Dupont
went before the board he convinced the
board to
issue a letter saying that he was
eligible to be armed and he could apply
for a license the board was not then and
is not now an issuer of licenses he
moved to New Hampshire he sought a
pistol and revolve her license he sought
an armed security guard license he fully
improperly disclosed
that he had been convicted and provided
proof that his civil right to be armed
had been restored I know these things
because as a non-attorney representative
the New Hampshire Supreme Court
graciously allowed me to appear as a
non-attorney
before it
because
Mr DuPont's licenses were revoked
on the basis of the Massachusetts
conviction
I think the feds had a hand in that they
could have prosecuted Mr Dupont on their
own
but Folks at Nashua police department
and I'm ashamed to say our own
Department of Safety revoked his
licenses
the licenses were shared under separate
laws there were two separate cases
that he brought
armed security guards don't make a
fortune and when his armed security
guard license was revoked
it broke his race book slashed his
income so
I stepped forward
to
file a brief on his behalf of the New
Hampshire Supreme Court and to argue his
cause a very kind attorney
stepped up pro bono
to
appeal the other revocation now here's
The Clincher New Hampshire had no
interest
in those reputations
we could have we meaning Department of
Safety a national PD could have accepted
the action of the Massachusetts
Firearms licensing review board they did
not
and as a result
the matter went through district court
for his pistol and revolver license at
Superior Court for his armed security
guard license both
were if you will
I guess prosecuted by the state on the
basis well if we let Mr Dupont acquire
Firearms by respecting the Massachusetts
decision our employees New Hampshire
state employees might be prosecuted
I thought that was a joke then I think
it's still a joke okay
the New Hampshire Supreme Court issued
an extraordinarily strong and favorable
decision restoring Mr DuPont's licenses
so you think that's the end of the
matter no someone in the AG's office I
do not know who
decided to seek review by the U.S
Supreme Court with a view to overturning
with a view to overturning the New
Hampshire Supreme Court decision
maybe that person wanted to Curry favor
with the feds but this is a real life
example of what happens when the feds
and the state decide to team up in this
case against someone who had done
nothing wrong who had been totally
honest with his licensors throughout
so to repeal
the statuted issue would be to encourage
further abuse of this sort just for the
record as a non-attorney representative
I could not by Court rule and therefore
did not charge Mr Dupont even a penny so
I met the cost of copying filing fees
out of my own pocket because I thought
what department of safety and Nashua
Pete did to him was just plain wrong
so the idea that you know this is sort
of theoretical no it isn't theoretical
it's happened you can google and find
the decision
Gregory Dupont versus National Police
Department
the Supreme Court of New Hampshire
rolled in 2050.
I'll be happy to take any questions
thank you for your testimony at this
point I am closing houseboat 78 and
we'll be opening House Bill 106 from
this point forward I am instituting a
two-minute rule we still have five bills
to get through before the end of the day
and testimony is unfortunately becoming
close to being repetitive so I would
encourage you to keep your comments to
the point on the bill we're talking
about and assume for the sake of
argument that we all understand or at
least know the Constitution thank you
and at this point I will recognize
representative Bradley to introduce her
bill
thank you good afternoon
I'm here today to testify in support of
HB 106.
a few years ago
I lost a friend to gun suicide
having HB 106 in place could have saved
his life
89 of all gun deaths in New Hampshire
are suicides in New Hampshire the rate
of gun deaths has increased by 26
percent compared to a 13 increase
Nationwide
and currently 19 states have implemented
Arco
Oracle is a forward-facing court order
that asked the court to assess future
Danger
temporarily removing access to guns when
a person is in crisis
under HB 106 law enforcement and family
members can enlist the help of a court
to issue an erpo
an in-person petition can be filed in
the county where the respondent or
petitioner resides
sufficient evidence is proof that is
clear and convincing which is a
rightfully High bar to meet
signs include recent Acts or threats of
violence
a history of domestic violence
and a past violent criminal history
HB 106 establishes clear
and appropriately high standards that
must be made before court issues and
erpo
HB 106 also makes it a criminal offense
to falsify a petition or use the process
to harass
and the petitioner must appear in court
under oath
a temporary or vote can be issued in
emergency situations
respondents that have a temporary or bow
issued against them can request an
expedient expediated expediated hearing
to occur occur within three to five days
court-ordered mental health valuations
are already a part of court procedures
HB 106 allows loved ones to intercede in
a crisis situation without involuntary
commitment
constitutionally supported due process
is built in throughout the reporting
hearing and notice process
this is a public safety specific civil
action
law enforcement are expected to
intercede in instances of imminent
danger
both with and without a Court warrant
in the case of irfo the issuance of the
order requires surrender
I ask that the committee recommend OTP
thank you foreign
thank you for introducing the bill
at this point I recognize representative
David Muse
thank you Mr chair
um one of the things that I thought I
would do because this is a a nine page
bill it's very long it's very
complicated and it has quite a history
because I thought I just might spend
some time going through what the bill
does and and what it doesn't do
so as quickly as I can
um lender the bill law enforcement
officers and family or household members
in New Hampshire who recognize warning
signs of danger could enlist the help of
a court in filing a petition uh to issue
an extreme risk protection order
unlike our domestic violence or stalking
protective order process the procedure
for seeking an herbal order is a civil
versus a criminal process that focuses
solely on limiting a person's access to
Firearms if they are found to be an
immediate threat to themselves or to
others
under the bill Law Enforcement Officers
family or household members and intimate
partners of the respondent can petition
for an order
there are two types of herpos that can
be that can actually be issued a
temporary order and a final order
a temporary order can be issued in
emergency situations if a judge finds
there is reasonable cause to believe
that the respondent poses a significant
risk of causing personal injury to
himself or herself in the immediate
future by having access to firearms and
ammunition
in urgent situations the order can also
be issued ex-party that is without
notice to either side and before a full
hearing but ex parte orders are only
issued when circumstance I'm sorry when
circumstances pose a real risk that
irreparable harm will result if the
judge doesn't take immediate action
without hearing from all of the decides
in this in this in the dispute
temporary orders can last no longer than
seven days and after that time the court
must hold a full hearing at which time
all parties have the opportunity to
appear and present evidence
respondents who are subject to a
temporary europeo can request an
expedited hearing which must take place
within three to five days of their
request
the temporary order automatically
expires on the hearing date for the
final order
if granted the final order can remain in
effect for no more than one year and can
only be issued after notice to the
respondent in a full hearing at which
all parties have the opportunity to be
heard
vital orders can only be issued if the
court finds there is clear and
convincing evidence
that will respondent poses a significant
risk of causing personal injury to
himself or to others by having access to
firearms and ammunition
the court also has the option during the
final hearing to order a mental health
or chemical dependency evaluation
throughout the process the person asking
for the order Bears the burden of
proving based on all relevant evidence
that the respondent poses a serious
threat to themselves or to others by
having firearms representative I'm going
to have to stop you at that point I'll
let you go a little over to two minutes
I will however give you as much time as
you like during the executive decision
to address us
um so we're gonna have to move on to the
next Witness
thank you at this point
um representative John Burt
thank you Mr chairman and find committee
members I oppose this bill as I always
have
it seems to keep coming back like a bad
penny
one of the biggest reasons I oppose this
is because I'm from the old Vermont
not the Vermont today but the old
Vermont that used to be there
the new Vermont has this in a few of my
friends have been caught up in this with
an X that has a grind you know you know
to get back at them they'll make up
something and let's go to the punishment
of this if you make up a lie
it really doesn't exist
because when I sat on your committee
criminal justice when a policeman came
up once I asked him
what's the chances of you Prosecuting he
said zero
because you can't know the intent of the
person you can't prove that they're
lying I mean sometimes you can but they
still just won't prosecute anybody that
lies and it happens all the time
the other reason I'm against this is you
know I think most of you know who I am
yeah I I have a huge Target on my back
and you know there's some people that
don't like me for some reason and I
don't understand why
but there is they would love to have
this
to make up some stuff on me and take my
guns because I'm very vocal about my
guns that I have
until I had the boat accident of course
they're all gone now but people want to
to you know harm certain people there
are certain crazy people out in this
community
and sadly I have them in Goffstown
that would love to have this bill and
make up something on me or other people
that dare to push the envelope which I
do thank you please oppose this I tell
it to me it's exactly very good
representative
chair recognizes James Gaffney
and he will be followed by Kathy Holmes
thanks for the opportunity to speak
I would hope that you will vote this
bill itl we've tested mode testified
many times on this bill it's not con
it's not consistent with the
Constitution of the United States nor is
it consistent with the constitution of
New Hampshire article 20 clearly states
in a Civil Trial that involves uh
property exceeding fifteen hundred
dollars that person has a right to a
jury trial
the proposed bill will accuse try and
convict and apply punishment without the
party ever being made aware let alone
having an opportunity to face their
witness or defend themselves in no way
shape or form is this bill
constitutional or lawful as we see and
you will hear I'm sure others testify
uh our our current existing ex parte
laws are used as a matter of of course
ins you know uh divorce proceedings
they're abused regularly there are no
consequences to it the courts don't even
try to prosecute it we have no data
quantifying the problem but any lawyer
that practices family law will tell you
as a matter of course they're abused on
a regular basis
New York State the New York state
supreme court just invalidated declared
an unconstitutional their emergency
protective order
are we really going to go down that
route too especially in light of the the
Bruin decision at the Supreme Court
which is cast doubt on pretty much all
of these laws
I I don't think it's uh it's a
a good place to go thank you
thank you for your testimony the chair
recognizes Kathy Holmes
Kathy Holmes Chichester I'm against this
bill
and the main point you'll find in my
orange box there the actual law breaker
accuses the innocent and gets away with
it again and again they use the system
to suit a myriad of purposes and this
happened to me and then my husband just
because
is by proxy
uh we had a past tenant
long 10-year court case got the Judgment
10 years previously they owed us twelve
thousand dollars pure rent just to keep
the lawsuit simple we left out damages
pure rent
and over the course of their
manipulations and lying and uh they got
warrants for their arrest we uh well we
were a thorn in their side
and how convenient when I was substitute
teaching in Concord happened to be in
this their second grade girls class I
don't even know the last names when
you're subbing you don't know people's
last names but
um So within a flash
we I was accused of stalking
and they were afraid
what might I do
so
we got the bad advice from the police oh
ask for an expedited hearing oh we did
and but yet we weren't heard
and we tried to bring up what the
situation was the judge said I can't
hear that that was a previous that's
another case
when I asked why won't they be arrested
I can't hear that
so my husband lost the guns and I lost
my job
and because we asked for that expedited
hearing we had to go to the New
Hampshire Supreme Court that was our
only recourse expensive
and here this tenant over the years they
were living in our property that was a
proven liar we
time and time again Liars lie and they
keep on lying man at this time I have to
cut you off at two minutes
um we will we do have that and we
appreciate it and if any of the members
would like to ask further questions
um you can approach bottom to verify my
testimony by the court case you can look
it up I will and I appreciate that thank
you very much
and again the chair hates to have to cut
anybody off but there's just only so
many that's left in the day
um the chair recognizes
Dr Leonard Hort cord
why do you change
thank you again for hearing my testimony
as a psychiatrist I have witnessed many
situations where
individuals with serious mental illness
are suicidal
um sometimes even homicidal and there's
no actions really that we can take until
after
uh some violent episode takes place
23 days ago I attended a funeral
of a 26 year old young man who I used to
treat I still treat his mother
and she knew that her son was very
paranoid
and was a potential danger to himself
but she could do nothing
and she told me at the funeral how sad
she was that she could do nothing to
prevent his impulsive act this
bill
a so-called red flag law
are present in 19 States and they have
reduced suicide in particular and I
encourage you all to consider passing
this law so that we can do something to
prevent mostly suicide but also
potentially homicide thank you very much
the chair recognizes Mr George gerick
thank you George R jurik g-u-r-i-c-k Jr
I live in Farmington New Hampshire
I live in Farmington New Hampshire and I
represent no one except myself
the uh treating House Bill 106 is a red
flag law is entirely appropriate but
what is
um
in my research missing from many of
these is the consideration for what is
called in New in American criminal law
state of mind
and before the fact to bedrock
principles and American criminal law
before the fact
in many applications to seize a person's
private property under red flag laws
there's nothing in the person's
background that they are convicted of
crime
did a crime or anything else
before the fact
also to secure a conviction in
misdemeanors and felonies the
prosecution
Beyond Reasonable Doubt must
get the ruling that the state of mind
has been established
State of Mind here in New Hampshire is
with purpose
with knowledge
recklessly or negligently
and State of Mind applies to Red Flag
laws to show that they're
unconstitutional red flag laws
everywhere because they don't take those
foundations into
effect
thank you
thank you for your testimony
chair recognizes Timothy Wolfe
thank you
um
I'll just State you know this bill of
all the bills today this one uh is
really kind of horrific to me it scares
me
um and it's I understand the intent but
it's just the methodology uh it it's um
it's basically saying that you're guilty
until you're proven innocent and the ex
parte not having representation you know
as you know again uh as constitutional
right just having the ability to face
your accuser uh you don't get that
um I understand these situations that
they use them as a difficult situation
but I just don't think it's a path we
want to go down to I feel like we're
treading two uh it's it's a I feel like
it's a fine
um sheet of ice we're kind of trying to
walk across here and
um I I think the cold water underneath
is something we don't want to go into
um it just I think there's too much
potential for abuse I think this could
be politicized
um and I really
um don't it just doesn't feel who we are
as a Americans
um it doesn't I I understand the
intention but I think there's got to be
a different way than this it just does
not feel right to me
um you know I situation with this that
comes to mind
and I I'm trying to be respectful of my
language here but you know if there's a
300 pound man per dating a 95 pound
woman
and
they
somebody calls and and uh and and
basically uh you and this man's being
abusive and they get a restraining order
or whatever
um it does not not much saying that that
300 pound man couldn't red flag this 95
pound woman because she knows she's got
a gun
and that night after the police come and
take her gun she comes in
he's waiting there for
and you know we probably know what the
outcome would be there I'm overwhelmed
that uh you know three to one body
weight ratio and physically stronger
thank you that's your time okay thank
you
it sure recognizes Holly Stevens
okay
chair Roy members of the committee thank
you for the opportunity to testify today
my name is Holly Stevens and I am the
director of public policy for Nami New
Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness
Nami is a
non-profit Grassroots organization whose
mission is to improve the lives of all
people impacted by mental illness and
suicide through support education and
advocacy on behalf of Nami New Hampshire
I'm here today to speak in favor of
House Bill 106 relative to explain
extreme risk protection orders
the United States Surgeon General has
identified that suicide is a major
public health issue in the United States
and one that is largely preventable
however we have done little as a state
or a society to prevent suicide
the impact of even a single death is
profound and ripples into our family
friends Schools workplaces First
Responders and Beyond
it is important to note that 90 of all
people who survive a suicide attempt do
not go on to die by Suicide
unlike almost every other means of
suicide use of a fire firearm in the
suicide attempt is almost always lethal
and leaves little opportunity for
intervention
while people may contemplate suicide for
a long period of time once they make the
decision to end their life the window of
time before they make an attempt is
often very small
toward that end temporarily restricting
access to lethal means in this case
firearms
is one tool
that can help reduce
the Public Health crisis of suicide
as indicated in the accompanying chart
that I provided you in New Hampshire
suicide is the second leading cause of
death
of people ages 15 to 35 the third
leading cause of death
I'll wrap up in one second sir I
apologize let me just wrap up by saying
that you know simply put you've got the
chart you can look at it
um temporarily restricting Firearms when
individuals pose a significant risk to
themselves for others is one tool that
we can use to reduce suicide New
Hampshire thank you very much and thank
you for your testimony committee will
read your submitted testimony as well
um the chair calls John hink MD
foreign
[Music]
representing the New Hampshire
Psychiatric Society in support of HB 106
the Psychiatric Society in New Hampshire
is a branch of the American Psychiatric
association APA the APA recognizes the
critical Public Health need for Action
to promote safe communities and reduce
deaths and injuries
due to firearm-related violence
many deaths and injuries from gun
violence can be prevented through
National and state legislation and
regulations
the APA view is a problem of
firearm-related deaths and injuries as a
public health issue and supports
interventions that reduce the risk of
such harm
the APA supports restricting access to
firearms for persons who conduct whose
conduct indicates they are risk to
themselves or others
extreme risk protection order laws in
other states have been shown to reduce
suicide rates
these types of laws exist in 19 States
and the District of Columbia
they allow for family or police to
petition a court to ask for temporary
removal of guns from people
who they fear may be at risk of farming
themselves or others
in Connecticut
in extreme risk protection order law was
passed and was shown to prevent suicides
research by Swanson regarding the
Connecticut Law showed that for every 10
to 20 guns removed one suicide death was
prevented
over half of gun related deaths in the
United States are deaths by Suicide
and legislation such as HB 106 may help
reduce those deaths
another study by kevisto and Phelan in
showed that risk-based Firearms seizure
laws in Connecticut and Indiana were
associated with reduced firearm suicide
rates
a particular concern gun violence is now
the leading cause of death in children
in the United States
for the first time in 2020 more children
died from gunfire than motor vehicle
accidents with
3597 lives lost
30 percent of child gun deaths were due
to Suicide thank you that's your time
doctor could I give you my custom
written absolutely we encourage you and
to study yes please
and if it's one copy we'll have copies
made and distributed to the committee
um at this point the chair recognizes
Elliot axelman
again for anyone who is not in the room
when the hearing started testimony is
limited to two minutes at this point
please
hello my name is Elliot I go by ALU
axelman I live in Hooksett with my wife
and my son I'm speaking in opposition to
House Bill 106 the erpo red flag laws
plain and simple red flag laws violate
due process on its face
we all learned in first or second grade
in Civics that were Presumed Innocent in
this great United States until presumed
until proven guilty beyond a shadow of a
doubt with a jury the judge and a whole
courtroom
when flag laws take what any person
could exhibit red flags if someone
mentions uh joke or they're angry or
they seem upset or anything and it
punishes them by taking away a natural
right as protected by the Second
Amendment and article two a I believe of
the New Hampshire Constitution it
punishes them with hearsay evidence ex
parte hearing without their
constitutional natural right to face
their accuser without them being present
without them knowing
and it punishes them forces them after
the fact to pay for a lawyer which you
may know costs hundreds of thousands or
millions of dollars which I don't have
that kind of money on me and then they
can go to court and try to reverse a
judgment and if you've gone to court to
try to reverse a judgment you know it's
pretty difficult it would cost hundreds
of thousands of dollars in lawyers fees
so it's flipped you're presumed guilty
and punished until you prove your
innocence in the country I thought I
grew up in you're presumed innocent
until someone proves you're guilty
it also violates the Second Amendment
which says shall not be infringed and
you'll notice some amendments actually
have some exceptions like the fourth and
fifth amendments but upon probable cause
but upon you know a search specific
search the second amendment has no such
exceptions it says shall not be
infringed the founders could have put
exceptions in there but they didn't for
anything that could be considered a red
flag
um so for anything that could be they
didn't put exceptions for potentially
but flag Behavior or speech speaking of
speech where flag laws may actually
violate the First Amendment too that
there have been some cases that went
into federal courts I think the Supreme
Court of of uh speech that someone made
that was posting song lyrics that were
uh pretty intense and passionate and
they were he was red flagged for song
lyrics
um I don't think it was even Eminem but
I think it was a little less intense
than that but if you post any any song
like that they could be a red flag
because he says some some pretty
um intense ridiculous stuff that should
count yeah thank you very much I'll try
to submit testimony to them please do I
appreciate it thank you
the chair recognizes Kimberly Morin
that's you're so evil no I'm gonna cut
stuff out and try to be quick about this
uh this is the same route here until
midnight what hey hey watch it this is
the same degree just in Draconian
legislation that New York City
billionaire Michael Bloomberg spent
thousands of dollars pushing a few years
ago so we'll remind you why this
legislation is so bad aside from the
fact that it's completely discriminatory
against a subset of granite Staters
um pretty much anyone and their brother
can make an accusation against an
unknowing law abiding gun owner your
ex-mother-in-law who hates that you left
her abusive son a former Psychopathic
roommate who was still angry and moved
out even if it was two years ago a step
cousin of your stepson of your husband
from a second marriage you get the drift
and of course the police can file a
petition on anyone at any time ironic
coming from the same people who support
that defund the police movement the bar
is set so low for evidence that pretty
much anything goes all the petitioner
has to do is convince a judge that they
believe the accused is thinking about
thinking about harming themselves or
others sometime in the future in other
words the petitioner has a crystal ball
and can see into the future in the
courts and law enforcement will act as
thought police the accused could have
written or said something out of anger a
couple of years ago that's considered
evidence the rules for evidence are not
the same as in a criminal case who are
the accused law abiding gun owners who
have committed no crime I'm going to
repeat that the accused are law-abiding
gun owners who have committed no crime
once a petition has been granted
surprise the thought police are your
door confiscating your firearms and you
have no idea why
someone already talked about the the
thousands that the accused would have to
spend to get their rights back uh
proponents of the red flag Bill have
talked about suicide and all the states
that have red flag laws in place neither
suicides or homicides were decreased red
flag laws did absolutely nothing there's
another law we do have on the books in
New Hampshire called involuntary
admissions this is specific to mental
health applies to every single Granite
stator there's due process and it's
adjudicated by a court and that actually
provides and mandates mental health care
whether outpatient or inpatient and as
we already know spoke about it earlier
you're adjudicated mentally how to get
mental health help you're a prohibited
person
HP 106 isn't about protection it's about
gun confiscation Bill of Rights be
damned and you know it's really really
kind of ironic a New York state supreme
court judge just ruled Michael
Bloomberg's red flag law
unconstitutional in the state of New
York
please vote in expedient to legislate
the thought crimes in the book 1984 were
fictional they weren't meant to be a
road map for real life especially not in
New Hampshire
thank you have you um submitted your
testimony in writing
a chair calls Chase simkin
you have to
I do have testimony Mr chairman and I
have the pink card that I promised you
foreign
I will consider that you have given me
the two-minute warning without of course
use of the starter pistol
h B 106 has two defects and these
defects are common to most red flag laws
first a person who is the target
of
a red flag action needs to have their
attorneys fees and costs paid from tax
dollars at their chosen attorneys
regular hourly rate
defending one of these things is tens of
thousands of dollars
most folks can't write a check for that
amount
second
any red flag law has to have in it a
right of private action to bring the
prosecution for perjury against someone
who mislead support into granting a red
flag order
perjury is a
basically never prosecuted
but since a red flag order can cause
tremendous financial and reputational
damage to a person there has to be short
recourse
so that
the right of private action means the
person who's wrongly targeted falsely
accused hires an attorney who then is
authorized by law to bring and prosecute
a perjury charge
and again that attorney has to be paid
their normal hourly rate attorneys are
not charities
thank you Mr chairman I'll be happy to
answer questions and I think I'm within
the two-minute limit
thank you for your testimony thank you
we'll stay well calls Joanne Brown
hello and thank you I believe 106 is
essentially good intentions gone wrong a
family the definition could be an
ex-spouse who no longer lives at the
same address which means women suffering
for an abusive ex could be stripped of
her main line of defense by her ex
reporting her many people suffering
mental health issues don't care about
laws or penalties this bill will arm
abusers with another way to weaken their
victims law enforcement as defied in the
bill doesn't even have to be in their
Hometown it could be from any city or
town I'd like to remind you in 2021 the
FBI highlighted highlighted moms
speaking at school boards it would have
been very easy for the FBI to contact
local police to Target us
foreign
people lie they lie all the time I know
I was in a relationship with a
pathological liar
and we've seen that on the testimony on
the gun background checks criminals
don't tell the truth
but the big problems of this bill
is that it's based on predictions not on
actions the other main problems of the
court is not bound by any technical
Rules of Evidence
and the temporary order does not require
notice to the respondent or defendant
C-section 159 F4 what's worse is the
temporary extreme risk protection order
is an ex parte hearing which means the
defendant is not even included and
cannot defend themselves this is
unconstitutional plain and simple thank
you
thank you for your testimony
Lena nerk
my name is Lana nerk and I represent
Mom's demand action for gun sense in
America I'm testifying in support of HB
106 the extreme risk protection order
bill
I support the extreme risk protection
order bill because it provides families
a proven tool to reduce gun suicides and
mass shootings I will focus my comments
on gun suicide because a shocking 89
percent of gun deaths in New Hampshire
are suicides
gun suicide in New Hampshire has
increased 61 percent between 2011 and
2020. compared to a 12 percent increase
Nationwide
many gun violence tragedies are preceded
by red flags warning signs that are
often noticed by family members reducing
a suicidal person's access to Firearms
by temporarily removing them from when
them when that person is clearly in
crisis could save their life
data shows that having access to a
firearm triples one's risk of death by
Suicide and states that have passed this
type of protective order or red flag law
have seen decreases in fire firearm
suicide rates
my personal experience working with
families in New Hampshire
in crisis reinforce my belief that
families deserve access to every tool
that can help prevent warning signs from
escalating into tragedy
the ability to temporarily limit access
to lethal Firearms by individuals in
crisis can help save lives
thank you
thank you for your testimony
representative Hall
sure is
it it sounded like you said Hall I said
we're in the hall I probably did
pronounce it wrong I'm sorry that's okay
good afternoon Representatives thank you
for sitting there I know this is a long
day
um I have four documents I want to turn
into you one is a letter from the New
Hampshire Firearms Coalition regarding
all the bills I would ask the clerk that
a copy be placed in each bill folder
that's listed on that letter instead of
me speaking multiple times I covered it
all in one letter
there is a letter from former
representative Itza relative to this
bill in particular I would have asked
that you would add that to the file
second is a supreme court a third is a
Supreme Court decision that's worth
reviewing and fourth is the famous that
we've been talking about New York
Supreme Court's Court decision that came
out late December that has to do with
the bill at hand
I would like to read a couple of pieces
from that particular Supreme Court
decision so everybody's on the same page
and I'm going to ask for an extra minute
if I can from the committee only because
this keeps coming up
on August 30th the petitioner filed with
the court I'm cutting out a few words
names and things an application for a
temporary extreme risk protection order
in his application the petitioner
alleged that his estranged girlfriend
was a threat to herself the petitioner
or another person that was the grounds
for this entire case
okay this is the exact same case former
speakers have talked about that says oh
this is about suicide
at the conclusion of this court case one
or two pages from the end
the judge right or the Supreme Court
writes however when viewed objectively
the law which is their law CPL are
63-a's goal of removing weapons from
otherwise lawful possession of of their
owners with adequate sorry without
adequate constitutional safeguards
cannot be condoned by this court
therefore temporary extreme risk
protection orders extreme risk
protection orders are deemed
unconstitutional by this court
going on further it cannot be stated
clearly enough that the Second Amendment
is not a second class right nor should
it ever be treated as such
that is the recent Supreme Court
decision on the heels of sorry New York
Supreme Court decision on the heels of
some of the Supreme Court decisions
all of these bills that we've heard
today violate constitutional protections
all of these bills today okay would if
they came out of committee would run
afoul of
um house rule 45a which commends or
commands us not to pass with a positive
recommendation any bill that violates
the Constitution
two years ago this bill was was sent to
this committee I know hurry up two
million okay and it was a financial
protection order at that time that's how
they were trying to get it through at
least they've been on this this year
they aren't intending to take our
Firearms representative we we did
actually Grant you an extra 30 seconds
okay in there and we are going to have
to okay this is a civil process not a
criminal process if it was a criminal
process all the new protections that the
courts are looking for would be in place
but this process by its design is
intended to circumvent those civil
protections thank you thank you
foreign
Barry
with one of my favorite books right here
if you all could please I'm sorry Brian
Joseph Barry just New Hampshire I own
Next Level firearms in Salem New
Hampshire
Article 15 writes of the Accused at your
convenience please
an essential proven guilty in our
country however
page nine
line 26 the respondent shall have the
burden of proving by clearing convincing
evidence that the respondent is no no
longer possesses a significant risk of
causing bodily injury to himself or
herself
or others by having a firearm like
what there's no due process at all
you're taking personal property from
people taking it on the mere suspicion
that somebody may be a danger to
themselves
and I teach this kind of personally
because on the back of my business cards
I put the suicide hotline
nowhere in this bill
and no one else and this hearing today
has mentioned about the person who's in
distress
why aren't we going to deploy
a specialist or a psychiatrist to go to
the house hey we understand that you're
having a bad moment you're thinking
about hurting yourself can we talk to
you can you come with us to the
facilities we can talk
he's aware that is a problem
why are they going to go and get
petition to take personal property away
instead of going to seek help from
professionals
call The Suicide Hotline call a doctor
call 9-1-1 hey I need someone down here
to help the person who's in distress
we're more concerned with taking away
the firearms
than waiting a few days until he can get
a hearing
for the person who's in distress but we
leave them with their car keys alcohol
over the kind of drugs prescription
drugs rope kitchen knives chlorine
bleached so on and so forth
if it's that serious
ladies and gentlemen you really care
about people that much
but don't worry about it thank you for
your testimony two minutes
thank you don't worry about the
materials we're about the person please
thank you
representative Manion
I am uh Tom mannion I'm uh represent
Hillsboro One Pelham I'm here to speak
against HP 106. everybody covered uh the
due process component of this really
well and so I'm gonna cut through a good
chunk of my testimony here
um there's something that nobody covered
uh as an Iraq war veteran I fortunately
emerged mentally sound from my time over
there not all of us did while the VA
offers free Mental Health Care there's a
free fear amongst veterans that if they
seek help their guns will be taken away
this is a very rare real fear amongst
that community
the mere existence of red flag laws with
language about potential harm to
yourself it's understandable why the
Vets feel this way so instead of getting
the help that they need they'd rather
tough it out
they'd rather grapple with their demons
alone and have than have their firearms
confiscated and I completely understand
however the deadly scenario the red flag
law is attempting to prevent can become
a reality instead I asked the committee
to itl HP 106 and I'm willing to take
any questions
thank you for your testimony
Marie Cassidy
my name is Marie Cassidy and I live in
Peterborough New Hampshire and I am a
volunteer with Mom's demand action for
gun sense in America I'm here to testify
in favor of HP 106.
the importance of this public safety
issue is personal to me
I have lost two family members to gun
suicide
both young men Edward Rogers and Fred
shields were veterans dealing with PTSD
at the bill such as this one that would
allow family members to request the
removal of firearms had been in place my
family might still be whole
gun suicide death rates in New Hampshire
are more than 25 percent higher than the
national rate
the granite state rates 26 in the
country for gun suicide deaths
suicide is the second leading cause of
death for ages 10 to 14 44 in New
Hampshire
on average one person dies by suicide
every 68 hours in our state
nine out of ten Firearms suicide
attempts end in death
suicides account for the majority of gun
deaths in our state 89 percent
data from states that have enacted
herbal laws suggest one life is saved
for every 10 to 11 gun removals carried
out under the law
suicide is an impulsive Act
guns are a fast deadly way to act on
those impulses
people considering suicide often give
some signs of their intentions
passage of hb-106 would allow the family
members and loved ones who see these
intentions to act
to have weapons removed and to help
ensure that those they love and those
around them are kept safe and whole
thank you
thank you Miss Cassidy I speak for all
of our the criminal justice members and
I offer you a condolences for your loss
Brian blackton
I ask to itl this bill please
this is merely a red flag gun seizure
bill
it is discriminatory to Firearms only
and not to other possible dangerous
weapons such as Motor Vehicles hammers
knives baseball bats poisons alcohol
bottles and any other weapon like if you
look on WMUR today the woman you use her
exercise wrote to kill her three
children
but we don't see that in the bill
this bill is also right for abuse by a
spurned spouse significant other or a
police officer you may have had an issue
with
it is not difficult to get on the wrong
side if you file complaints against them
as we know they are not above abusing
Authority while it may be a minority it
only takes one
this is another punitive proposal to a
firearm owner as they must pay storage
for their Liberty strip from them and
the respondent must prove his or her
innocent Which flies in the face of
constitutional protections
it is also less than believable that
someone will be prosecuted under 159 f11
as we see domestic violence cases
based on untruths fail and no charges
are ever brought I know this is a fact
because I represented a man last year a
Conga District Court he was found not
guilty of domestic violence and she was
proven to have committed perjury and was
never charged
further charging quality is skewed in
this bill from Felony possession to
misdemeanor attempt for application
lies when it's a federal felony for
lying on the same 44 73 application form
this bill is flawed thank you
thank you for your testimony
representative Newman
yes thank you I'm Sue Newman I'm from
Hillsboro for nashua's Ward 2 and I
support this legislation
unfortunately everything I've put down
most of it has all been said and
especially I didn't get your name but
the not the most recent mom but the one
before her she really I was scratching
out things along the way she covered
just about everything however
I will comment that I know no amount of
legislation
can mandate or require good rational
safe
Behavior or for someone to make good
choices we just can't legislate good
behavior but I do believe that extreme
this extreme risk Bill does provide a
way a mechanism to intervene in
situations before warning signs and
exhibited disturbing behaviors become
tragedies
I'm going to roll back just a little bit
I think 2018 the Parklands Florida
school shooting and not too long after
that
awful tragic occurrence happened Florida
did pass red flag laws and they did it
primarily because the shooter at that
school had been he was he was made
noticed to police and other officials
several times before that and I think
they felt we could have we could have
done something
true story
several years ago I was having a casual
conversation with the United States
senators staff person we were talking
about background checks who could
qualify to get a firearm who wasn't
allowed to get a firearm and so forth
and all of a sudden it came okay but
what do you do about the person maybe
your brother they've lost their job the
wife took off the mortgage is late and
the dog just got run over by a car and
there's a firearm in the house what do
you do
and it was
there was silence she had nothing more
to say I had nothing more to say so if
there can be something
in the form of an intervention that is
out there it's a tool I hope it could be
used as for comments made by several
people as to what's constitutional or
not I'm aware of the court case that was
cited but I'm also aware that as I came
early this morning I hadn't seen any
news crawler that 19 states that have
red flag laws have repealed all their
laws because of Any court case yet so I
maybe some fact checking would be
helpful so everybody knows what is
actually fact what's constitutional and
whatever thank you very much I would
support
OTP thank you
thank you representative
Bill Rogers
thank you again
um something that hasn't been touched on
but I thought of is let's think of a law
enforcement response potentially we have
someone who's in a psychotic break or in
crisis
and someone has just turned them in that
they want their guns taken away
you think the law enforcement agency is
going to go knocking on the door
politely think about the response that
they have to make
and now you're putting law enforcement
potentially In Harm's Way
over this as well only to find out it's
an ex-husband who's pissed off we all
know ex-husbands don't lie
so the the the potential for abuse the
law enforcement
putting life with them at Jeopardy for
someone who wants to kill himself why
why instead of one person dead now
you've got three makes no sense as well
as innocent until proven guilty not
guilty until proven innocent thank you
thank you for your testimony
John Bunker
just as a friendly reminder we are
limiting testimony to two minutes
everybody's doing a fantastic job thank
you
foreign
good afternoon I'm John Bunker I live in
Stratham New Hampshire
I strongly support this bill
and I support it for two reasons
it is rational
it is reasonable
and it's common sense
19 other states have also thought the
same
I have a handout for you
and this is from the Johns Hopkins
Center for gun violence and solutions
it's uh what we refer to in the academic
world is a literature review of
public policy
in this particular one has 17 references
that are peer reviewed on this
particular law
I would encourage you as you deliberate
the testimony you've heard to refer to
these citations
to get an appreciation for the research
that's going into this field and I'll
end with a quote from a researcher at
Johns Hopkins
when I look at the landscape of gun
violence prevention policy in this
country
in the possibilities in the progress
I'm very hopeful
by bringing science to policy
we're getting good new laws that are
making a difference in our communities
every day and this is a prime example
thank you
Andrew Schuler
yeah I just had a quick note here um so
house bill 106. so when looking at his
historical uh American history the
government was formed to serve the
people and if the government wasn't
serving a people it was the duty of the
government to handle the situation to
remove those not serving the people
which means that the there's a risk of
the government official losing her job
because of the civilians well this bill
is trying to flip that on its side The
Government Can intervene into your life
and take away your rights because of
somebody said so and that somebody said
so it could be neighbor friend former
friend lover or another government
official but because you don't know you
have no recourse you have no it could it
could allow for government to just
intervene in your life and
there's nothing you can do about it and
therefore I suggest uh itl uh 106. thank
you
thank you for your testimony
Dr Hannon
okay start the timer
um
Johanna from Governors New Hampshire
I'll try to be brief I'm going to be
quick but that's not to be a
disrespectful topic it's a serious topic
so
um I'm going to run through this uh no
adequate due process protections are
less reliable
um
and there's no reason for a person to
participate in their accident to be
required to be at their their hearing
then they can remove have their firearms
removed and their rights lost but there
is a hearing required to regain their
property after the protection order has
ended which does not make sense
uh there's an increased potential
increased risk to innocence uh in the
respondent and possibly Law Enforcement
Officers by increasing the chance of a
violent encounter uh we've heard of
cases where just mental health checks
where someone goes in because someone
was threatening to harm to themselves or
others and there's a recent case in New
Hampshire where a young man died I don't
believe there's a firearm involved on
his part but they don't show up to you
know they're there to protect their
safety and sometimes people die when
that happens it could be the officers it
could be the respondent
um this is reminiscent of the 2002 movie
Minority Report uh it's about pre-crime
you know we don't have uh anything that
in our laws anywhere that you lose your
rights before you've committed any crime
or violation just or even the threat you
don't have to threaten actual violence
or commit a crime you can still be
convicted in the sen they don't call it
a conviction obviously but you are
losing a constitutionally guaranteed
right uh social media and other things
can be used against someone they're
using other states against people to
even attain their rights in the first
place
um and as you heard from another veteran
and some other people spoke about the
less likelihood of seeking psychiatric
help
um people will be less likely to talk
about the problems they have if they're
worried about losing their rights
possibly
and lastly I mean rumor has it that uh
you know Abel and his parents were
concerned about Kane's mental health so
they had his Spears removed we all know
what happened after that so removing one
thing that is potentially dangerous is
not necessarily an answer to preventing
a violent crime or some harm to someone
or another uh if someone commits a crime
obviously they need to be dealt with and
deal with the consequences but pre-crime
is something that none of us should be
addressing in this in this chamber or in
any government thank you
thank you for your testimony and the
chair calls Jonathan Weinberg
thank you for the opportunity for
letting me sneak in last moment my name
is Jonathan Weinberg I'm a member of the
Concord school board however I'm here in
my capacity as an individual on behalf
of the board
I guess does wearing a seat belt prevent
death no
does wearing a helmet absolutely prevent
brain injury no
does holding a knife down while walking
in a kitchen absolutely ensure that no
one is hurt by it
now
yet we don't wear a seat belt or a
helmet or practice safe knife handling
because we know the outcome
we know they are designed to minimize
the risk of a dangerous outcome
no bills no law will completely change
the reality that too many people are
dying at the hands of gun violence
but if you believe that like the other
safeguards the helmets the seat belts
and that this bill is proactively trying
to address a real Challenge and save
lives then I urge you to vote ought to
pass on HB 106. thank you
thank you for your testimony and the
chair recognizes Dr Michael
layern layer
that's it thank you I will be very fast
with my testimony
um
foreign
for those of you who watch the State of
the Union the other night
Joe Biden talked about ending no knock
warrants and yet here we are listening
to testimony advocating no knock
warrants I'm going to go through a brief
history and in less than two minutes I
have one request for this committee
this country we've heard so much about
systemic racism in this country nowhere
is it more apparent nowhere is systemic
racism more apparent than in gun control
you can go back and look at the Dred
Scott case specifically the words of
Chief Justice Taney which I will not
repeat you can look at the words of
Senator Shields from Tennessee if you
think the word Common Sense gun control
you should be proud of using it today in
2023 go look at his words it is right
out of Jim Crow
it is absolutely horrible unfortunately
the United States exported gun control
to Germany to Weimar Germany very
Progressive State incredibly Progressive
State thank you President Wilson
following Weimar Germany we got the
national socialists of Germany who very
very effectively used a red flag law to
disarm the undesirables which went far
beyond the Jews it included gays the
undesirables the not good Nazis of
society
over the past 10 years unfortunately the
gun control policies that have been
advanced in New Hampshire have not
differentiated from what was used in
Nazi Germany at all which is truly truly
a tragedy
this brings me to my requests in 2012
Representative Steve Vaillancourt was
censured by this body for saying Z Kyle
to then speaker of the house I thought
it was the right thing to do because I
think Nazis all socialists are
absolutely abhorrent
that's still on his record he's
unfortunately passed away if you are
going to advance this if you're going to
spread Jim Crow and you're going to
advance the policies of Nazi Germany
please vindicate the late representative
and honorable Steve Vaillancourt and
remove the censure from him for uttering
those words in this Hall thank you
foreign
chair recognizes Kang Lee
oh hi ladies and gentlemen thank you
again for your time
um I present myself through support and
defend the Constitution which this
legislative body is sworn to uphold
but let me be let me disclose an
uncomfortable and hidden truth the
legislature has no power of rule making
or legislation that would impair our
fundamental rights in fact this body has
never made any statute directly
prohibiting the right of the people to
keep and bear arms take note of the
Fallen United States Supreme Court
decision in Miranda versus Arizona
1990-1966 stating
we're right secured by the Constitution
are are involved there can be no
rulemaking or legislation which would
abrogate them
next we have the the newest decision
from 2022
wherein quoting DC versus Heller
that Bruin Court stated that the Second
Amendment is the very product of an
interest balancing by the people and
surely it elevates above all other
interests the right of law-abiding
responsible citizens for arm or to use
arms for defense
that said
in 1943 the Supreme Court also wrote
that the very purpose of the Bill of
Rights was to withdraw certain subjects
from The Vicious from from the this into
aciditudes of political controversy
to place them beyond the reach of
majorities and officials and to
establish them as legal principles to be
guided by the courts one's fundamental
right may not be submitted to a vote
they depend on the outcome of no
elections
again you can confirm this for yourself
as no statute
has ever been written by this body
that directed its subject matter
jurisdiction against the right of the
people to keep and bear arms that is the
words to keep and bear arms are totally
absent from the so-called
legislation or gun laws that's your time
sir okay thank you very much thank you
we appreciate testimony
thank the court excuse me the court
we're talking about court so much the
chair recognizes uh Vic toppo or Topo
foreign
good afternoon chairman Roy and members
of the House criminal justice and Public
Safety Committee
my name is Vic toppo I'm CEO of the
center for Life management and Dairy
and I am here representing the New
Hampshire Community Behavioral Health
Association
and the state's 10 Community Mental
Health Centers
to express our strong support for house
bill 106.
I am also here as a member of the New
Hampshire Suicide Prevention Council
part of the council's charge for RSA
126r is to oversee the implementation
of the New Hampshire suicide
prevention plan into serve as a
proponent for suicide prevention in New
Hampshire
according to the New Hampshire child
totality
review report issued last week suicide
was the cause of death for over 23
percent of our residents
age 1 to 21
between 2017 and 2021
and 38 of those suicides were gun deaths
finding reasonable and practical ways to
help prevent those deaths is part of my
mission personally and professionally
and as a member of the suicide
prevention Council
House Bill 106 is one such solution
we all know that mental health issues
especially among children and teens
spiked in the past three years
following the shutdowns in isolation
of the covid-19 pandemic
we also know that the state has a severe
Workforce shortage in the health care
Arena
and that extends to the Community Mental
Health System
we are struggling to ensure that
everyone in all our communities gets the
care
they need when they need it
as you have already heard from others 19
states in the District of Columbia now
have so-called red flag laws
and in New England all our neighboring
states except for Maine have acted these
laws
main passed a yellow flag law in 2019
which was a compromise with the
Sportsman's groups
and which is still being evaluated for
its effectiveness
that's your time
thank you if you want you can submit
written testimony if you have more thank
you thank you
um and the chair recognizes Penny Dean
thank you for your perseverance and a
long day I'm Penny Dean from Concord New
Hampshire and I'm sad to say that this
12-page bill or I'm sorry
um 106 FM of 12 Pages needs to be itl
because of the time limit I won't be
able to pre point out probably five
percent of the flaws
closer sorry because of the time limit I
won't be able to point out not even five
percent of the flaws and there's serious
flaws when we talk about the New York
case yes it was found on second
constitutional but how much blood sweat
tears and money did the plaintiffs have
to do to do that you guys are supposed
to be our first line of defense
you're not supposed to pass legislation
and say Let them fight it out in the
courts that's not right
people like me can do that but what
about the average person that's just
going to destroy their life and destroy
their finances
start with the very beginning this bill
deserves a black ribbon not a blue
ribbon a black ribbon if you look at
page two
line six seven and eight that is the
first section which talks about
proceedings under this chapter may be
transferred to another Court upon the
motion of any party
or the court is the interest of Justice
requires there's two famous United
States Supreme Court cases international
shoe and Kokomo tire and they talk about
jurisdiction
so what if I'm in Concord New Hampshire
and what if someone files one against me
and they say we want it to be heard in
coax County because it's more convenient
for us
should I behold into coax County I don't
ever go to Cross County but yet that's
what's going to happen here what's going
to cost me to litigate and travel up
there that's huge next what other states
do I don't give a fake about other
states don't have seat belt laws I mean
do have them and we don't guess what
we're different
helmet laws I don't care what the other
states have not my
because they plan to be sillies no but
the bottom line is there's two things
you have to know
I don't want to use the word never but I
don't recall ever in 22 plus years of
practice seeing anything but an ex parte
order coming down number one ex parte
which means one side gets to go and tell
the judge their side for a temporary
order now once these orders these are
one year orders so everyone says oh
these are temporary if it's you one year
is not temporary I can tell you that and
after the one year judges automatically
rubber stamp another year and another
year and another year the other thing is
I have never once seen a person who
committed perjury prosecuted for this
prosecutors have absolute prosecutorial
discretion and I've heard everyone say
to me I can't prosecute a victim and I
think you need to look at page three
which is another highlights of bad
things
lines seven and eight
they appeal to the superior court of
Errors along again Hoover wrote this
looks like they took a bunch of bad
bills and threw them together and don't
understand how the mechanics work and
I'm only pointing out the big things
because of time the other things can I
say two one sentence just one sentence
okay if you look at lines 21 and lines
28 and line three you were told
it was a certain standard right here you
see preponderance of the evidence
so don't believe what people are telling
you read the bill and it's a bad bad bad
Bill
thank you for your testimony
with that anyone else have a card
going once going twice closed
um house bill
106 is closed and now I open the public
hearing House Bill 351 and I recognize
representative David Muse to introduce
his bill as the sponsor where is he
there he is
as the sponsor representative Muse you
are not limited to the two minutes
um but you are the only one
thank you
there are a few tragedies greater
than the negligent death or injury of a
child or another innocent person
as a result of a firearm being left and
attended
while HP 351 won't end all of these
tragedies it will reduce the risk of
them happening
as many of you will recall in 2019 an 11
year old child from Alton was arrested
for shooting and killing his parents
with an unsecured firearm
last month in Virginia a six-year-old
boy brought his mother's unsecured and
loaded gun to school and shot his
teacher
over the years we've also read tragic
news stories in New Hampshire and
elsewhere about shootings involving
children playing with unsecured firearms
and the wounding or killing of those
children their siblings and their
Playmates
in 2015 13 million U.S households with
children contain firearms
in 2019 a study in the medical journal
Pediatrics said incidents involving guns
are estimated to be the third leading
cause of injury-related death among
children age 17 and under the third
largest cause of death
the Centers for Disease Control and
prevention reports that every day in
America
eight children and teens are injured or
killed in shootings involving an
improperly stored or misused gun found
in the home
two more injured or killed attempting
suicide with a firearm and equally
alarming 38 percent of firearm related
deaths in the age in 19 and under group
are suicides
incidents involving suicide or Firearms
injuries involving children are often
kept confidential by law enforcement
the department of safety has told me
that it doesn't collect or report this
data in a centralized way
depending on jurisdiction incidents may
be handled by State Police County
Sheriffs or local police this makes it
extremely difficult to examine New
Hampshire incidents from a data-driven
perspective it's also hard to get
anecdotal information because newspapers
and media elements are very protective
of the privacy of minors and their
parents
many times if we hear of an incident at
all we tend to hear a bit as a as an
unreported shooting where a child might
be involved and that's the last we hear
of it
the bottom line is unsecured Firearms
pose significant safety risks especially
to children
the American Journal admitted the
Journal of the American Medical
Association reported that 70 percent of
parents surveyed reported their children
had no independent access to firearms in
their household but over a third of the
children actually living in those
households reported being able to access
a firearm in less than five minutes
so what this bill does is it requires
that Firearms sold their transferred
commercially or privately be accompanied
by a locking safety device that
specifically designed or manufactured
for the purpose of allowing the owner to
temporarily disable or safely store the
firearm
the bill also gives the buyer the option
of complying with the law by bringing
their own locking safety device when
they take ownership of the firearm
the bill also strengthens New
Hampshire's existing firearm storage
negligence law that's RSA 650 C1 by
doing several things
it expands the scope of the law to cover
unattended firearms that are unloaded
but where unsecured ammunition is also
available to the child
the current law only addresses loaded
weapons
it broadens the circumstances that
constitute an offense
currently a gun owner who allows a child
to gain access to an unsecured weapon is
only charged If the child uses the gun
in a reckless manner uses it in the
commission of a crime or negligently or
recklessly discharges it
under HP 351 a child displaying a
firearm to others would also constitute
an offense
additionally an offense would take place
if the child brings the weapon onto the
grounds of any facility public or
private that's accessible to members of
the public where other people are
present
the bottom line is we have a plague of
kids
bringing unsecured Firearms into
situations where they're not only
endangering themselves they're
endangering other children they're
endangering endangering as adults uh and
they're endangering the public
and there's no reason for this
this is not an issue of taking anybody's
guns away this is an issue of frankly
helping more people understand
what a responsibility it is to own a
firearm especially if you have a child
um
I think the bill is also very clear
about exceptions which which you can
read yourself in the bill it doesn't
restrict access to Firearms it doesn't
penalize any responsible law abiding gun
owners negligence is actually already a
crime in our state
what it would do is offer additional
protection for New Hampshire children
and something to think about is it would
save gun owners from the horror and the
liability that is a risk whenever an
unsecured firearm is left around a child
in a state where guns are part of our
culture responsibility in protecting our
kids from the very real danger that
unsecured Firearms can present
really needs to also be part of our
culture and a stronger part of our
culture and hopefully HP 351 will make
it a stronger part of New Hampshire law
as well
uh please give HP 351 and not to pass
recommendation
thank you
thank you for your testimony
and the chair calls
um James Gaffney
thanks for the opportunity to testify
this bill like previous bills attempts
to re-classify what a private sale is
come here this is well established it's
a it's a theme or a problem that exists
on several bills today this bill isn't
going to accomplish anything it's a
cable lock
why are we
we're painting with a broad brush we're
just applying additional requirements to
a problem that doesn't currently exist
nobody's brought forth examples where
cable lock would solve a problem in this
state
I live in other states where where
they've had these laws and it
accomplishes nothing
so thank you very much I urge you to to
uh vote this itl
thank you for your testimony and the
chair calls Kimberly Morin
the CDC stats include children up to the
age of 19 years old the more majority of
children that are killed with Firearms
are gang bangers
um
it would be really really actually
useful of gun controllers we're
concerned with getting illegal guns off
the street because there would be less
dead children according to ages 19 and
under
um also once again this is another out
of state gun control organization that
seeks to change existing laws in New
Hampshire these out-of-state
organizations attempt to solve problems
that don't exist in one of the safest
states in the country please vote in
expedient to legislate on HB 351 there's
no need to change the law there's
especially no need to change the law to
satisfy gun control organizations
located in states that aren't nearly as
safe as New Hampshire thank you
thank you for your testimony
the chair recognizes William Rogers
thank you again
I grew up in a household where the
shotgun was stored in the corner we knew
where it was nobody ever touched it we
knew better we just knew better we were
all familiar with Firearms nobody ever
touched it until we were 14 and able to
take an NRA hunting hunting course then
but it still was there
again the the people's lack of
understanding how how firearm
purchases work is every gun I've ever
bought probably in the last 20 years
comes with a lot it comes with a lot
we don't need to legislate you cannot
legislate common sense you cannot
legislate
good behavior all you can do is make
good citizens
violators
I keep guns in my house I have
grandchildren I have children when they
come over
believe me there's no way they can get
it but I don't need a law to tell me to
do that because I have half a brain
thank you very much
thank you for your testimony the chair
calls
um Dr Leonard Cohen
thank you for hearing my testimony again
on this bill let me start
with just a couple of comments first
since I've sat here and listened to all
the testimony today
first of all in terms of Mental Health
people say do something about Mental
Health
I'm a psychiatrist I'm interested in
doing something about Mental Health
but when we present
possible laws
to do something about mental health you
say no
no
don't want to do that
so
not sure really how we can do something
about mental health if when we present
reasonable ideas
about mental health the answer
seems to always be no
and let me talk about something about
the Constitution
nothing in New Hampshire law
says anything about gun law about ghost
guns
as far as I know nothing about New
Hampshire law says anything about
turning in the names of people who are
committed to the state hospital
to the National Data Bank
so it's not a constitutional issue it's
just a reasonable issue that we're
interested in and this has to these have
to do with mental health now
in terms of negligent storage of
firearms
it's reasonable
for people who have a license to drive a
car for them to do it reasonably
it's reasonable for people who have guns
to store them reasonably especially if
they have children in the house
now it used to be that the major most
incidents of
death for kids or car accidents
but that's no longer because we have a
lot of good laws to do something about
child safety in cars and safety and cars
in general that's your that's your time
doctor
so
please let's do something about
negligent storage of firearms thank you
very much thank you for your testimony
the chair calls Timothy wolf
foreign
I have more
comments just on my testimony on this
um
I you know one is that most
I I can't think of any newer
manufactured firearm that you would
purchase that doesn't already come with
a cable lock so I think a lot of this is
already happening
um anyhow my observation with that is
you can pass a law on it pass all the
laws you want but somebody has to use
that cable lock so if you get a cable
lock somebody doesn't use it you still
don't have
the um the means of
making the firearm inoperable to
essentially I'm assuming this is you
know uh primarily quite a bit aimed at
uh preventing children from getting a
hold of these Firearms
um
you know the the other thing uh that
comes to mind is
um there is already a law it's a federal
law to the ATF and the problem of the
gum dealers it can probably speak better
of it to me than I can I don't I don't
know it intimately but um you are
federally under federal law already
responsible I think it's called I think
I wrote it down here at the best of my
memory just like the child safety I
don't know if it's protection act or
something like that but quite often
you'll get a flyer if you buy a firearm
and it'll open they'll give it to you
and so there is Federal Regulation it
makes you accountable if somebody who
underage gets a hold of your gun
um so again it's a law are we doing
anything about it we Prosecuting anybody
because a child get
harmed or damage we're going to approx
you know pass another law that we're not
going to prosecute somebody for if
something bad happens so I would say we
may already have the tools to do what
this is intended I don't know we need
another law to achieve what is wanted
here and lastly I'll just
um State personally I think education is
important here uh education of parents
adults and children
um how that happens there's a lot of
ways to do it I know personally
my kindergarten my son my parents Kids
kindergarten Keisha came up to me I said
boy you boys are so well behaved you
know all the other kids are running
around making things in the guns and
shooting each other with them your kids
don't do that and you know I taught them
my youngest son I taught him at age five
how to shoot under my supervision
my next son I actually taught him at six
because he thought he knew more than I
did at five so we waited and said this
is going to happen another day when he
was six and um they have always been
very respectful I feel safer with them
than I do just about anybody I know who
keeps and bears a firearm and uh so I I
will just leave you with that but I I uh
you know thank you that's the time
relevant thank you thank you
the chair calls representative Granger
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I'd like to share a sad story
about a horrific act of violence where a
safe storage techniques led to a
fatality I'd like to share the story of
the fate of Mrs orpington
on a gorgeous Autumn night in New
Hampshire a loud noise was heard outside
of rural New Hampshire home while a
family was sleeping sensing danger the
man of the house looked outside to see
Mrs orpington's home under Invasion
thinking quickly the man ran to his
office and started unlocking his rifle a
Ruger 10 22. it was dark and he had a
punch in the code multiple times for the
mechanism to work correctly but finally
he did open the safe and once he had it
he found the rifle unloaded he searched
around for the magazine and found it on
the floor he loaded the rifle and headed
outside nothing could prepare him for
the Carnage that awaited him the once
beautiful blonde and buff hen
affectionately called Mrs orpington laid
dead on the ground surrounded by
feathers the culbert was a skunk who had
already gone long gone
she was the only she was only one year
old and had the potential to lay
hundreds of eggs before retirement but
due to the inaccessibility of a tool
capable of saving her life she never
laid those eggs in the current economy
those actions represented a 500 retail
value
this bill would enable more tragic
stories like this to occur for centuries
those who had poultry and livestock
stored their rifles above the door to
their home this allowed them and their
family the ability to handle Critters
that would attack their homesteads
without having to jump through hoops
this bill would endanger farm animals by
taking away the protections of the
farmers Fox into their damage quick
raccoons as well chickens even well
guarded blocked with a rooster present
are always at risk from Critters to
attack swiftly and often for fun seconds
count this bill also puts unreasonable
age restrictions in Annie Oakley was
eight when she began to hunt to feed her
family she was winning competitions at
15. in New Hampshire if this bill is
signed her Widow mother would be guilty
of a misdemeanor I I ask you to please
vote itl on this Bill thank you
thank you for your testimony
chair calls Andrew Schuler
thank you for letting me testify
um one of the issues I have with the
quick analysis here where it says there
has to be locking safety device a
company all private in commercial
Firearms this build requires infringing
on the right to privacy as outlined in
the Bill of Rights and therefore I
should just be I tell this Bill thank
you
thank you for your testimony
chair calls Dr Hannon
foreign
early evening to everyone
um johannan Gunners New Hampshire uh
we're in opposition to HB 351
um there are several reasons obviously
one I mean you're requiring a citizen to
purchase something commercially so we've
talked about commercial sales and all
this stuff I don't know of any laws that
mandate you buy something well there's
one but we won't get into that here uh
it's a federal thing
um so as far from besides health
insurance you have this you're going to
mandate that they buy a lock I've never
bought a firearm from a dealer that
didn't have one available or didn't have
a big bag or a bucket or a bin somewhere
they said take one
um I've rarely seen a gun show without
them around or everywhere uh Private
Sales like you heard earlier you can't
really dictate what's happening at a
private sale you don't know if they have
it you'd think that people would have it
the other thing is you can't mandate
having them locked up either
um they've done they did a study uh last
year that talked about interviewed 55
000 Firearms owners and states that had
child access laws and we are one of
those States we have child access laws
currently
and states that didn't have them and
most people didn't even know the
difference if you know they didn't it
didn't affect greatly whether they
locked them or not uh so as far as
mandatory locking them they're not even
doing that when it's required by law
sometimes or even know what the law was
um
real quick um
you know this takes a violation and
makes it a misdemeanor uh we already
have a lot of exceptions for uh safety
uh for firearm storage you know you
heard hunter safety course uh parental
permission is one thing if you say I'm
giving my child permission to have
access that can be an exception to the
law currently so what's going to happen
they're going to get in trouble for this
and they're going to say you know the
kid might have had permission now the
parent's going to go to jail possibly
and they're going to say well I didn't
give that kid permission they're not
going to lock up the kid but hey you
know it's it's a bad position to put
people in and they added also lastly
Firearms is exhibited or displayed to
others that's not recklessly threatening
that's not using the commission of a
misdemeanor or not an English
negligently or recklessly discharging it
it's just showing it to someone now I
don't want to encourage that I don't
think it's a good idea I think it's bad
parenting it's a bad kid in some senses
if they don't know better but uh just
the mirror exhibiting of something
should not rise to the level of a crime
for the parent
uh and what if the parent of the other
child doesn't like guns in general you
know if I know that and this is a law
I'm not going to let those kids come to
my house just they're locked up and
they're safe but I don't want to have
the risk of them even making that
accusation
um two time yep thank you that's good
you get the idea
thank you for your testimony
um
chair recognizes Linda Haskins
good afternoon Linda Haskins Rockingham
representing Exeter
thank you for your forbearance
and kind attention this afternoon
I'm a retired school counselor and Dr
horn has said it better than I
Gunn rights Advocates always talk about
Mental Health
it's a problem of Mental Health
we are here today
with the opportunity to do something
it's not everything but it's something
and I think with all the bipartisan talk
I hear in the hall
this is one bill that we could agree on
it's not about taking anybody's guns
away it's about preserving life it's
about giving us an opportunity to
intervene when there are only very good
reasons and let's have some confidence
in the judges in our court system to be
able to distinguish when it is a
critical need it's not willy-nilly
they're not going to go along with a
protective order I am the proud daughter
of a dad who spent my entire childhood
in law enforcement the only time I ever
saw his gun was when he was in uniform I
have no idea where he kept it in the
house but this is not 1980. this is 2023
and we have to acknowledge there are
many more guns and parents are very busy
and even the most well-intentioned
parent could neglect
to put the gun safely where it belongs
we've got to do this for our kids and as
I say this is an opportunity for us to
have a bipartisan agreement to help save
our kids thank you
thank you for your testimony
the chair calls J.E simkin
Jay simpkin born once going twice
chair calls Maybe
I will ask that you it all the spill
please
I will go through again the bad parts
quickly 351.
we start at the beginning I think this
is a cute little back door trick nice
try to get us to redefine again
commercial sales of firearms and get it
through the back door so that all
firearms get checked through the system
and personal sales are not a lot
because if you look at the first lines
in 1A it's on page 1 8 9 and 10.
public sale or exchange including but
not limited to and then when you look at
the next page which is page two
um lines three seller means a person
offering a firearm for commercial sale
private sale or barter we're getting
back to the fact that they want all guns
to be checked through the system that no
Private Sales will be allowed that's
really what this is coming down to
and second
when someone says oh they can access the
firearm in five minutes that's about
four and a half minutes too late
in most instances not quick enough
the next thing that we talk about is
specifically
on page two lines 29 30 31 32.
okay so without the supervision or
permission of the child's parent
so if the child's parents are
supervising what does that means I mean
they're out at the pool watching what
what does supervision mean but when it
comes to parent
I'm the step parent is that good enough
I'm the parent without custody is that
good enough does it have to be written
is that good enough what if Mom and
father differ and they're divorced is
that good enough
these type of things really become to
matter
next you're looking about gross
negligence that necessarily has it on
page three lines four
going back to the fact that you're
basically saying the kid can't defend
themselves in the house we've had
six-year-olds seven-year-olds
eight-year-olds camping in Firearms
defend their family defend their
siblings defend their mother and save
lives so you're gonna punish these
people
that's just plain old crazy
but the other thing when we look at this
and we have to look at this as someone
said we're giving your time oh one line
one line we're gonna trust our judges
they're unelected judges you can't an
elect them they're appointed judges
that's a big deal
thank you for your testimony
um last try for JE simpkin have you
returned to the room
at this point I'm closing the public
hearing on House Bill 351 and I'm
opening to public hearing on House Bill
444 and I recognize representative Muse
to introduce his bill excuse me that
looks like I showed up in person and I
gratefully thank representative Muse for
filling in for me I we have a long
executive session to Judiciary and I'm
here to get back to that we've got Lord
Harrington will be introducing as well
what and uh although he certainly would
have been prepared done a great job of
introducing it and probably would have
prepared to answer any questions
um
so I'm hoping this issue has come up
before uh most recently in 2022
representative Muse actually sponsored
1096 which is a very good bill that fell
a little short I think
this one is uh
this one is similar I think it's a
little bit simpler uh for sure it
creates fewer problems for the uh for
the gun owners because I know there's
always the issue of keeping track of
where your gun is welcome and where it
isn't where you can carry it where you
can't and I think just makes it easier
it bans guns and other deadly weapons
with a hundred feet of the polling place
and we're just I'm just using the
commonly understood definition of
polling place which is uh
well understood appears in many other
places in both state and federal law and
and rules too and it's the place where
the election activities are taking place
only places are very clearly marked it's
very specific requirements for how to
mark them in addition there's signs
marking the 100 foot radius around the
entrance
even if the signs are missing I think
most people maybe not everyone but most
of us can recently have a pretty good
idea like how long a distance 100 feet
is
and unless that turned out is extremely
low or it's just not a very
controversial issue at the election
there's going to be a few individuals
holding political signs 101 feet from
the entrance and I'll say two here I
have enough confidence in our law
enforcement our Judiciary here that
they're not going to be like swooping in
and nabbing somebody who accidentally
carries his gun you know 90 finds
himself 99 feet from the entrance of the
high school or wherever else
whatever place where the polls are pink
place and if you're worried about you
know running into bad guys Bears
whatever while you're trying to vote
she takes solace in the fact that
there's always law enforcement officers
on duty at the polling place
is a pretty large one usually have about
at least five or six armed officers uh
in the polling place some even out in
the parking lot mostly directing traffic
but
if there's an attack on the polling
place they would be our first line of
defense and it actually originally when
I put in the LSR I was originally
playing just put in open carry but I
decided to go ahead and just make it all
weapons so simpler that's practical
matter if you're
if you're concealing your weapon they're
not going to know you're carrying a
concealed weapon anyway so the issue is
not going to come up and I've got a
a specific carve out for unloaded
weapons secured in Motor Vehicles even
if your parking place is less than 100
feet from the door and also
also for law enforcement officers not
those who are not just those who are
specifically in duty at duty at the
plumbing place but also those
who are you know voting on their way to
work and the way to back work and
happened to be wearing the uniform of
which the gun is an integral part I know
I have a neighbor who's a member lives
in Durham but she's a member of a force
in another town I think it's Northampton
she showed up on the last election day
with her Northampton Police Department
uniform including her service revolver
and I had no problem with that
and uh also the
the penalty is a class A misdemeanor
which usually it could theoretically
result in a year in jail but once again
I have confidence in our criminal
Judiciary or they're not going around
I don't think they're going around
Prosecuting uh someone who somehow
accidentally manages to carry the gun
into the polling place and in most cases
a good moderator would probably just
tell them to lock it up in their car and
go back and vote so I heard she
committee to ought to pass
and pretty here to get back to my own
executive session but I suppose I have
to
open it up for any questions bear in
mind uh president Muse was definitely
probably would have done a better job of
testifying to me but I guess he'll have
to say his observations for the exact
session unless you want to recognize
them as a speaker but thank you
thank you for your testimony
good thank you
chair recognizes uh honorable John Burke
thank you Mr chairman and find committee
members I do oppose this bill I have
fought this bill many times and luckily
been successful at killing it each time
and let me tell you why
open carry a lot I like open carrying
today I'm concealed carrying but what I
believe is uh I have the right to do
either so in Goffstown when I go to Home
Depot Hannaford's anywhere as I go I'm
carrying my nine millimeter on my head
um
Bartlett School is within 100 feet of
the polling place you know where we
stand with our political signs so that
means
I'm not going to be able to stand there
and also this disenfranchises me from
voting because I feel I have a right a
constitutional right to bring my gun to
the poll in place to make sure I'm
protected while I'm voting
and I just don't see why we need this uh
up in where when I was a State Rep and
at some point I will return
um
when up and where we're within 20 feet
of the polling place here's the door
here we are right outside the door
saying hi to the voters as they come in
and most of us are carrying so this
isn't going to work so I hope you it
yell it and please do the right thing to
make sure that the people that decide to
carry a gun constitutionally they have a
right they can still vote or you're
disenfranchising them and I know how one
party does not want to disenfranchise
anybody so I hope that you will do this
thank you
I give you testimony and the chair
recognizes Kimberly Morin
so while we're practicing our right to
vote this bill makes it so we aren't
allowed to practice our fundamental
human right to self-defense protected by
the Second Amendment
again just like with the school zone
bill this bill creates a gun-free zone
that enables criminals to easily prey on
victims especially women who choose to
protect themselves and their children
with a firearm once again this is
legislation looking to solve a problem
that doesn't exist in New Hampshire
please vote in expedient to legislate on
HB 444
all of these gun control bills we've
heard today do nothing but make Granite
standards less safe thank you
thank you for your testimony
and the chair calls James Gaffney
I'd urge you to vote this itl
the sponsor didn't offer any
problem that it's looking to solve do we
have a problem with people carrying guns
quietly silently not obviously when they
go to vote
again solution the solution in search of
a problem it creates a mass
Second Amendment
both you know at the state level on the
federal level doesn't say accept at a
polling place
this is silly
I can't believe that that somebody's
suggesting we should suspend one
constitutionally protected right in
order to exercise another one please
vote this itl
thank you for your testimony and the
chair recognizes Timothy wolf
now it's on red red light okay
um
again this is just a I oppose this bill
it's uh basically just another gun-free
zone and um which I do not agree with
um I I again I have to reiterate what
some of these other folks have said uh
you know why is that we have a problem
with this I don't usually if you Pat you
want to legislate something like this is
because you've had a problem I don't
think I haven't heard of any problems
with this in New Hampshire I don't
really see it being necessary I don't
think we're having an issue uh seemed
kind of ridiculous to me that I can be
101 feet outside of a polling site with
a firearm that has a effective range
farther than that but if I step inside
that Circle it's a problem
um kind of silly especially if I am
intent on harming peaceful
um which I'm not uh but if somebody is I
don't really think they care about this
gun-free zone
um I do feel
um what we're trying to achieve here is
going to have the opposite effect if
anything I think it would Empower people
who are intent on this sort of harm uh
simply because they know nobody in there
is armed you know nobody in that
circle's arm so I I can be more
effective and do more damage and harm
because that's what I want to do
um so uh that said
um you know just doesn't make sense to
me on a basic logical level and I would
just ask that um
uh you pose this as well thank you
thank you for your testimony
oh
the chair recognizes Andrew Schuler
so thank you I recommend you I tell this
bill
um every person has right to speak be
safe while they're voting and this is an
infringement on the right to vote
um the Bill's sponsor suggested that uh
some assumptions on behavior of Law and
I don't think that's we can really do
that and so it's better to err on the
side of caution and instead of innocence
and therefore this bill should not pass
thank you
thank you for your testimony in the
chair recognizes Dr Leonard corn
so again again it seems like
or some people
the Constitution
does not allow any
uh any restrictions on guns and the gun
violence then in our country will just
get greater and greater
now this is a bill to
make polling places less threatening for
some people now I obviously some people
who want to carry guns don't find that
threatening but other people do
and uh
intimidation and threatened or actual
violence at voting places is so
detrimental to our democracy
that we'd like this limited restriction
to be in place
at our voting booths thank you very much
thank you for your testimony
the chair calls J.E simpkin in case he's
come back
get someone check on je simpkin for me
okay and the chair recognizes Brian
blackton
foreign
I have a license to carry concealed
firearms I am a federal firearms
licensee I have a constitutional right
to carry a firearm I should not be
threatened with incarceration for
exercising my right to carry and don't
forget
nobody likes guns until the wolf is
knocking on your door
thank you
thank you for your testimony
the chair recognizes William Reyes
Rogers I'm sorry
still can't read it huh
I apologize for that thank you again
my firearm on my side
or or rather I am never a threat when I
carry my firearm my firearm is not a
threat at the polling place it's not a
threat at the registry it's not a threat
in a supermarket it's not a threat at
the sidewalk it's not a threat
anywhere because it's on me the one
place I would take exception and where I
would not take a gun
is to leave it in my car while I go
someplace else because now the potential
is there for it to become a threat if
someone steals it from my car and that's
that's not talk I don't leave my gun in
my car ever and yet
this is the solution when I go to vote I
put my gun in my car or lock it up and
hold
no solution thank you
thank you for your testimony and the
chair calls Joanne Brown
it's gone
although excellent
oh there he is
hi my name is ALU axelman I live in
Hooksett with my great wife and son
um speaking in opposition to House Bill
444 I think it's to get a quick Swift
itl on consent calendar hopefully
um it's a simple bill that violates the
natural right to own property in this
case the property made of steel and
polymer and it violates the natural
right assault defense
both those natural rights are also
protected by the New Hampshire and U.S
constitutions
I do not know of any place in the New
Hampshire or U.S constitutions that it
says we have a right to own firearms
except at polling places
there's no exception
as I said on an earlier Bill the
founders knew what exceptions were the
fourth and fifth Amendments have
exceptions
um the second does not so if you want to
amend the Second Amendment or the New
Hampshire Constitution to have some
exceptions that's fine there's a process
in the state and federally to amend
constitutions so we can work on the
Constitutional amendment to add you have
a right to keep Firearms accept that
polling places
um or accept as deemed necessary by the
legislature or any time anything is
dangerous ever you know that'll be a
broad Amendment at least then it
wouldn't violate the constitution so it
just infringes on my natural right to be
safe at all times including when I do my
civic duty and vote so thank you very
much
thank you for your testimony
Dr Hannon
thank you again uh Johann and Gunners of
New Hampshire uh we stand in opposition
to House Bill 444
uh it's it's a little peculiar I mean I
understand some of the uh about carrying
a loaded firearm carrying an unloaded
pistol revolver firearm is it's still a
firearm but it's more of a paperweight
so it's not something that's dangerous
uh whether it's concealed or not we've
had tens of thousands of people carrying
concealed or even open carrying firearms
for many years in New Hampshire and I
can't think of an incident that has
occurred I mean there may have but I
just don't know about it uh
also and something that's very
concerning is uh carrying uh you know
within 100 feet you know I stood at the
polls like many of you for years and
you're about 100 feet away where I was
they made a stand back that's where most
uh you know conversations and political
dialogue would occur there's very little
happening when people go inside so it's
almost an arbitrary number and it's not
like a bullet can't go 100 feet so I
don't know why 100 feet was picked if
someone has the intent to hurt someone
that's not gonna really do anything
um
and the most dangerous thing is you're
allowed to unload a firearm in your car
in the parking lot of a polling place
and people that are not very familiar
with Firearms should know that that is
one of the most dangerous times to
handle to have a firearm carrying it on
your hip or even in your safe or on your
shelf you know if that's my gun I can
leave it there all day it's not going to
do anything I pick it up and I start
messing with it in a parking lot in a
cramped space I'm wearing a winter coat
because it's November election time it's
more dangerous I don't want to have to
do that I buy a little firearm it's
usually at a range or at a safe place in
my home that I have a bulletproof
backstop for I don't want to do that in
a parking lot
and that's what would be required for
people that normally carry on a daily
basis for personal protection and safety
and if they go to vote that's something
you're going to subject not just them to
but the other people in that parking lot
so this bill is actually more dangerous
than it first appears on at first look
so I'd ask you to please uh not pass
this you know we don't want to make a
crime and potentially put someone in
jail for just under a year for the mere
fact that They Carried something that
was okay here at 101 feet and 100 feet
now they have to go to jail for almost a
year that's the difference we're talking
about and that makes no sense
uh you have to take any questions but I
see your faces so
thank you
thank you for your testimony uh the
chair calls Joshua L Barry
El borrow it
hello my name is Joshua it's close
enough I reside in Manchester and I am
speaking in opposition to this bill
I wanted to note I believe this is
already a non-issue at the most recent
state election that I voted in I saw
plenty of people open caring and most
likely concealing Firearms at schools to
restrict this in any capacity I think as
ALU had mentioned is a violation of
natural rights and constitutional rights
so furthermore I personally would feel
extremely unsafe if I'm singled out
amongst my peers in any venue regardless
of whether it's a school or not if it's
known that I'm not caring or legally
carrying a firearm I feel like a Sitting
Duck so I potentially see this bill as
only violating rights and by letting my
potential safety if the fear is security
you know you can increase the security
add more cops whatever you need to do
but don't violate my rights thank you
thank you for your testimony
and the chair recognizes Penny Dean
I am exhibit one of why we need Firearms
at polling places and and everywhere I
go I ask that you itl this bill
unfortunately I'm not the spry young
woman that ran distance that I used to
be some days I hobble around pretty darn
bad with a crutch
I gotta tell you I don't stand a chance
against some of the larger boys and more
agile people
there's a couple of problems with this
bill that I find offensive
number one and line 11 law enforcement
individuals in uniform are exempt from
it
that's not fair their life is worth no
more than mine is
and it isn't like ones that are working
though we're talking people they could
leave their gun in the car just like the
rest of us do
it doesn't say coming and going to work
it doesn't say any of those things
they're just treated special
but the next issue which I think is
larger is those people talk about what
makes them feel uncomfortable
there are people who bikers make them
feel uncomfortable young kids wearing
dreads make them feel uncondual kid
throwing gang signs make them feel
uncomfortable where do we stop
the bottom line here is there's no
proven issues that we've heard about
and you are asking people to give up a
constitutional right that is clear on
its face in order to exercise the right
to vote which is something that people
in this country have spilled blood over
they're both important rights people
shouldn't have to choose and I'd ask you
I tell it please
thank you for your testimony
chair recognizes representative Granger
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee I'll make it very quick I
stand outside of polling places quite a
bit I think we all have done that before
and I really don't want to get shot and
not have the ability to shoot back so
for the security of everybody who is a
representative please itl this Bill
thank you
thank you for your testimony is anyone
holding a pink card who's not turned it
in yet
seeing none I hear very close public
Hearing in HP 444
I hereby open public hearing on HP 474
and recognize
the prime sponsor
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Tom minion I
represent Hillsboro One Pelham I'm here
to introduce HP 474 relative to
enforcement of federal firearms laws and
establishment of penalties
last year we had a fantastic build HB
1178 courtesy of our John Burt uh it
came through this committee and
ultimately ultimately was signed into
law it is commonly referred to as gun
sanctuary Bill and its language is
modeled after immigration Sanctuary
provisions and other states and cities
across the United States the difference
being this one solidified New
Hampshire's dedication to protect
protected citizens rights against
Federal overreach
this law was already covered in the
hearings all during the day we've
mentioned it many times so I'll focus on
HP 474
uh during the tank uh testimony for a
sanctuary Bill one of the chief
complaints from our citizens was the
lack of penalties or teeth
to any law enforcement that decided to
ignore this New Hampshire law and Aid
the feds in trampling our natural rights
to keep and bear arms
this bill corrects for that I consider
it a government accountability bill it
weighs qualified immunity and permits a
wronged individual to have their day in
court
furthermore
I do not believe our state could benefit
from employing federal agents that have
disregarded our natural rights and bars
them from employment if they have a
history of doing so
this type of Insidious perversion from
within can ultimately would ultimately
diminish the quality of law enforcement
in the state dragging them down to the
levels of the right trampoline the
rights trampling federal agents
we should be ostracizing individuals
with this mindset not allowing them to
train alongside or manage police
departments and granted Staters
yeah sorry or managed police departments
with granted Staters that respect the
rights of our citizens
the militarization of police which has
caused disharmony and strife in our
communities traces back to Federal
programs doctrines and enforcement of
their laws
if we hope to amend the distrust of law
enforcement bills like HB 474 are a path
towards it
we should not
be employing individuals that consider
our rights an obstacle for them to
overcome
and create arbitrary rules on the fly
with no Congressional feedback only to
eventually be struck down by courts
after the harm has already been done I
asked the committee to OTP hb474 and I'm
willing to take any questions
thank you for your testimony introducing
your bill
and the chair recognizes William Rogers
I got it
could read that one
thank you again
I'm glad to see you Common Sense gun
control bill on the floor finally
I support this bill
Federal reach is only getting worse
as the federal government becomes more
and more politicized and more and more
weaponized we need to protect the the
granite state people from from the
federal laws I firmly support this Bill
thank you
thank you for your testimony and the
chair recognizes Brian Blackman
the question of self-protection keeps
coming up today
I support this bill
the Supreme Court in 1989 in the shade
the Winnebago County of Social Services
State stated the police had no duty to
protect
in 1981 Warren the District of Columbia
appeals court held police out of general
duty but no specific legal Duty exists
to protect
in 2005 Castle Rock B Gonzalez sued the
police for failing to protect her from
her husband after he abducted and killed
her three children justices said police
had no such duty to protect them
in 2018 the 11th circuit upheld the
police were not liable for for not
protecting students in Parkland Florida
with 17 lives were lost
this simply means we can protect
ourselves and we should thank you
thank you for your testimony
chair recognizes The Honorable John Burt
thank you Mr chairman again my name is
uh former well my name is John Burt but
I was a former representative
um I support and thank the prime sponsor
of this bill it would enhance my 11 my
house bill 1178.
where the police cannot be used for a
federal unconstitutional gun law so what
I'm hoping for you guys to please do is
support House Bill
474 and itl the other bill of House Bill
78 and then that way New Hampshire will
be even a stronger and more safe and I
trust me in that we will be the safest
state if we can pass this thank you
thank you for your testimony
and the chair recognizes James captain
uh I'm here today to urge you to support
this bill I I don't understand why there
wouldn't be penalties for a person
violating the law under the auspices of
their official duties
um the construction of the New Hampshire
and the federal Constitutions are such
that
the Second Amendment in article two are
there to to guarantee our rights
and the way they guarantee our rights is
to restrict government
is the infringer
officially or unofficially on our
natural rights so restrictions are good
consequences are similarly good
thank you very much I hope you support
this bill
thank you for your testimony
the chair recognizes Andrew Schuler is
he still here
okay we'll set his card aside uh
representative Granger
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee uh thank you for the
opportunity to testify on this bill uh
police accountability is a hot issue on
today's heated political climate this
bill is a small step towards ensuring
those who protect us don't abuse that
trust the law requires that the state
police do not cooperate with Federal
enforcement without penalties this is
merely a polite request this bill would
fix that and send a message that police
are not above the law merely because
they enforced the law
I wish to remind the committee why this
law was required in the first place the
ATF has become a rogue agency one that
arbitrarily changes the rules in drastic
ways that render thousands upon thousand
people into being felons for only
Firearms at the ATF themselves have
approved of
the rules they enforce and frequently
change are not the result of changes in
law made in Washington they are mayor
rule changes put in place by unelected
bureaucrats the ATF is not a simple
regulatory body their primary purpose is
tax collection when you make a
short-barreled shotgun you are not a
felon for possession of a shotgun it is
perfectly legal to have a short barrel
shotgun this is America no you only
become a felon if you don't pay the tax
on the shotgun the tax is two hundred
dollars the ATF just changed the rules
and made a wide variety of commonly
owned pistols into short-barreled rifles
which are taxed short-barreled rifles
get taxed pistols do not despite nothing
about the Firearms themselves being
changed the ATF decided these Firearms
are taxable and the punishment for not
paying the tax is potentially fatal
remember the Ruby Ridge Massacre was
started over the potential sale of a
short-barreled shotgun without the
paying of the appropriate tax what
happens to the people who didn't get the
memo that the ATF changed their mind
what is their fate when it is discovered
that they didn't pay the tax on a
short-barreled rifle they thought was a
pistol why should everyday gun owners be
required to become legal experts in
order to exercise basic rights at least
we can the least we can do is borrow
police from helping the ATF this bill
puts in reasonable penalties for
cooperation with the Rogue agency please
OTP hb474 thank you for your time
thank you for your testimony
chair recognizes Dr Leonard corn
thank you again for listening to my
testimony
I guess According to some people it's a
natural right to die and close to 50 000
people in this country die from gun
violence
slightly more from suicide than homicide
it's reasonable again as I've stated
before to pass Common Sense was
and it's reasonable for the state to
follow reasonable federal laws and this
type of Statute takes us in the wrong
direction thank you very much
thank you for your testimony the chair
recognizes Dr Johann
hi Johanna Gunners New Hampshire house
bill I'm opposed I mean I'm up for this
one sorry it's been after nine or ten in
a row uh so you know we've already heard
some arguments I'm not going to make uh
the same ones but there's a few good
things that I could bring up that
haven't been brought up already
um we we just heard about reasonableness
and you know we want reasonable laws
well wouldn't it be reasonable if
someone violates their rights that they
should actually have to pay some
consequence for doing so that is one of
the most reasonable things that
legislators could possibly come up with
it's accountability
and I think that this does provide that
we have the laws that do protect us from
overreach of uh you know the things that
are mentioned in here but uh you know
one example in particular there's a
recent rule you might have heard about
pistol braces uh now being considered
short power rifles and they are now
going to require a tax stamp and a long
process to go through millions of people
have them I even know a few that have
them and now those people are going to
be felons if they don't get the tax
stamp to pay for something they already
had something interesting about these
things they're not more lethal if
someone holds a short barrel rifle
they're actually a little less strong
because the long sort of the barrel the
less energy the bullet has when it comes
out so not necessarily more lethal they
might be more maneuverable but that is
actually something that is very useful
in a home situation for home defense is
also very helpful for people with
physical disabilities handicaps small
people of smaller stature the reason why
the braces were developed is because
some people have maybe a physical
difficulty holding it up now you might
say they don't deserve they shouldn't
have a firearm but there's something
that just need a reasonable
accommodation that's something we allow
people for all things in society
including surgery I was a surgeon I knew
stock doctors that couldn't do certain
things without having a reasonable
accommodation and they were allowed to
operate on people if they were given a
stool or a certain prosthetic to use of
some sort this is something that's very
important to people and I think it's
important to have a reasonable uh
consequence to violating someone's
rights so please pass this bill and uh
I'm not taking any questions it's late
thanks thank you for your testimony
Andrew Schiller
thank you for your patience
she said in my car anyways uh so
I would like to uh support this bill
uh there's too many infringements
generally with when
the government like the FED isn't
serving people
there's a little incentive to change
laws to serve the people and this
thought is used to force the guaranteed
to serve us and allow for
yeah net Firearms as a natural right as
this is the United States
and I the idea here was of course
or I support the forcing of the public
officials to be served and by allowing
other public servants like police to
suit Force the potential to uh I guess
can't take the punishment for having not
served the
people uh thanks that's all
thank you for your testimony
the chair recognizes otherwise
hi my name is still Aloo axelman I still
live in Hooksett
um I am speaking in support of house
bill 474. I think it's a great Common
Sense bill that would use a state law
to protect our natural rights to
property and self-defense and I think
it's great that representative Manion
put in some punishments in this bill
it's in the form of a civil cause of
action as opposed to criminal penalties
I think it's great um I don't think it's
too strong at all I think it's really
appropriate
that if law enforcement agents violate
their oath of office violate the natural
rights of the citizens they're sworn to
protect that there should be a civil
cause of action to send them in court
for violating our rights
so I urge you all to please support this
OTP
thank you very much I'm happy to take
questions
thank you for your testimony
chair recognizes
thank you chair and members of the
committee this bill also although I
support the concept I do not support the
language it also gets a black ribbon
and here's the problems that I see in
the law we have a saying it's called
sauce for the goose sauce for the gander
which means each side needs to be
treated equally
there are certainly a lot of bad law
enforcement I've had some retaliate
against me personally but
this does not make it clear will a
person of average intelligence what is
prohibited and just like we have to have
speed someone be speed limit Lines on
the Highway before we get pulled over
for a ticket law enforcement needs to
know what they can and can't do and I
think what's most important to me here
if any of you who followed the
exculpatory evidence schedule or the
Lori list there are certainly a lot of
officers that were put on it that I'm
not sure belonged on it and it was
politics because your supervisor could
put you on it
there are also a ton of officers that
need to be on it that aren't
and so when you look at for example
um 159e which is page 3 line 30.
I want bad law enforcement more than
anybody way more than anybody probably
but they get hearings they get due
process just like we do
and I don't think I think all of us in
order to have good law enforcement you
have to treat them fairly
and I think this bill is a wonderful
concept but it needs to be retained and
it needs to have a whole whole lot of
work done to it because we need more
specifics as to what you're prohibiting
and what you consider to be a violation
of our rights and I think there's a
wholeness that can be put together but
when you look at this
the way it is now the other and most
important thing which
um prosecutor is going to be assigned to
do this because if you don't assign them
prosecutors have absolute prosecutorial
discretion you won't have anybody
bringing charges and that's a problem
and I can think of Catherine Rogers when
she was the county attorney and she and
I agreed on little but one particular
time when Brian blackton's
camera was wrongfully seized short of
the State Police to return it to him
they refused her answer is who's going
to bring be bringing your felony cases
the Merrimack County boys
and so you have to look at that and you
have to say who specifically is going to
be responsible for that and will that be
a person who's willing to Buck the boys
in blue and do whatever the right thing
is but this is not clear it's not fair
to the police quite frankly
and coming out of my mouth people say
penny Dean saying that but I'm like I'm
for fairness
and I just don't think this is fair and
clear
thank you
thank you for your testimony to be clear
on your card you you mark support are
you good Amendment support with
amendments so as is not support and as I
would not support but support the
concept and support with amendments
because I support it but not in this
language because I don't think it's
workable and I would suggest a sponsor
wherever he is take advantage of free
legal advice and speak to people and
again it's a one thank you to the
sponsor and it's a good concept because
we all need to be treated fairly but I
just don't think it'll do what he wants
it to do
there he stands
anyone holding a pink crowd who hasn't
turned it in yet there ain't none
I hereby close the public hearing on
hb474 and we are going to take a
top nine minute break
huh
yeah but some people
okay
foreign
at this time I call or open the public
hearing on HB 512 and recognize
representative gerhardt in versus bill
thank you chairman members of the
committee
you guys are definitely put in overtime
tonight
Bill 512 would allow any firearm or
accessory that's made within and
ammunition it covers a lot of things
made within the confines of the State of
New Hampshire to not be subject to
Federal jurisdiction
so I was going to take a different tact
because I have a feeling that the people
behind we're going to cover the whole
gun rights aspect of this and just go
into how the federal government actually
claims ownership over things that happen
within a state so in 1940
1942 to be specific there was a farmer
in Ohio Roscoe filburn he produced a
greater quantity of wheat than what
Congress had allowed under the
agricultural adjustment act they were
trying to stabilize the price of wheat
so he grew 23 Acres
which was double what he was allotted by
the powers that ought not be
so writing through unanimous Supreme
Court
they found that the Commerce Clause
gives Congress the power to regulate
prices in the industry and this law was
rational rationally related to that
legitimate goal okay he pointed out that
filburn would not have needed to buy
wheat if he had not used his own wheat
for personal consumption so this man did
not sell any Wheat over state lines he
simply fed it to us his livestock and
they claimed I'll finish up he pointed
over would have needed to buy wheat if
he had not used his own wheat for
personal consumption
so his choice still affected the
national economy and Interstate Commerce
by removing a buyer from the market
so my whole argument would be
it's absurd why is the federal
government have the ability to tell us
what we can own in this state if we as a
legislature choose to Outlaw certain
guns or accessories or whatever it may
be let's do it fine let's have the
debate here and figure it out but to to
delegate that authority to a bunch of
unelected bureaucrats because what's
been going on with the ATF they say oh
this is legal today that's not illegal
they didn't want to go raid people's
houses with no not warrants that bill is
coming up tomorrow but the point being
is I think we need to really
well first off breathing Hampshire State
Constitution Article 7 State sovereignty
and just say okay this is our state
people within the state they want to
produce a gun within the confines of the
state
it's subject to this state's
jurisdiction not the federalism so I had
probably not going to have any questions
but I'll take some
okay
thank you for your testimony
chair Rick has recognized Tom mannion
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Tom minion
Hillsboro One Pelham I'm here here to
speak and support of hb512 the one thing
we did cover my testimony is covering a
lot of the exact same ground with the
the filburn case I do believe that
that's the impetus of a lot of the
problems that we're seeing from the
federal government where they just
assume that because anything could
potentially ever be sold across state
lines it is now covered by the
interstate commerce clause I completely
disagree with this interpretation I
think it's important now that we uh
states with the current makeup of the
scotus that we do begin to reevaluate
this activist judged behavior from
almost a century ago that has given us
the monster Behemoth that is the federal
government that we see today uh so I'm
here speaking in in support OTP uh HP
512 and I'm willing to take any of your
questions
thank you for your testimony
the chair calls William Rogers
when I finally get his name right
and she and chair calls Dr Leonard corn
the chair calls Andrew Schuler
thank you again for inviting me
um so I think I support this bill
um I think that the federal firearms
laws especially NFA are arbitrarily
enforced to see the recent ruling with
the pistol brace Rule and I think that
New Hampshire citizens should have an
option to opt out of Interstate Commerce
and therefore these Federal Regulations
as long as they the full in
use of the Second Amendment or yeah
resuming right two is the Second
Amendment if within the state of New
Hampshire shouldn't use federal
regulations and the current regulations
because there's arbitrarily
unfortunately
it curates felons out of your neighbors
and friends and family and there's
nothing you can do about it
and I'd also like to say that one part
of the NFA you know it mentions all of
the weapons well anything can be level
up into some creativity and intent so
instead of trying to just immediately
make everything government regulated
free New Hampshire residents from this
over regulation I think that's all I had
to say
thank you for your testimony chair calls
Dr Johanna
uh thank you for hearing me today Joe
Gunners New Hampshire this is everybody
after five o'clock version of testifying
uh we're in support of the bill
uh I think it's very important that uh
we we realize that this is as needed as
this bill is it's going to be a very
limited scope it's got to be
manufactured in New Hampshire for actual
Firearms accessories are a little
different in the bill but uh it's you
know we're not gonna have to more you
know
um pull the iron out of the ground
ourselves and get the ore but you're
gonna have to make everything from the
raw materials uh that's a very intensive
process but it's actually a very
exciting process for New Hampshire
there's a lot of potential business and
development opportunities this could uh
could bring about and made New Hampshire
is something that we're very proud of uh
you know I'm wearing limber boots from
up and up in you know the White
Mountains they're the oldest boot in the
country right you should try them but um
anyway I I'm I think you should really
consider passing this the only uh
comment I would make is uh and I'm not
against it but I think you know I'd be
willing to bend on the the penalty parts
of Class A misdemeanor and class B
felony I think like I said before
punishments are definitely something
they're needed but I'm not sure seven
years in prison is the acceptable
response some people may differ uh but
there should be some penalties but um
I'm up for negotiation if these are
something that would be sticking points
for some some members thank you and good
night
thank you for your testimony and the
chair calls
um William Rogers
I support this bill I I think New
Hampshire made firearm to be a great
thing and that we should regulate it in
state and completely out of federal
control thank you
thank you the chair calls Dr corn
thank you again for
uh being here for this long day so
I don't think we should give a free pass
to any manufacturer
whether due to faulty guns or faulty
cars
or anything that's fought the nor should
we allow any manufacturer to falsely
advertise
and promote products that malfunction
and cause harm
and so I don't think we should give a
pass to a company that makes
a firearm or a firearm accessory in New
Hampshire if it's malfunctions
we should
insist that all products made in New
Hampshire uh function properly
guns killed and it's obviously important
that gun manufacturers produce safe guns
and safe devices and this law would
allow
great exceptions to that basic principle
thank you very much
thank you for that testimony
representative Granger
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee the interstate commerce clause
has been abused for a very long time
this bill does something very small to
help Granite State businesses operate
smoothly in an area where federal
government tries its darndest to usurp
the power of the states it wields the
interstate commerce clause like a
sledgehammer everything that can
potentially be bought or sold May
apparently be regulated by the federal
government their army of bureaucrat
stands ready to tell everyone what to do
at all times unless States come in and
protect their citizens and their
businesses this bill would protect New
Hampshire firearm manufacturers from an
enormous amount of bureaucracy we love
our local businesses every dollar they
spend on compliance is another dollar
they have to they can't spend on our
Workforce this bill doesn't spare them
the wrath of regulators when the
manufacturers export their products to
other states therefore any firearms
company that wishes to have Safe
products that are sold in other states
they will be making sure that their uh
their products are safe uh you guys are
probably eager to get out of dive so
I'll leave with that thank you very much
thank you for your testimony the chair
calls aloha
hi thank you my name is still Olu
axelman I still live in Hooksett
um I'm speaking in support of house bill
512. I think it's a simple bill that
just reasserts our 10th Amendment type
states rights that the state is supposed
to be Sovereign as per article 7 of the
New Hampshire Constitution like a few
others alluded to today the federal
government for decades now maybe 100
years has been using the Commerce Clause
in the Constitution
to say they can control everything in
the universe and here's how the Supreme
Court ruled in wickard versus filburn
like 80 years ago that even if a person
uh grows grain wheat on his own property
feeds it to his own cows because
theoretically he's feeding us cows from
his own grow and not buying it from the
neighboring state because he lived on
the border of Iowa and Nebraska or
something technically the price of the
market of wheat could be affected
because he's growing his own therefore
anything in the universe that could
affect any price of anything ever
could be interstate commerce because it
affects prices and I think wicker versus
Phil Burton which might have been the
most Broad and terrible Supreme Court
case in history of existence
um but there are a lot to choose from
that was one of the worst things and
that's what allowed the federal
government to say anything is Commerce
If I Grow something if I collect my own
rain water and I buy less Poland Spring
from Maine I'm affecting the price and
it's interstate from New Hampshire
domain so it's obviously Preposterous
any three-year-old with 12 brain cells
understands that it's way too far and
this pushes back a little bit on this
Commerce Clause by saying things made in
the state by Ruger or Sig Sauer kept in
the state and carried by me my Sega my
hip the federal government should have
zero involvement at all there's there's
no justification for it and it'll be a
violation it was half Amendment and
under the use of their Converse clause
which I reject so thank you very much
I'm happy to take questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
chair calls Joshua el-barre
thank you take two and my name was much
better this time
I am speaking in support of this house
bill 512. and I wanted to say I
generally on principle it is my firm
belief that any laws restricting guns
accessories Etc is a violation of the
Constitution but let's think even more
just practically for a moment as many of
others have alluded already a lot of
federal gun laws are
ill-informed at best and schizophrenic
at worst you know a law can be passed
with no grandfathering Clause that turns
millions of law-abiding people
suddenly into criminals they can't even
go and you know address the law
themselves already there are Criminal
there are all sorts of laws that are not
based in any real science or reason for
example silencers have all sorts of
restrictions and rules on them and are
outright and illegal in many places
silencers realistically are a tool to
preserve people's hearing when they're
shooting
um
I don't know if people think that
Hollywood and video game rules apply to
these things where it's you can simply
shoot somebody and someone five feet
away has no clue that is certainly
ridiculous to me and there's all sorts
of things like this in the legal code if
you look so I think the people of New
Hampshire Pride themselves on being free
there are certainly a culture of Freedom
vis-a-vis guns and other things in this
state it's one of the reasons that I
moved six months ago and I simply do not
wish to be under the purvey of the
federal government that can arbitrarily
impose whatever they like at any time
it's ridiculous
um I'm a little surprised it's taken
this long to kind of bring this up so I
very much support this Bill thank you
for your time
thank you for your testimony
chair calls James Gaffney
for the last time today I believe I hope
so
until Friday I guess
um I support the bill I won't believe
belabor the points over and over again
enough's been said thank you
thank you for your testimony and the
chair calls Penny Dean
I support this bill and I ask you vote
ought to pass this is fundamental
fairness for gun owners gun
manufacturers and dealers let me tell
you just about three basic things Native
Americans had a term he speak with fork
tongue and what that basically means is
people lied and changed their mind and
went back on their deals
here's why that matters there's three
recent things in our lifetime that's
happened to gun owners in this state
with the ATF
street sweepers FRG triggers and bump
stacks
the man who initially
or men and companies who initially
marketed each one of those got what I
call a good boy letter from the ATF they
submitted it to the ATF the ATF said
this is how we characterize it
and then the next thing you know the ATF
said for example when it came to bump
stocks you can thank anti-gun president
Trump for this one
they said when it came to bump Stacks oh
no these are full Autos now they had a
letter an opinion nothing hadn't changed
on them other than politics
they have the FR tree triggers right now
people paid three to five hundred
dollars for those triggers
yeah and anyone who has one lately has
been getting letters from the ATF that
says either forfeit them or we're going
to come arrest you and seize them I have
plenty of clients with those letters
because they went to the manufacturing
the seller of those and seized all their
records so they knew they sent them to a
person a and person B and person C sent
them letters
and if you don't do the right thing when
you turn them over to the ATF meaning
the proper legal things
you lose your right to get them back if
there's any lawsuits or anything that
matters I have several cases of those
going right now and the clients know
Freedom isn't free and to handle each
okay we should talk in thousands of
dollars for 350 or 340 thing but for
those clients it's principal they're not
going to turn over products
without having a chance to get them back
but if you see the ATF at your door and
they say you give it to us now or we're
coming to your house we're taking it and
we're charging with a felony that's
pretty scary and you're like wait a
minute here's a letter yeah we rescinded
that letter years later oh is there a
trick are you no we just rescinded it
there's no explanation it's called Tough
Luck Chuck those are just three examples
street sweepers they gave people 30 days
to register them which they went from a
title one time oh title three thank you
very much so please vote this ought to
pass thank you
anyone else have pink crowd who hasn't
testified
with that I will close the public
hearing on HP 512 I'd like to first of
all thank the members
um for staying so late I'd like to thank
the legislative staff who have stayed
here to ensure this video keeps working
and the lights are on and that we are
here safe and I'd like to thank all the
citizens who took time out of their day
to come here today and exercise their
civil rights and I wish you all good
night
if